hello everyone welcome to this java full
course from simply learn
before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies if you
are a tech gig in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's discussion
in the first segment that is the core
java we will understand how to install
java install eclipse in our local
systems followed by that we will have
the fundamentals that is the data types
in java data conversion arrays and java
operators in java and followed by that
will have the control statements in java
moving forward we will discuss the data
structures in java next we have the loop
statements in java then java collections
java streams access modifiers in java
inheritance encapsulation
and next we will discuss the abstract
classes in java interface in java
polymorphism in java static keyword
exception handling in java and finally
to sum up the core concepts in java we
will try to create a calculator project
based on core java concepts now moving
ahead we will discuss some of the
advanced java concepts that we will be
discussing in this particular tutorial
the topics in advanced java are
enumeration in java annotations in java
serialization in java multi-threading
synchronization auto boxing input and
output strings in java moving ahead we
have java database connections generics
in java java.lang and java.util
concurrency utilities regular
expressions and advancing ahead we will
have the spring frameworks spring mbc
and finally we will have spring and rest
api and also to make things more
interesting we will have spring boot
project at the end i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda now over to our
training experts let's get started with
installing java we will basically look
at how we can install java on a windows
machine so the first step to install
java is to download it from the official
oracle website so for that let's open a
web browser and let's type jdk
java download and hit enter then you
need to find the link which says
oracle.com because like we discussed in
the previous lecture uh java is owned by
oracle so we need to download it from
the official website only so we can
click on this link which says java se
downloads it will bring us to the
downloads page and we will see different
versions of java you can see the java sc
15 you can see java se14 you can also
see java se11 and all the previous
versions
under another thing which you will
notice that it says lts here which means
long term support basically long term
support are the releases for which
oracle is going to provide
long term security patches and updates
for the non lts releases java will not
provide long-term support and long-term
patch fixes and long-term security fixes
so it's a good idea to analyze and
evaluate on which version you want to
develop your applications on for this
demo i think it is fine we can go with
the non lts version and even for your
for your customer facing applications
you can start with the non lts version
and then upgrade to the latest lts
version whenever that is available so
for this demo we can download java se15
and you can also do the same on your
machine it will work exactly the same
way as an lts works
so you can click on the jdk download
option here
let's click on that it is going to bring
up the downloads detail page and you can
see uh there are multiple options given
here uh in terms of what platform you
want to install java on whether it is a
linux platform or it is a mac os machine
or it is a windows platform so like i
said in the beginning of the demo that
today we are going to see how we can
install this on a windows machine so i'm
going to download the windows x64
installer here if you are working on a
linux machine or a macos machine you can
download those respective installers as
well so you can see the exe here so
let's click on this
once we click on this we'll get this
pop-up which will ask us to accept the
oracle technology network license
agreement
so we can hit this check box
and click on download jdk 15 and this
shall start the download and you will
see some some exe getting downloaded in
your download box here but as the
download is going to take some time and
uh i'm not going to wait for that and
that's the reason i have already
downloaded the jdk 15 for this
particular demo and that jdk is is
sitting here on my desktop which i have
downloaded prior to this demo so we'll
just run this particular exe which is
exactly the same exe as the one which is
being downloaded so let us double click
on this it will ask you for this pop-up
in some cases so you can just hit yes
basically it is asking whether you trust
this exe or not but as we downloaded
this from official oracle website then
we can trust this particular exe so i
will hit yes
and now the installer is going to unpack
and you might get a screen like this
which will be an installation result for
the java sc development kit 15. another
thing which before i proceed i just
wanted to highlight that as well that
you might have noticed about jdk here
it's exactly the same term which we
covered in the last lecture that when
you install java you basically install
the jdk which is the java development
kit and this is also visible here when
it says java sc development kit 15. so
let's hit next then on this particular
page you have the option to change the
installation location of java if you
want to by default it is going to
install in c program files slash java
slash jdk 15 but if you want to change
the location and you want to install
java to a particular custom location of
your choice that is also possible you
just hit change here and then you can
choose whatever directory or folder or a
place you want to install this
java on and you can
basically select the appropriate
location for this particular case i
don't want to change that i'm happy with
the default location which is available
here so i'm just going to proceed with
this particular location here so i will
just hit next
and then java is going to install and
it's it's very fast installation it
generally takes few seconds as you will
see in this demo basically it is going
to unpack all the all the libraries and
all the runtime libraries and all the
class path libraries which we discussed
in the previous lecture and put all that
into the location which we specified to
install java it will also set up the
rest of the prerequisites which are
required to run java successfully so
looks like the java has been
successfully installed as is visible in
this message and there's also a next
step if you want to
access the tutorials or the api
documentations the developer guides the
release notes etc i don't want to do
that so i will just hit close here and
now if we want to just verify if java is
uh is installed or not then we can
verify that from the command line prompt
let me just exit this
and let's go to the command prompt to
verify to see if java has been
successfully installed so to do that
we'll we'll just open the search bar and
we'll type cmd
it is going to show us this command
prompt here we'll click on this
and it will open the command prompt for
you like it has opened for me and there
you just need to type
java hyphen version and you hit enter if
you get a message like this it means
java has been successfully installed if
you get a message saying that java is
not recognized as a command it means
that java is still not successfully
installed and something has gone wrong
in your installation and in that case
you might want to restart you might want
to go back and reinstall this java exe
again so in this case it looks like it
has been successfully installed and we
can also get some interesting
information from here we can see which
version of java has been installed it
says java version 15
we can also see that the jre is also
installed the java sc runtime
environment or jre is also installed and
we can also see that the jvm is also
installed which is java hotspot server
vm vm means the virtual machine so if i
connect this back to the previous
lecture we can see that
the java jdk basically installed the jre
as well as the jvm as well and the
complete java package has been
successfully installed
now we are ready to use java
a java program and run java programs on
this machine let's get started with
installing eclipse on a windows machine
so the first thing which we need to do
is to download eclipse so for that i'm
just going to open my web browser and
type
eclipse
download
press enter and then you need to find
the link which says
eclipse.org
downloads which is the first link in my
search results you can also see it says
eclipse downloads the eclipse foundation
and eclipse foundation is the one is the
organization which maintains the eclipse
installers so we can click on this once
we click on this we will be redirected
on to the eclipse downloads page and
there again you will see bunch of
options you will see the default option
highlighted which would be the eclipse
installer for uh for jre for mac os
windows and linux and then you have some
other tool platforms option as well like
eclipse g or oreon which you might want
to use for advanced cases but for
running java applications all you need
is an eclipse installer which is coming
from here so based on your machine
eclipse will automatically detect
whether you want a 64-bit installer or a
32-bit installer and you can just click
on this particular link which says
download 64-bit here so i'm just going
to hit download 64-bit it is going to
open this particular screen where based
on your current location eclipse will
suggest the nearest possible
distribution mirror distribution mirror
is basically a server which is present
somewhere
in this world which contains this
eclipse installer exe and eclipse has
created these servers all across the
globes these servers are basically
called the mirrors and based on your
current location which will be deducted
taken taken from your isp from the
internet ip address from which you are
accessing this particular website so
based on your isp location it is going
to suggest you the nearest possible
mirror location so that your download is
the fastest so in my case the nearest
location is netherlands here as you can
see and i get a download option this is
the file name which says eclipse
installer jre windows64.exe
and if you think that this mirror
doesn't make sense just click on this
option select another mirror and then
you can choose another mirror but
generally it works really well it works
based on it works based on your ip
location and it's generally uh the
download speed is pretty good based on
the suggested mirror so i'm not going to
change the mirror location because i
think this works fine for me so and i'm
just going to click on this particular
button which is going to start the
download of the eclipse installer so now
i have i have hit the download button
and you can see right now an exe has
been download has begun to download uh
it is going to again take some time and
i have already downloaded this
particular exe just to save us some time
and i'm going to use that exe to
showcase how we can install it another
thing just wanted to highlight is that
eclipse is an open source organization
it works on donations so if you feel
generous about it and if you feel that
eclipse is doing really great work you
can also donate to it which will show
here so we can move to the next step
which is about installing so you can see
here i have an installer here an exe
file basically which i have
pre-downloaded to showcase this demo i'm
just going to double click on this and
it is going to unpack the installer you
can see this this icon will be presented
to you which says eclipse installer by
oomph oomph is basically the provider
for this particular installer who
manages the installer and based on your
computer's capacity and speed it is
going to take few seconds and
in the background what it is doing is
basically it is unpacking this installer
and creating all the installation files
which it needs to successfully install
it on your computer once that is done
you will be presented with this kind of
screen and you will see that eclipse
provides multiple different kind of ides
for different set of developer
communities you will see an option which
says eclipse ide for java developers you
will also see eclipse ide for enterprise
java developers you will see the ide for
c plus plus and c developers web and
javascript php eclipse committers who
basically contribute to the eclipse
organization or
rcp rap tester scientific computing
there are tons of ides which eclipse
maintains for our use case throughout
this series i think we will be focusing
on this particular ide which says
eclipse ide for enterprise java
developers you can also use this
particular ide but this is a very bare
bone ide with very limited set of
integrations like it says it includes a
java ide a git client an xml editor a
maven plugin and a gradle plugin but if
you look at the enterprise you will get
more integrations you can use this
particular ide to work on whatever you
work here so these all will work here
but in addition you can also use this
ide to build a web application build a
web service build a jpa application data
tools java server pages faces etc so
this is more uh more advanced i would
say and we will go with this particular
ide and
you can also choose this id if you want
to but for this demo we are going to
choose this one i will click on this
then it is going to show me which
virtual machine it is going to use so if
you remember in the previous lecture we
installed java 15 it has automatically
detected that location by reading my c
program files folder and it has
automatically taken that if you have
multiple jdk installations on your
machine you can click on this icon and
change a different java virtual machine
i'm going to leave it as is again the
installation folder is also by default
taken to your c users user name slash
eclipse slash the jee
version number and again if you want to
change this you can also change a
different installation folder i'm going
to leave everything as default it will
automatically create a start menu entry
and a desktop shortcut and now i hit
install it might come
ask you for a user agreement so you can
hit accept now and now it has begun the
installation the installation generally
takes a bit of time to complete in some
cases so again it depends upon your in
your computer's capacity and speed
basically if it's a good robust machine
with with good capacity the installation
might be very fast as you can see in my
computer and if you have a computer
which is not very strong on
configurations you can just be patient
and wait for some time and the
installation will be finished once the
installation is finished you will see
this launch option here you will also
have an option to keep an installer if
you want to show the readme file but i
think the the main option here which we
are going to use is the launch option so
if you hit the launch option now the
actual ide is going to start up it's
again going to set up some configuration
files and some bootstrap configuration
files which it needs to and then it will
ask you to choose a workspace again
workspace is up to you where do you
where you want to create your workspace
the workspace is basically the location
where you
you will create your projects it will
store those project files and the source
code of those projects so it is up to
you where you want to create it again
i'm going to leave it as default here
but if you want to change it just hit
browse here and choose whatever location
you want to you can see you can choose
you can go to pc and you can choose
whatever location you want to i'm going
to leave it as is and you also have a
choice that you don't want eclipse to
ask this every time so you can check
this box and next time eclipse is not
going to ask you to choose a directory
as workspace and every time you start
eclipse it will automatically go to this
particular directory so you can either
check it or uncheck it based on your
convenience and hit launch once you hit
launch it is going to start the actual
ide as a desktop application and you
will get a nice interface and a welcome
screen from eclipse which will which
will basically show the basic uh
overview of the screen something like
this
so now you can see that the eclipse id
has started it has a welcome page which
has multiple options you can check out a
project from git you can import an
existing project you can go to the
marketplace create a java web project or
whatever or you can just close this you
have a nice navigation project
project explorer bar here so all the
projects which you are going to create
will be listed here there are also some
quick shortcuts here for creating
different kind of projects and if you
don't want to use that just go to file
new and choose a kind of project you
want to create whether it is a maven
project or enterprise application
project or dynamic web project or just a
project if you just hit just a project
you can choose a basic java project to
start with click next give a project
name let's call it test demo you can
choose an execution environment here
that the jre and currently this
particular ide has support up to 14 but
i think this is going to work fine we
don't need to worry about it we can also
use a project specific jre like in this
case java 15 which is the current
installation so i can use this option
because i want to use java 15
environment because i have java 15
installed so you can basically choose
whatever option you want to choose it
gives you flexibility in terms of
choosing the gre whether you want to
choose an external gre whether you want
to choose a project specific jre or you
want to use the default gre jdk
installation so you can use this option
as well if you want to project layout is
great either you want to create separate
folders for source and classes or you
want to create the use the project
folder again this is these are just
basic configurations which you can play
around with if you want to i'm just
going to leave it as is and hit next and
then it is going to just give me a
review screen here if i want to change
anything i can otherwise i can just hit
finish
i can create a module name here if i
want to but i don't want to create it so
just hit on don't create and open the
java perspective
and that's it you have a java project
here where you can create your java
files under this src and you can start
executing those files let's get started
with primitive data types in java we are
going to learn about the primitive data
types in java and we'll also see a short
demonstration of it
so let's get started let's first just
learn about those uh data types i've
just opened the official
oracle documentation and don't worry if
you see how this link appears here you
can just open a browser window and just
type java primitive data types and if
you hit enter the first link which you
will be given is this particular link
and this is the same link which i have
opened so let's learn about the data
types now so java has
these primitive data types which you can
see here some of them store numbers some
of them store boolean values and some of
them store characters so the data types
which store numbers are byte short int
long float and double
these six data types basically are used
to store any kind of numeric value let's
understand these a bit more byte is the
shortest possible data type value which
you can use in java to store numbers you
can only store numbers within the range
of minus 128 to plus 127. so you can see
the range is very small and java has
created this variable for use cases
where you want to store numbers which
have very small value in this range why
do we provide these kind of options just
to save memory because the smaller data
type will require less memory to be used
in the java program similarly the next
bigger data type is short which is a bit
bigger than byte and the range of this
particular data type where
variables will range from -3 to 678 to
plus three two seven six seven so that
is the range for this particular
variable and you can see that it says it
has a very big range as compared to the
byte data type so if you want to store
very uh values which lie in this range
you can use short the next one is int
data type you can use this one to store
even larger values which range from
minus 2 raised to power 31 to plus 2
raised to power 31 minus 1. the next one
is long which is even bigger than int
and it can be used to store the values
within the range of minus 2 raised to
power 63 to plus 2 raised to power 63
minus 1. so as you can see as we go from
top to bottom from byte to long the size
of the value which can be stored using
this data type increases and that's how
you will basically take a decision of
whether you want to use byte or you want
to use short or int or long based on
what size of the value that variable is
going to contain then the next ones are
float and double these two have been
created for the use cases whether where
you want to store the values numeric
values which have decimals which are
precision values i should also mention
that byte short int and long are only
used for storing absolute numbers which
do not have any decimal representation
even if you try to store a decimal value
in these variables they will
automatically be trimmed the decimal
values will automatically be removed and
you will only be
shown the absolute values
and in case of float and double
they can maintain those precision and
decimal values so we use float for the
use cases where you want to store
decimal representations of the values
and you can see that the float value can
store a smaller precision value but
double can store even a bigger precision
value so if you have really big
precision values to be maintained very
big decimal values to be maintained you
should use double and the float is used
for
storing a bit smaller size of the
precision values i mean its range of
values basically beyond the scope of
this discussion if you want to read more
about this you can go to this particular
links which will explain this in detail
but the basic idea is that float is good
for storing two precision values and if
you want to go beyond that you want to
use double in some cases some people
also use float to store even beyond two
values as well so it completely depends
the main the decision factor is how long
the value you are going to store in the
decimal and that will take the decide
whether you want to use float or double
the next one is boolean which is used
for storing the boolean values boolean
values can be either true or false so
there are only two possible values and
then we have care which is used for
storing characters it is using 16 bit to
store the value and this is a very
popular java question for beginner level
programmers that why does it store uh
need 16-bit to store the character it's
because it stores a unicode
representation unicode representation is
a representation which can be accepted
across platforms across the world in
different character encodings
so let's move on to eclipse now where i
have prepared a very short and simple
demo i'm just creating a variable for
each data type and i'm printing them
you also see some things here like
these keywords and don't worry about
these keywords i will cover these
keywords in detail in the upcoming
lectures you also see this and you can
just for now you can remember that
system.out.println is used for printing
anything in java anything you want to
print on the console you would be using
system.out.println
what is system what is out and what is
println again we will cover these in the
uh upcoming lectures
for now i'm just creating a bunch of
data types here variables here basically
i'm creating a cad type variable a byte
type variable a short type variable an n
type variable a float type variable a
double and a boolean the way you create
variables is basically you put the data
type name you put the variable name
which can be anything you put an equal
sign and you put the value actual value
which this variable is going to store
and i've done the similar thing for all
of these
variables java wants semicolons to be
there when you write your statements so
please remember that your statements
always end with semicolons so i've
declared all of these variables here a
byte a short and int float double and
boolean and then i'm printing all of
them basically here i'm printing the cad
variable here i'm printing the byte
variable here i'm printing the short and
so on so forth so how do we actually run
this application or this program we just
double click on this or right click on
this you go to this run as option you
see this run as java application option
so you can hit this option it will run
the application and it will present all
the output here in the console tab let
me just bring this up so you can see all
the variables have been printed here and
this is coming from these print
statements like i said this is used
system.out.println is used to basically
print anything and i've used that to
print all the variables here first i am
printing the carry variable whose value
is
a
then i am using the byte variable which
is denoted by b and whose value is 2 so
you can see the value is 2 here then i
am printing the third variable which is
c which is a short type variable which
has a value 22 you can see short and
this is coming here the next print
statement is int so you can see int here
with the value 45 and this value is
coming from here then we have float
we can see the float value being printed
here and you can see the float value
declared here you also see an f here and
this is the standard naming convention
with java proposes that whenever you
declare float and double you end them
with f or d based on whether it is float
or it is double then you see the double
value which is having which is having a
bigger precision than float so i have
printed the double value using
this particular print statement which is
printed here and then we have the
boolean value which is stored as g
and the value of g is true and the same
value is printed here so whatever i
write here basically is printed here
this is just a placeholder and this is
the actual value so you can see that we
are able to use all the variables here
all the primitive variables basically
which range from byte character byte
short int float double and boolean let's
get started with non-primitive data
types in java first of all let's
understand what is the difference
between primitive and non-primitive so
the primitive data types are the ones
which are by default supported by java
and non-primitives are the ones which
are a bit custom in nature where you as
developer have the liberty to define the
nature of that data type we'll look at
some examples of that as well but when
we talk about which all are the
non-primitive data types we broadly talk
about arrays we talk about classes we
talk about strings as well and we will
cover some of them in today's lecture
and we have the detailed lecture
upcoming about the classes as well in
fact in the in the after few lectures we
will cover how we'll create classes as
well but for today's lecture we are
going to focus on string data type and
array data type and like i said for
classes we have a dedicated lecture
upcoming so don't worry about that and
again for this particular case as well i
have already prepared a demo for this
and we'll basically do some look at some
hands-on examples to see how do we
create these variables what is what does
these variables mean and the first
non-primitive data type we are going to
talk about is string and before i go on
further i should also mention that it's
very debatable in the java community to
call string as a non-primitive data type
and actually technically speaking string
is a special data type it neither fully
lies in the primitive category nor it
fully lies in the non-primitive
categories i'm covering this as a
non-primitive data type because it's a
bit inclined towards the non-primitive
category why do we
do this is because java does provide
native support for string handling in
the jdk and that's the reason some of
the developers feel that string is a
primitive data type which is primitively
supported by java but at the same time
string is so customizable and it's so
special in nature it's the way it stores
the value the way it provides the
operations and handlings it's so
different than primitive data types that
it cannot fully be put in the same
bucket as the primitive data types so
that's why i said it's it's a special
data type a bit inclined towards the
non-primitive category so what is string
basically we covered about the cad data
type in the previous lecture and in cap
data type you can only store a single
character right but if you want to store
a complete name of somebody then it's a
list of character it's basically lot of
characters together then in that case
you would need a data type to store that
continuous sequence of characters and
that's what string does string can store
a continuous sequence of characters
technically string is basically a
character array you can call string as a
character array and don't worry if you
don't understand about the word array i
will explain that in the same lecture so
basically it stores the continuous
sequence of characters that's how that's
how we define string and you see this
string this is a basically the keyword
the data type basically in java so
whenever you want to create a string you
need to write string with s capital you
need to give a name to the string this
can be anything and then you can provide
the value which is which this particular
string is going to contain so you can
see this is a continuous sequence of
characters t e s t are the four
characters which this string is going to
contain and after that again i'm
printing this particular value and like
i said don't worry about this we'll
cover this when we'll when we'll write
our first program in java so this is
just to print the string value i'm just
putting a string placeholder here and
then i'm actually printing the printing
the values of the string variable now
string can be created in multiple ways
in java this is one way of creating it
there's another way of creating a string
variable which is this one which says
again the string data type some variable
name a keyword called new again don't
worry about what is this new keyword
we'll cover this when we'll talk about
running our first program in java and
writing the first program from scratch
then we against a string and then we
provide the value so if i compare this
line number 4 to line number 7 you can
see the difference is that i'm still
storing the same value test but the
difference is that here there is no new
string keyword but here we have this new
string keyword so what is the difference
the difference is this that in this case
in this particular case
string is going to reuse the same object
multiple times but in this case every
time you call this it is going to create
a new object again what is object it's
just you can think of it as for now you
can think of it as a memory block we'll
again cover objects in details but these
are two different ways in which you can
create string this is generally the most
popular way of doing it because this is
memory efficient because you can reuse
the same variable again and again so i'm
creating the string variable here and
creating another string variable str1
here and printing both of them
then i've created this strange looking
thing here which is basically an array
array like i said is also an a
non-primitive data type in java and
array can store
a continuous sequence
of anything that anything can be a
number
that anything can be characters that
anything can be or a floating number as
well so basic idea is that if you want
to store a collection or a sequence of
multiple multiple
values how do you do that you do that
with the help of arrays array is a data
structure a non-primitive data structure
in java which can store lot of values of
similar type we also call it as
homogeneous data structure which because
it can only store same data type values
or homogeneous data type values
so the the biggest way to identify array
is this square bracket whenever you see
this square bracket in java it means
it's an it's an array variable so here i
am creating an integer array variable
with the name arr this is the name of
this particular array it is only going
to store integer values because of
specified int and the moment i provide
the square brackets it's mean it means
that it is an array so you can declare
an array like this and then you need to
assign a size to the array size is
basically denoting how many values
this data structure is going to store so
i'm saying new again it's a keyword and
i'm saying that okay create a
memory block for storing two integers so
this particular array arr can store at
max two values two values at continuous
locations the next thing about array is
that it stores the value in a zero index
base location so like i said it can
store two values so the first location
will always be array of zero and this is
how you specify the location or index
of the element which is going to be
stored so at the zeroth location of this
array i'm storing zero the first
location of the array i'm storing one
and this is just to show an error
scenario but i will just comment this
for now you can just put double slashes
and comment any line so i'm just storing
filling up this array for two values and
the two values location would be zero
index and first index these are just
continuous memory locations and we
denote those memory locations as zero
and one array indexes always start with
0 and i'm just putting some values here
you can put any values and then i'm
printing the whole array and i'm also
printing the first value of the array
and we'll see how this pans out and
we'll also see how we can change this so
now we are going to run this application
so i'll just go to run as and click on
run as java application and once i hit
that i get this output here so let's
understand this output the first one is
i'm just printing the string which has
the value test and you can see it has
printed here it is coming from this line
then the next line which is printed is
line number eight where i'm saying
another string str1 and str1 also had
the same value so you can see another
string has the same value and then
i have printed the array here the
complete array and you see this strange
value here it also tells us that if you
want to print the array then you cannot
just put the variable name and print it
the reason is because this is a
non-primitive data type and once you do
this it is basically printing the memory
footprint of this array the whole memory
location where this array is stored
that's why you see this strange looking
number which is the memory hash code and
if you want to print any particular
value or any particular element inside
this array then you can do that by
providing the index location of that
element so here i have said that print
the zeroth location element of the array
the zeroth location array element of the
array was zero so you can see the value
zero here let me put some other value
just to just for fun and show you how
this works so just change the values and
now let's see what do we get for array 0
you can see now i get value 3 because
now that at the 0th location the 3 value
is being stored and that is what is
being printed here we can also print the
first value i'll just go run as java
application you can see now the array of
first index is being stored which is
basically technically the second element
of the array but because array always
works on a 0 index based value format
that's why when we say array 1 the
second element is printed when i say
array 0 the first element is printed so
always remember that array is a 0 index
based collection or data structure
basically what happens if i do this
now
there is no third element in this array
because the array has the size only of
two elements and when i say air are of 2
which means i am trying to print the
third element in this array which does
not exist so let's see what happens in
that case
i get an exception exception is
basically an error i get an error saying
that index 2 is out of bounds for length
2 it means that the array length was
actually 2 and index 2 does not exist
remember it's saying index 2 not the
element 2. index 2 doesn't exist because
only index 0 and index 1 exist this
makes two elements and the actual size
is also 2. it does not have capacity to
store third element it does not have
third element location anywhere that's
why it complains that you are trying to
print a non-existing value let's get
started with how to write your first
program in java once you have created
your java project so your java project
might look like something like this you
will have an src folder here so and
under the src folder you see some some
namespaces sort of things created here
right we call these as packages and in
java you can think of package as
something which can group multiple
related artifacts together this is
simply a grouping mechanism i can say
it's a way to put all the related
artifacts to a particular business
problem into a certain place for example
if you are working in an e-commerce
application so you have you might have
created multiple java files for
let's say for checkout and then some
more java files for the
filters flow i would say then some other
java files for designing the
advertisements so you have multiple java
files and these java files now below
belong to these three different domains
so you want to group them together for
easy accessibility for referencing each
other files with the within the code so
if you want to achieve that kind of
flexibility you would group the checkout
code files into a single package you can
name it as checkout package then you can
similarly do the same thing for the
advertisement package and for the
filters package so similarly i have
created some packages here which you can
see you see a package here which says
are your github wikis panda hello world
and how do you create a package you just
right click on this so you go to the src
and you right click to go to new and
here you will see this option which says
package so you can just click on this
and write anything which you want as the
package name let's call it as test
package uh it says invalid because the
package is a keyword so it is not
allowing me to put package here but
let's call it test package one and you
can just click finish and you will see a
test package popping up here then you
can right click on this again go to new
and then you can create a java class now
what is a java class a class is
basically a blueprint for an object it's
basically the specifications of an
object like i covered in the very first
lecture everything in java is an object
or most of the things in java are object
i would say so object is basically an
instance of the class so let's say you
create a class for if i take the same
example of e-commerce you create a class
for writing the business logic of
checkout and then you create
instance of this particular class to
work for a particular customer order so
class is basically a blueprint it's the
specification it's the skeleton of the
object so once you click on this you can
create a class now eclipse is a pretty
smart ide it will provide you with bunch
of options on how you actually can
create a class what and it will also
provide use with some sensible defaults
for example it will automatically select
a source folder in your project which
you have created it will automatically
select a package in fact the currently
selected package and if you want to
change the package just hit browse and
choose any other package which you want
to choose so your your class file will
be created in that package then you can
provide a name to the class so let's
call it as
test
hello
world and you can see i have followed a
sort of a naming convention here the
first character i've kept it as capital
and then any other new world which is
coming in my class file name is also
capitalized so java would expect you and
it would encourage you to follow this
naming convention that whenever you are
creating a class always start with a
capital letter then small letters and
every new word you are writing can start
with a capital letter again java will
not throw an error if you don't do this
h capital or w capital but it's a good
practice the next thing is the modifier
we are going to cover the modifiers in
details in the in the upcoming lectures
but for now you can understand that
anything which is
marked as public is accessible to every
other java class in this whole project
that's the basic meaning of making a
class as public public as the name
suggests itself it means it's visible to
everyone you can select a super class
and again we'll talk about the super
class later but this is the java lang
object is the super class of all the
classes which are created in java again
interface is again an advanced concept
and there are some other interesting
defaults it provides whether for example
if you want to create a main method now
what is the main method we'll just cover
it in a while so i will not do that i
will leave everything as default and i
will click on finish so i have this new
file coming up here and you can see it
has automatically picked up the package
which i selected and it has also written
public class test hello world with a
starting and ending curly braces in the
previous lecture we covered about this
curly braces that all the code block
have to be in the curly braces whenever
you write a java class the very first
statement java would expect to have in
the class is package name so make sure
that you have package as a keyword and
then the actual package name as the
package name for that particular class
you can see the package follows a dot
convention and it always ends with a
semicolon like all the java statements
end with semicolon so that would be the
first thing which you will write in your
class second thing is the access
modifier of the class like i said you
want this class to be accessible to
every other file in this project then
you can mark this class as public the
next thing is the class keyword you need
to write this particular keyword as is
otherwise your class will not be
detected so you write this as class
then you write test hello world or
whatever name you want to write but make
sure that whatever public class name you
provide here that name should match with
the file name these two things should
match the file name and the class name
if they don't match you would experience
weird behaviors as the class will not be
compiled or class might not be able to
run etc so always make sure that
whatever file name you provide you
always have a class with that name in
your file so my class structure is is
ready but there's nothing here in this
class in fact you cannot you cannot even
execute this class because for executing
the class for executing any class in
java any class at all in java you would
need a main method in java main method
is the entry point method of the java
whenever you are trying to run any
application be it a very small or very
large java application you would always
and always need a main method in the in
the class in the project somewhere and
you need to tell the java uh runtime to
execute that class and then the class
will have a main method and the your
program will start executing so always
have a main method otherwise your
program will not execute and how do you
write the main method so you first write
public
then you write static
then you write void
and then you write me and then you
provide
a parameter to this method as this now
let's understand what did i actually
write here first keyword is public
because this method has to be public
because like i said java runtime needs
to be able to access this method so the
similar concept which applied on the
class is applied on this method as well
that the entry point method has to be
public otherwise java will not be able
to find this method so you need to make
this method exactly as public the next
keyword is static you again need to
write this keyword as is and the reason
we write static here is because we
we want to run this particular class
without creating an object of the class
static is again a keyword which we will
cover in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that whenever you
want to access
something within the class without
creating an object then you need to
create it as static the next is void
void is basically the return type of
this method the method name is main and
it has to be main it cannot be main one
or main two otherwise if you do that
java will not be able to run your
program because it will expect you to
write this particular method exactly as
what i have written here no changes at
all should be there if you make any
changes java program will not run
because it will not be able to find the
entry point method which is the main
method so public static void main
remember that you need to have this in
your program so white is the return type
which means that this particular program
it will not return anything back to the
runtime because a method can have this
capability to either return something or
not return something for example a
method which can uh add two numbers will
return the result of addition right so
we return the result return is the word
here in this case this method is not
expected to return anything because
there is nobody consuming it right java
runtime will not do anything with the
with the return value of this particular
method that's why java will force you to
write void here and main is the exact
method name which you need to use java
will expect you to supply a string array
argument if we covered arrays in bit
detail in the in the in the previous
lectures and we will cover arrays in
actually in the next lecture in very
detail but you can as we discuss that
array is basically a sequence of
characters or words or integers or
anything right so in this case this is
basically the mandatory parameter which
you need to write as is this parameter
name can be anything obviously it can be
a rg args or whatever you want to write
it as but the basic fundamental is that
java will basically supply all the
command line arguments using this
particular string array that's why you
need to provide this then let's write
something in the program because this is
a hello world program so i will just
write
system
dot out dot print ln and i'll type a
string here which says
hello
world and a semicolon so again i have
been saying that i will explain this and
now i will explain this why do we need
this and what does this mean so as i
have told earlier that whenever you want
to print something on the console in a
java program you need to write
system.out.println now system here if
you just go if you just hover over it
eclipse will show what it is so system
is basically a class which contains
several useful class fields and methods
it cannot be instantiated means you
cannot create an object of it and it
provides many facilities like
standard input standard output and error
output
exactly what we want to focus here
because we want to
use system class to print something on
the standard output the standard output
in this case is the console so if you
want to input something or you want to
output something or you want to output
an error then you need to use system
class and all of these standard input
standard output and error are streams
and that's what comes to the next word
what is this out how it is a stream to
print standard output similarly we have
system dot e r r which is for printing
the error output streams similarly we
have system dot in for taking its
standard input streams so system dot in
system dot out system dot er these all
are these in out and err are streams and
then print ln is the actual method let's
hover over that let's first see out here
so you can see this is a stream object
which is used to print anything which is
ready to accept output data basically
and then we go to the println method and
it says print a string and then
terminate the line so like i mentioned
earlier as well this whole syntax is
used to print and actually this is the
core method this is the real method
which prints something on the console so
system class uses the output stream to
print something on the console using the
help of println method there is also a
print method so there are two methods
one is print and one is println the
difference is that in case of print
method the print method will not provide
you or terminate on a next line but in
system.println
the ln means line here it will print
something and it will bring the cursor
to the next line if you do not use this
and if you again use another print
statement then both of the statements
will be printed on the same line i will
show that as well but
and then we provide any random string
here which we want to print so you right
click on this particular program you go
to run as and you run as java
application and you want to save this so
we can say always save resources before
launching and you see the output here so
this is how you can run your first java
program now let's also see the
difference between
system.out.println and system.out.print
so i will just copy this here and i'll
say hello world 1 let's say and this
time i will not use system.out.println
but i will use
system.out.print
just put a space here so that it's
visible so if i use print how does that
look like i go to run and i go to run as
java application so now you see both of
the outputs are printed on the same line
there is no this output hasn't gone to
the next line and now if i run the same
program with
system.out.println methods now both of
these outputs will be divided on two
lines the first output then a line break
the hello world one goes to the next
line in the previous run the hello world
one was printing right next to it on the
same line so that is the difference
so this is how you can build your very
first program the hello world program in
java let's get started with arrays in
java we discussed about arrays uh in a
bit detail when we talked about the
non-primitive data types but this is a
concept and a topic which needs to be
understood well so that's why we'll go
we'll do a deep dive on arrays in this
particular lecture so as i described
earlier that array is basically a
container which can store values or a
sequence of values or sequence of
numbers or sequence of characters into
itself we can think of it as a box which
can store all the values in a continuous
fashion as you can see here this is a
just a pictorial representation and this
is coming from the official java docs
and you can see that we if we create an
array of size 10 then we have these 10
blocks created here you can see 1 to 10
so the whole length of boxes the number
of boxes here are 10 but the way arrays
are designed is that the index index is
basically used to access the element in
this particular box the index of the
boxes start from zero so it goes from
zero to nine so remember the array
length is ten it array and the array can
contain ten elements but the index of
the array starts with 0 and will always
end at length minus 1 which is 10 minus
1 in this case which comes as 9 so it
will always be length minus 1 it will
always the index will always start from
zero and go till length minus one length
can be anything in this case the length
is 10 so the index ends at nine if the
length was 20 the last index will be 19
but in total you have these 10 memory
locations we also call them as
continuous memory locations because they
are continuously placed and array
basically blocks 10 memory locations and
creates a container over it so this is
how an array basically looks like inside
the memory and
whenever you want to access the elements
of the array you will say array of 0 or
array of 1 or array of 2 you basically
need to specify the index to access the
element at index for example if you want
to access the element which is sitting
in this box you need to say array of
index 8 and we'll see how we can do that
but this is the basic understand
understanding an idea of the concept of
arrays so let's try to understand this
with the help of an example i will
switch back to eclipse ide and i've
created a very simple program here to
demonstrate the functionality of arrays
here so
we already covered in the previous
lecture of what is package and what is
public and what is class how do we give
the class name and what is the meaning
of this particular method so i'm not
going to cover that again we'll start
directly from here so here the first
thing which i'm doing is i'm declaring
an array of integer this is a variable
name the identifier basically it can be
anything and this is the data type it's
an integer array and as we as we covered
this as well that whenever you put
square bracket in front of a data type
it becomes an array data type so this is
an integer array representation now we
just declared an array but we still
haven't allocated a size to it so you
can do that with this particular
syntax so you can put the variable name
of the array and say new int and put the
right size here this size can be
anything and once you do this now array
will actually allocate those memory
boxes which we covered here but the
moment you do new int 10 this box these
boxes continuous boxes will be placed in
the memory and the memory is allocated
to this array we call this memory
allocation this is how you allocate
memory to the array so we allocated
memory to this array for storing 10
integers the next thing is now we can
start storing elements in those boxes so
like i said that the array index always
starts with zero so if you have to store
the first element you actually have to
store it at index 0 location so you give
the array name you provide these square
brackets and you put the index value
within the square brackets that is how
you basically point to a particular
element inside the array so we say an
array of zero and we put the value
hundred then we initialize the second
element which will be index one then
will be the third element which will be
index two fourth element index three
fifth element index four sixth element
index five and so on until we store till
the last element so this is the tenth
element which is accessible as index
nine and the value is uh thousand
basically so from 100 to thousand we
stored 10 values in this array and we
stored them by accessing the index and
this is actually the only way you can
store values in the array by pointing to
the indexes so we go from 0 to 9 and we
stored all the values 0 being the first
element and array of nine being the last
and the tenth element remember the
length minus one concept okay so now we
will try to print all the elements one
by one that's pretty much what we are
doing now so as we covered in the
previous lecture that we use
system.out.println to print anything and
we understood the whole meaning of this
so i'm not going to repeat that now
we want to print the first element the
first element is sitting at index 0 and
we can access that element with this
syntax by providing the variable name
and the actual index value so i'm just
writing a random string here which says
element at index 0 and then i'm putting
this plus here and putting the variable
name this plus is basically used to
concatenate the output of a static
string with a random variable or
basically you can print anything uh with
using plus plus is used for
concatenation so i'm just trying to
print this whole value but here this is
a string value which is a static string
and then i have a value coming from the
array so whenever you have to print some
value from a particular data type or
variable or collection then you can use
this plus syntax to concatenate a string
static string with your actual value so
that's what i've done here by saying
plus and array 0 and similarly for index
1 i'm printing the
the first index then for 2 3 so far and
so on so forth till the index 9 so
basically i'm just printing the all the
values of the array starting from index
0 to index 9 so that's all which which
is written in this program now let's try
to run this program so i will right
click go to run as and go to java
application and hit on this and now if i
just expand this console you can see all
the system.out.printer and statements
have been executed and they printed this
so this is the static screen a string
part in fact including the colon this is
the static string part element in index
0 printing exactly as is and then
dynamically the zeroth index element of
an array is printed here similarly we
have printed the index one location
element index two location element index
three location element and so on so
forth till the index nine location
element so in total these are the ten
elements but the index always works from
zero to length minus one in this case it
will be going from zero to nine so this
is basically all which i wanted to cover
in this lecture the whole idea was to
give you more understanding of arrays
and remember this is just an integer
array you can similarly create a
character array you can also create a
string array for for you as well so it
it's completely uh it's completely
related to the data type you are using
if you create a care array then you can
only store characters into it if you
create a string array then you can only
store strings into it and now you can
probably relate back to this particular
thing which i explained in the previous
lecture that we create this string array
for the reason that when you run this
particular program and if you want to
provide any command line values command
line arguments to the program those
arguments will automatically be stored
in this args and then you can access
this as args of zero or gsf1 etc in your
program that's the whole concept let's
get started with operators in java when
we talk about operators in java there
are multiple types of operators like
assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what how what these operators are and
how they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assignment operators and we will
also see if we can cover unary operators
so when we talk about assignment
operators i have again opened the
official java docs here if we understand
assignment operators we have been using
this operators all the while in all of
the demos so far and the basic idea is
very simple whenever you assign a value
to a variable you use the assignment
operator which is nothing but the equal
sign we have already covered this in
multiple demos so i will not cover this
as part of the demo but what i am going
to cover in detail is about these
arithmetic operators so arithmetic
operators are basically used to perform
any kind of arithmetic operation on a
java program it can be an addition
operation it can be a subtraction
operation
it can be a multiplication operation a
division operation or an operation by
which you can find the remainder of the
division so we will look at each of
these
with an example and as you can see the
symbols are expectedly what you
generally use in mathematics so
you see the the plus sign here which is
for addition you see the minus sign
which is for subtraction you see the
star sign which is for multiplication
you see the slash sign which is for
division and you see the percentage sign
which is for finding the remainder of
our division so let's see an example of
each of these and how we can use them in
a java program
so for the arithmetic operations i have
prepared a demonstration of it in the
eclipse ide again i'm using the same
java project which i've shown you we
created in the previous lectures so i
will for all the demonstrations i will
just continue on the same project so
again the way to create a class remains
the same exactly the same as how i
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also i created a class i
named the class as arithmetic demo and i
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class
and i have basically tried to
demonstrate each of the operation so
let's start with the addition operation
first
so i create an integer variable here
named as result and then i try to use
the addition operator to make this
variable store the result of this
addition so it's a simple one plus two
you can also create two different
variables for one and two let's say x
equal to one and y equal to two and you
can also do end result equal to x plus y
it will have the same effect but just
for simplicity i have put the literal
numbers here
so result is storing the
the expression value of 1 plus 2 and
then i'm printing this value here you
can see i'm printing the result variable
here with using
system.out.println then i'm storing this
result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then i'm trying
to subtract something from it so now i'm
saying result equal to result minus 1 it
means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so i'm printing the
original result and
then what i'm doing that i'm again
assigning the new result which is 2 to
the original result so now original
result and result both are at 2 then i
move ahead and i try to demonstrate the
multiplication operation so i take the
same variable result and i say multiply
it by 2. so whatever the value of result
was which at this place should be 2
multiply that value by 2. so 2 into 2
the new value of result should become 4
after this multiplication operation and
again i'm assigning the value of
original result to this particular
variable and then i'm showcasing the
fourth mathematical arithmetic operation
which is division so you can see result
by 2 here so basically i'm whatever the
current value of result is i'm dividing
that value by 2 so 4 divided by 2 should
become 2 so again the new value of the
result variable should become 2
then i am printing the value and again
storing the value
back into the original result
then the next operation is again an
addition operation where i whatever the
value of result is at this particular
point which is 2
add 8 to that particular value so the
new result value becomes 10
and then i'm printing that particular
value again assigning the original
result to the result and then to
showcase the remainder operation i'm
doing result
we call this particular operator as mod
or modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is
in this case would be 10 so i'm saying
10 mod 7 so 10 mod 7 would become 3
because if we divide 10 by 7 the
remainder should be 3 and this modulus
operator is used to calculate the
remainder of a division operation so
that 3 will be stored in this result
variable and then we print that
particular variable so that is what i am
doing if i take you back up there i will
just minimize this window and this
window as well so if i take you back to
the starting
i'm doing an addition first here at line
seven then i am doing a subtraction at
line 12
then i'm doing a multiplication at line
and a division at line 22
and then again an addition at line 27
and then a modulus at line 32 and i'm
printing the respective values so let us
run this program and see
what results do we get so i right click
i go to run as i go to java application
there is also a shortcut for it if you
want to use the shortcut you can use
that so i click on this and the output
is displayed here so you can see let me
bring this output back to its original
position yeah i just dragged it here to
the top to the bottom so if we start
from the top and see what all results
did we get printed so line 9 says 1 plus
2 equal to the value of result so 1 plus
2 equal to at this particular point the
result value was 3 because 1 plus 2
equal to 3
moving on the next variable here is
minus so the current value was 3 we said
3 minus 1 which becomes 2 and we store
the value of result or 3 into this
result variable and we print that value
at line 14. so original result plus
original result is 3
then a string here minus 1 equal to so
this is just a string
and then the actual current result value
which is 2. so far so good we move ahead
and then at line 19 we are multiplying
the current value of result by 2 and
again displaying the original result and
the current value so
2 is the original result here because
here 3 minus 1 had become 2 so original
result value was 2 multiply that by 2
becomes 4
then moving on to the line 24 2 by 4 by
2 should become 2 so 4 by 2 equals 2 the
current value of result then again
moving on to the next variable
at line 29 now the result value should
become 10 because 2 plus 8 is 10 and
again we are printing the original
result and then the current result value
so the original result was 2 then we
added 8 to it and the new result value
had become 10 which is coming from this
particular variable
moving on to line 34 we are again
printing the original result which was
10 here
and then we are saying this particular
string which is modulus 7 and the
current value of result is coming from
this expression which is 10 modulus 7
and like i said modulus or mod operation
is basically used to calculate the
remainder of a division operation which
so 10 divided by 7 remainder is 3 so
that becomes 3 and that's why you see
the value 3 so this is a demonstration
to show you how we can use the addition
multiplication subtraction division and
modulus operators which are all the
arithmetic operators let's get started
with equality and relational operators
when we talk about relational operators
they are sometimes also called
comparison operators and the basic idea
behind using these operators is to
compare things or compare the values of
variables or compare the objects in java
so in java if you need to compare
anything for example if you want to
compare if something is less than the
other thing or something is greater than
the other thing or something is equal to
the other thing then you need to use the
comparison operators which are provided
by java here you can see i have opened
the official java docs and you can see a
bunch of comparison or relational
operators both of the terms are used
interchangeably some people call them
comparison operators and some people
call them relational operators
so you can see if i want to compare if
an object or a value is equal to another
value then i use the double equal sign
if i want to compare for non-equality i
will use exclamation with an equal to
which means not equal to if i want to do
a greater than comparison then i will
use the mathematics greater than symbol
if i want to do the greater than equal
to or less than or less than equal to
they again follow the same kind of
terminology as we see in mathematics so
this is all we have in terms of the
relational operators so let's understand
the usage of these operators with the
help of some examples so as you can see
i have created a class here which is
called comparison operator there is a
public static void main method inside
this class and this method has two
variables of integer type called value
one and value two value one has the
value 1 and value 2 has the value 2 and
then i am trying to compare the value 1
and value 2 variables using the
different relational operators we just
covered for doing that i need to use a
conditional operator as well we will be
covering conditional operators in much
much detail in the upcoming lectures but
for now you can understand that when we
talk about conditional operators we talk
about if an else statement so if is
again a keyword in java which can be
used to compare things and the syntax is
very straightforward you write the if
keyword and then you write the actual
comparison syntax or the actual
comparison expression so in the first
example we can see that i am writing a
condition which says evaluate if value 1
is equal to value 2. i should put a
curly braces around here you can see
there are no curly braces here but that
is for a case when you have only one
statement under it but again i will
cover this in detail and i don't want to
confuse the audience here so i will just
put curly braces around all of these if
statements so that it becomes easy to
interpret what is actually going on in
these code blocks as we know that these
curly braces are used to define a code
block so the first if block says compare
if the value 1 is equal to the value 2.
if yes then this condition will become 2
and the control of the program will go
at line number 10. if this condition is
not true then the control will not go
inside 10 because this condition is
false so it will never go to line 10 and
it will move to line 11 or 12 instead
similarly the next condition is we are
comparing the value 1 is not equal to
value 2. so this condition will only be
true if these two values are not equal
or unequal and if that is the case then
line 14 will execute it otherwise line
14 will not be executed similarly in
this condition i am saying compare if
value 1 is greater than value 2 or not
so if the actual value holded by value 1
variable is greater than the value 2
variable then this condition will become
true and the line 18 will be executed
otherwise it will be skipped then
similarly at line 20 i am doing the
reverse i'm comparing if value 1 is less
than equal less than value 2. if that is
the case then line 22 will be executed
otherwise it will be skipped and at last
i'm also showcasing an example of less
than equal to operator that you put less
than and equal to together and again you
compare the two variables similarly you
can also use greater than equal to
variable comparison operator as well in
this example so we have an example of
equality not equal to greater than less
than and less than equal to let's run
this example to understand so for
running the example i will just right
click here go to run as and click on
java application and we can see the
output here so as the value 1 holds the
value 1 and value 2 variable holds the
value 2 obviously 1 is not equal to 2 so
the first condition is not going to be
evaluated to true so line 10 will never
be executed because 1 is not equal to 2.
similarly if i talk about the
next condition which was if value 1 is
not equal to value 2 then execute
statement 14 and yes 1 is not equal to 2
that's why we see this particular
system.out.println here you see this
printed moving on is value 1 greater
than value 2 so is 1 greater than 2 no
it's not so line 18 will never be
executed then the next one is is value 1
less than value 2 so yes 1 is less than
2 so line 22 will be executed and we see
the line 22 output here
system.out.printer and output moving on
is 1 less than equal to 2 yes 1 is less
than equal to 2 so this particular
condition is also true and line 26 will
be executed and that's why we see this
here and that's all so we can see that
we are able to use these comparison or
relational operators to evaluate
different conditions and we write those
conditions using the if block and again
if you do not understand the if block
fully don't worry we will be covering
the if blocks in detail but the focus
here is in using the operators the not
equal to operators the greater than
equal to operators less than equal to
operators etc so i hope these operators
give you a better understanding of how
to use them now moving on to the next
section of this
comparison operators sometimes we also
use some logical terms to do the
comparison for example if i just move
down here and i show you these
conditions here we call them conditional
operators conditional operators are used
to evaluate the conditions like and or
or and we use them in two two ways
either we can use it as ampersand or
double ampersand or we can use them as
pipe or double pipes so the idea is
basically to evaluate if one condition
is true and other condition is also true
or one condition is true or other
condition is true so whenever you want
to combine two conditions together
that's where you're going to use these
logical operators or conditional
operators you can also use the simple
english keywords like and or or or you
can use the logical representation of
these keywords for example ampersand
ampersand or double ampersand is
equivalent to and similarly double pipe
is equivalent to or so we can use these
as well interchangeably you can use
either of these
operator representations to run a
conditional check in composition meaning
you can compare two conditions saying
okay if one is true and second is true
or one is true or second is true so the
whole focus is here in and and or
comparisons so let's switch back to the
ide and let's look at an example of this
to understand this in detail so i will
again take the similar kind of example
again i have created two variables here
value one and value two value one has
value as one and second variable value
two has value as two and then i'm
writing two conditions this time in the
same if block you can see i am writing
first condition saying is value 1 equal
to equal to 1 and is value 2 also equal
to equal to 2 so this whole if condition
is only going to be true only if both of
the conditions are true that's the
property of and and will force that both
the conditions on the left hand side of
it and the right hand side of it hold
true and then only the whole expression
is going to hold true even if one of the
conditions evaluate to false the whole
if expression will evaluate to false
similarly for or conditions we again
write a left hand condition and a right
hand condition and in between we write
this double pipe we can also write or or
in english that will also have the same
effect and this will evaluate in a way
that this whole expression this whole
expression will evaluate to true
if even a single condition either on
left side or right side of it becomes
true so r will just need one expression
to be true to make the whole if
condition true whereas and will force
both of the conditions to be true to
make the whole expression as true so and
will require two trues to actually
become true but our condition will
require only one true to become true so
if we try to do uh understand this logic
here i am saying that if value one is
equal to equal to 1 which is correct and
value 2 is equal to equal to 2 then make
this condition as true so yes in this
case this condition will evaluate to
true because value 1 has value 1 1 and
value 2 has value as 2 so it will print
the line 10 whereas in the next
condition i am saying evaluate if value
1 is equal to equal to 1 or value 2 is
equal to equal to 1 so either of the
expression if becomes true either the
left side this expression or the right
side this expression either of the
expression becomes true this whole
condition will become true and line 14
will be executed line 14 will not be
executed only in a case when both of the
conditions here become false for example
if i write it like this then we know
that value 1 is not equal to 4 because
it's 1 and value 2 is not equal to 5
because it's true in that case both of
the expression will become false and
then line 14 will not be executed if i
write it like this then the left hand
expression is evaluated to true because
value 1 is 1 but the right hand
expression is false but it's fine the
line 14 will still be executed because
either of these side is true so the
whole expression becomes true similarly
here and will require both of the
expressions to be true and if either of
them becomes false the whole expression
becomes false so in the current state
line 10 will be executed but if i change
this to this then the left hand side of
this ampersand will evaluate to false
and the whole expression will evaluate
to false in that case and line 10 will
never be executed let's try to run all
of these scenarios to make a better
understanding of this so in this case
both of the conditions should work fine
so i will just right click and run as
java application and yes we see this
line 10 being printed and we also see
this line 13 being printed so both of
the lines are printed correctly both of
the conditions are evaluating to true
now let's try to play around with it let
me change this value to 4 so now value 1
this left hand side expression is false
which should make the whole expression
as false and it should not print the
line 10 which is this statement so let's
run this program and see if that works
yes we see that this particular line is
not printed now because this whole
expression became false because the left
hand side of this expression became
false similarly in the r case either of
them have to have to be true you can see
currently value 2 equal to equal to 5
condition will actually result in a
false condition because this is not a
true value 2 is actually 2 not 5 and
still we see this particular expression
because either of them have to be true
if i make both of them as not true now
both of the conditions on the left hand
side of pipe and right hand side of pipe
are false conditions what will happen
now nothing will be printed the reason
for that is that value 1 is also that
this condition is also false and value 2
condition is also false so the whole
expression became false and this was
already false so this is all i wanted to
cover in this lecture we covered our
about the comparison operators and how
to use them and in the next lecture we
are going to talk about the bitwise
operators let's get started with bitwise
operators now bitwise operators are very
less commonly used in the java
programming world generally we don't use
them and generally we don't need to use
them you would generally use them when
you are doing really complex bit wise
calculation where you need to manipulate
the bits now what are actually bits so
if you remember when we talked about the
integer type variables we talked about
how much memory each of the variable
type or data type was going to consume
we said that this will take one byte and
this will take two bytes etc one byte is
basically made up of eight bits and bits
are nothing but positions where either a
zero is stored or one is stored actually
the whole machine will convert your
whole program ultimately in zeros and
ones which are nothing but bits so if
you want to do the manipulation at that
level so now you can understand you are
you are actually working at right at the
machine level understanding so if you
want to manipulate the bits which are
going to be understood by the machine at
that level then you can use bitwise
operators but like i said generally we
don't need to use them now when we talk
about bitwise operators there are
multiple ways in which we can use them
we can use them with the standard and or
or operations if you remember we covered
this and or or operations in the
previous lecture you see a difference
here that in case of and we are using a
single ampersand or and not double
ampersand this is one of the concept
which we did not covered in the previous
lecture and i would just like to brief
you about this concept that if you use
double ampersand that is also called a
short circuit operator and if you use a
single ampersand that is called a
standard operator to build an
understanding about this i will just
quickly recap of what we covered in the
last lecture and we'll try to explain
these concepts as well so let's go to
the logical operator demo and here if
you remember there were two ampersands
and two pipes
this is also a valid expression a single
ampersand is also a valid expression the
only change is
in this case
even if the left hand condition
evaluates to false still the right hand
condition will be evaluated although we
know that in case of and either of the
expression needs to be false and the
whole expression becomes false so java
provides an advantage or with that if
you use double ampersand and if the left
hand operation becomes false
then it will not cover the right hand
operation it will not even evaluate the
right hand operation because it doesn't
matter if the left hand operation has
already returned to false or evaluated
to false then no matter whether right
side is true or false the whole
expression is still going to be false
right that's the property of and
one of these side has to be false and
the whole expression becomes false so
why why evaluate two sides why waste the
memory in evaluating the right side when
the left side has already turned as
false java takes advantage of that and
that's why if you use double ampersand
you save a bit of processing power of
your computer
by just evaluating the left hand
condition
and if the left hand condition is false
it will skip evaluating the right hand
condition and just make the whole
expression false but if you use this
a single ampersand then both side of the
expression will be evaluated
irrespective of their output so in this
case
even if the left hand expression is
false it is still going to evaluate the
right side expression and similarly it
works for the or case as well in this
case in our case as we know if one of
the condition is true the whole
condition becomes true the whole
expression becomes true so if the left
hand side becomes true and if we use a
single pipe then it will still evaluate
the right height side but if you use
double pipe like this then if the left
hand side becomes true then it knows
that it does not matter if the right
hand side becomes true or false because
ultimately the whole expression is going
to be true if either of the side is true
so if the left hand side is already true
it will not evaluate the right hand side
and it will say the whole expression is
true that's why you see the single
ampersand being used for bitwise just to
explain why it why it is used and how it
is used for our operations in bitwise
you use this cap or whatever you want to
call it as and for
the inclusive bitwise or
or operation you're going to use a
single pipe you also use some shift
operations where you shift the value of
bit of a particular variable to either
left or right again these are again very
complex calculations if you want to use
that please read about this and use that
but in the in today's demo what we are
going to cover is the and and or
examples of bitwise operations
so here i have again created a class
called bitwise operator i have a public
static void main method i have two
variables here which are int a equal to
5 and into b equal to 7. now these 5 and
are actually stored as bits
as zeros and ones in the computer's
memory so how they are actually stored
they are stored in a standard bit
representation which you may have
studied in your mathematics if to give
you a recap this five will basically be
written in a memory as this
0 1 0 1 and it starts from here 2 raised
to power 0 into 1 becomes 1 2 raised to
power 1 into 0 becomes 0 2 raised to
power 2
into 1 becomes 4 and 2 raised to power 3
into 0 becomes 0 so 4 0 plus 4 plus 0
plus 1 becomes 5 and that's how 5 is
displayed to you similarly for 7 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 plus 2
raised to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 1 plus
2 3 plus 2 raised to power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 1 plus
2 plus 4 7 and 2 raised to power 3 into
0 is 0 so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 which
is 7 and that's how this 7 is built and
stored and now if you try to do this if
you try to write this condition you can
also write the condition into a
system.out.println block and it will
basically evaluate this condition so now
if you say a and b
in this case this is going to do a
bitwise operation because this is
bitwise operand it is going to do a bit
wise operation and what would be the
result if you do an and on this so again
use the same logic as if in case of and
if 1 is false then the whole expression
is false
so 0 and 0 becomes 0
1 and 1 becomes 1
0 and 1 becomes 0 because 0 means false
and 1 means true so if either of them is
false the whole evaluation becomes false
so that's why 0 or and 1 becomes 0 and 1
and 1 is always 1. the value of this is
again 5 as we already have evaluated
similarly if you do a bitwise or and if
you do this again we are doing an or
operation
so 0 or 0 or basically false or false
becomes false true or
true becomes true false or true should
be true because one of them needs to be
true so this is false but this is true
so the whole value becomes true and the
finally true or true is also true so
this is the final bitwise or result and
if we convert this into an integer
representation that becomes 7 because 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 2 raised
to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 2 plus 1 3
plus 2 raised to the power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7
and plus 2 raised to the power 3 into 0
which is 0 so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1
becomes 7 and that's how you get
actually 7. so let's see if we get 5 or
7 in this bitwise operation yes we can
see the values as five and seven so this
is a bitwise operation happening
similarly you can also use the shift
operations where in case if you're using
the this particular kind of
representation or this particular kind
of representation they are called which
they are called left shift and right
shift operations so if you use this in
front of a variable then for example
this one will be shifted here and this
zero will be shifted here and this one
will be shifted here so that's how the
whole value is going to shift all bits
are going to shift one by one towards
left similarly if you are using the
right shift then all the bits are going
to be shifted towards right by one bit
that's the whole concept of left shift
and right shift bitwise operations and
if you want to know more about this
please read some official examples from
the java doc and some other examples
available on the internet to build an
understanding on this
so this is all i wanted to cover in this
lecture so in the next session we are
going to talk about the control flow
statements like if else etc let's get
started with control flow statements so
what are control flow statements and why
do we need them control flow statements
are the ones which can help you control
and define the flow of execution in your
program now why do we need them is
because if we want to evaluate some
conditions or we want to create some
branches of execution saying that if
this condition becomes true do this and
if this condition becomes false do that
so you can see there are two different
branches of execution of a program in
this kind of approach and that's where
control flow statements can help us
there are a lot of different types of
control flow statements like if then
else and switch and for and while and do
while and we are going to cover all of
them in detail in this series so let's
get started with the first one which is
the if statement we covered briefly
about this when we talked about
operators and i promised you guys that i
will be covering this in detail and this
is the session where we will go deeper
into this concept as we have already
understood that if condition is
basically used to evaluate a condition
if it is true or false the result of an
if statement will always have only two
values it can either have a true value
or it can have a false value there is no
other possibility or there is no other
value of an if statement or of an if
expression now like i explained if you
want to do a simple programming
execution where you say if a particular
condition becomes true do this
and if this becomes false then do that
it means you need to write this
else condition as well that if this
doesn't hold true what do i do and how
do i write that so let's understand that
with the help of an example for this
particular example i've created a class
and there is a public static void main
method which is the entry point of this
program's execution i have a variable
which is called test score this is an
integer variable with the value 76 and i
have a care variable which is grade
basically what i'm doing that based on
the test score marks i'm trying to
define the grades which a student will
get so for that i have built a condition
here so you can see it starts with if
which is a keyword then you put these
standard braces or brackets and you
write your condition inside it in this
case i'm writing the condition saying
that if test score is greater than equal
to 90
then the student should get and grade a
so here i've defined this grade variable
and here i'm just assigning the value to
the grade variable at line 11 if the
test score is greater than 90 the grade
should be a but what if the score is not
90 what if this condition becomes false
and you want to do something in that
case you can write this else block here
we call this else block so you write
else as the keyword you start the curly
braces and then you define the grade if
the score is not greater than 90 what
should be the grade of the student so in
this case we are saying the grade is f
so if we try to run this example in our
inner mind we see that the value is of
the test score is 76
so 76 is not greater than equal to 90 so
this particular condition will not be
true so line 11 will not be executed but
instead
else block will be executed because if
the condition goes false then else block
should be executed as per java so this
block will be executed and grade will
get a value of f
and then we are printing this grade
value by just writing a
system.out.println a string plus the
value so let's run this particular
program and see what happens
we get a grade equal to f here in this
cis out or system.out.println
because this condition was false so the
control the flow of the control of the
program went to line 12 and then to line
30 because this was the else block so
this is one understanding where we can
write an if and else logic you in some
cases you might not need an else block
so else block is not mandatory it's an
optional block if you want to remove
this and if you just want to do a sys
out here that is also fine cis out means
system.out.println
for shorthand we sometimes call it as
sysout so you can
do something here as well if you don't
need bells block if you need this block
feel free to write it but this is an
optional block but in some cases your
conditions will be more complicated than
just a single condition if you try to
understand it from a real world example
in real world you will not have only two
grades as a and f you will have more
grades right a b c d so on so forth
so what are you going to do in that case
for that kind of case
java provides us with an keyword which
is called else if else if is just a
continuation of if saying that okay if
this condition doesn't hold true
evaluate the next one with an else if so
i've commented out this code let me put
this code back into its place and then
we will walk through this code to
understand it okay so i have put the
code back to where it should be and this
is how it looks like so let's just walk
through this the line 10 and 11 doesn't
change it's still the same but then i
have added some additional conditions
saying that okay if the score is greater
than equal to 90 the grade should be a
but if the score is
not greater than 90 but
greater than equal to 80 then the grade
should be b
similarly if the score is not even
greater than 80 but greater than equal
to 70 then the grade should be c
similarly if the score is nev not even
greater than equal to 70 but greater
than equal to 60 which means basically
between 60 to 70 then the grade should
be d
and if the score is even below 60 then
the grade should be f so you can see i
have basically defined the whole logic
for defining the grades here and it
always works in our top down approach
one by one the way in the sequence in
which you will define the else if block
will be the sequence in which they will
be executed so after the condition at
line 10 and if this condition fails
line 12 will be naturally executed if
this condition also fails line 14 will
be executed and so on so forth it will
never be the case that if this condition
fails then suddenly line 16 is executed
and then again line 12 is executed it
will always work in a line by line
fashion so make sure whenever you are
using the else if statements
write it in a sequence in which you want
the natural program to be executed so
this is all we have here and now let's
try to run this example let me just
bring the system dot out dot println
align up save this file right click run
as
java application so we see the value is
grade equal to c which means
this particular code block was actually
executed only this condition held true
now that now let's try to understand how
this happened the value was 76 so 76
greater than 90 no this condition
becomes false so line 11 is never
executed it naturally goes to line 12
because that's where we have defined the
next else if block
is 76 greater than equal to 80 no it's
not so line 12 condition also becomes
false
line 13 never gets executed and that
control shifts to line 14 and there we
have the condition saying that is 76
greater than equal to 70 yes this
condition is true so the line 15 gets
executed and once this condition gets
true
none of the further conditions will be
executed because you only need one true
statement one true execution in the
whole if else if block if that one code
block gets true that code block is
executed and then the execution jumps
out of the is if else if blocks and it
will directly go to line 22 and it will
execute that had it been the case that
this particular block was also evaluated
to false it would go to line 16 and if
this was also false it would go to the
block which is else block let's see that
let's make this value as 56 so now
56 is not greater than 70 so line 15
will never be executed because this
condition will evaluate to false 56 is
greater than 60 no so this will also be
false and ultimately the grade should
fall to
else block where we are assigning the
grade as f let's see yes we get the
grade f because ultimately this block
was executed because all of the above
conditions evaluated to false let's get
started with using nested if statements
in java now in the previous lecture we
saw how we can use an if else block and
also an if else if else block but there
is another case where we can use these
if statements and that is when you have
nested if blocks when would you use it
let's take an example let's say you have
multiple conditions to check on a
particular program and where the output
of the first condition is the input of
the second condition and the output of
the second condition is the input to the
third condition and so on so forth if
you have that kind of situation you can
write it in a nested if statement kind
of block so let's understand this with
the help of an example as you can see i
have opened an example here which is
about nested if statements i've created
a class which which is named as nested
if demo and i have created a public
static void main method inside this
particular class and now i have declared
an integer variable with the value 50
then i'm checking the first condition
saying if i equal to equal to 50. if
that condition is true then i will check
the next condition which is if i is less
than 75 and then i am adding one more
hypothetical condition saying if this is
true then also check if i is less than
55 so you can see if i equal to 50 holds
true then only this condition will be
executed similarly if i is less than 75
then only this condition will be
executed so they are dependent upon each
other this condition block is dependent
upon the previous block to be true and
this if condition block is dependent
upon this if block to be true if either
of these if blocks don't go true the
next subsequent nested if block will not
be executed so in this case i'm checking
it for first equality condition saying
if the value is equal to 50 then execute
this statement at line number 10 then
check if i is less than 75 if that is
also true execute the statement at light
number 12 and then if i is also less
than 55 then also execute line number
14. i can also add an else block as well
anywhere in this nested hierarchy if i
want to if i add an else block here that
else block will be corresponding to this
block if i add an else block here and
that else block will be corresponding to
this if block and if i add an else block
here then that else block will be
corresponding to this particular if
block so you can also use those elsif
and else blocks as well with nested if
blocks and make it as complicated as you
want it to be so that's about this
program and let's see if we run this
program what output do we get and let's
interpret that output so i'll just right
click run as java program and i see some
output in the console first i get i is
50 so line number 10 gets printed
because i is 50 then i also see the next
line
output as i is smaller than 75 it means
this condition was also true because 50
is less than 75 so line 12 also got
executed and then i'm checking if i is
less than 55 so yes 50 is less than 55
so line 14 also gets executed and we get
this statement on the console so this
was a simple way to see how we can
implement the nested if conditions now
we are also going to talk about another
concept which is used in writing the if
conditional blocks which is called
ternary operators so ternary operators
are used as a shorthand of writing if
else block as you can see that these if
blocks are quite verbose we have to
write a lot of code to actually write
some conditions in this case i'm
executing three conditions but the code
is
almost seven lines or eight lines so we
will see how we can simplify this if we
use a ternary operator and for that i
have created another class which is
called ternary operator demo and this
particular class again has a public
static void main which is the entry
point of this particular program and
then i have declared couple of variables
first is int a equal to 1 and second one
is int b equal to 2. i have also
declared a result variable and we will
see how we can use this result variable
and at line 10 i have written my if else
expression so you can see this if else
expression doesn't look like the one
which we have seen before so let's
understand how do we write it if you're
trying to write an if else expression
with ternary expressions or ternary
statements then the first thing which
you need to understand is the structure
of it so here at first you will specify
the actual condition which you want to
test in your if block so this is my
condition then after that condition you
are going to put a question mark and
after the question mark you are going to
put the actual result which you want to
be executed if this condition becomes
true so if the if condition becomes true
what do you want to do whatever is that
you will write it here and then if the
condition becomes false then the logic
should go into the else block and the
else logic should come after this colon
so all you need to remember is this
question mark and this colon before the
question mark you are going to write the
condition after the question mark you
are going to write the statement which
is going to be executed if this if
condition becomes true and after the
colon you are going to write the else
block condition which is going to be
executed if this condition becomes false
another thing to notice is that ternary
operators can be used only in cases when
you have only one statement to execute
in if block and one statement to execute
in else block it cannot be more than one
statements so instead of this you can
also write
system.out.println here which will also
be fine if i just write this system dot
out dot print not print f but i want to
write println so i'll just write println
you can also do this this is also fine
you don't need to store the result
obviously
but but you can also write this
condition in a way but this all this
only has to be a single statement it
cannot be more than one statement
because this expression can only hold
one statement at a time so use it in
situations where you have to check a
condition and do something in the if
block which is only one statement and
again one statement in the else block
the same expression can also be written
in a verbose if else way in which we
have been saying it before and we'll
also i will also show that to you and
here where this a and b is going this is
getting stored in this variable called
result so if this if condition holds
true then the result is a and this is
going to be stored in here and if it is
going into the else block then b is
going to be stored in the result block
let's run this program so we can see we
get the value 1 because we have set the
condition as a less than b so yes 1 is
less than 2 so this particular statement
gets executed and this value gets stored
here in the result variable so that's
how you can use the ternary operators to
write shorthand if else statements the
same expression can also be written in a
verbose way for example you can write it
in this way saying if a is less than b
then result equal to a else result equal
to b this code has exactly the same
effect as this one line of code so you
can see this is this is pretty
simple to write pretty short to write
the code which i'm writing here in four
lines can be written here in one line
and that's the power of ternary
operators so this is all i wanted to
cover in today's session so we talked
about nested if statements and the
ternary operators here how to use them
in the next session we are going to
discuss about switch case statements
let's get started with using switch
statements in java so let us first
understand why do we need switch
statements generally whenever you want
to check a condition you can use an if
else block but what if you have multiple
conditions to check what if you have so
many possible execution paths that it
becomes too verbose to write it into an
if else kind of block what if you have
to check on constant values of certain
expressions how do you do that it
becomes even more challenging and the
code becomes even more verbose so in
such cases switch statement can be used
in which you can write switch statement
to have as many possible execution paths
as you want and it will work with
constant values as well so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as how and why will we use the
switch statements so for that i have
created this class which is called
switch demo and it also has a public
static void main method which is the
entry point and in this program what i'm
doing is i'm trying to accept a number
as the month number in the program and
then with that particular number i'm
trying to print the corresponding
month's name so that's the logic pick a
month number and you should get the
month's actual name so now in this case
you can you can imagine there will be at
least 12 if else if blocks which is a
long line of if else statements at the
same time if we try to do this for other
conditions where the value is constant
please understand that the value of
month is going to be constant it's going
to be the same number so it's not
similar to you evaluating a condition
it's similar to you evaluating a
condition to a particular constant value
imagine if you have to do some sort of a
classification of employees in higher
salaries and lower salaries and there
are hundreds of salary bands in the
company so are you going to write 100
afl's logics that is going to take a
long time and then what if new bands get
new bands get introduced then it gets
even more complex so we will use switch
case statements in cases where there are
lots of if else conditions and the
expression evaluates to a constant value
remember in the if else cases the
expression evaluates to a boolean value
so here uh i'm supplying the month value
as six then i'm also creating a string
month one string variable just to print
or store the name of the month and then
the way you write the switch statement
is to write the switch keyword and then
in the brackets you supply the month
integer value and then you start writing
your conditions so you can see you write
the case as keyword
and then you write the number or the
possible values this particular variable
or this particular expression can hold
so all the possible values this
particular expression can hold will be
written individually as cases so case
equal to one here one means the value of
month is one in that case the month
string which we created here shall store
january and then we see a statement
called break so break is again a keyword
in java and this keyword has a special
meaning it has a special usage you will
use the keyword break to abruptly break
the control of execution from the
current code block and the code block is
identified with curly braces so here you
can see the curly brace starts from here
and it ends
down to line number 51 at here so the
moment your java program is going to
encounter this particular statement it
is going to jump out of the current code
block execution and continue thereafter
that's the basic logic and usage of
break statement so use it whenever you
want to skip the rest of the code after
the break statement if you don't want to
execute the rest of the code you will
write break and the moment the java
program sees this particular statement
it will jump out of the current code
block specified by the curly braces and
will resume execution after the code
block so in this case it will resume the
execution after the line 51. that's the
usage and meaning of this expression
called break so in this case we are
saying that if the month value is 1
which we denoted as here case 1 then
store the
value of the month string as january and
break out of this particular code block
because we don't need to execute any
further we have found a match then
another case would be if the month value
is 2 so you write case which is a
keyword and then the exact expression
value the constant value which is 2 and
if that's the case then one string
becomes february and again you break
because in this particular case there
will only be one condition true at a
time there will never be a case that
month with the value two will have two
meanings will have two month names a
month with the value two will always
have a meaning called february it will
never have two meanings or two month
names attached to the same integer value
and that's why you do not want to
execute any further and that's why you
write this break statement if you do not
write this bake statement it is going to
evaluate all of the cases one by one
even if the cases are not going to be
true but it is going to waste lot of
processing time evaluating all the case
conditions which you have written here
which does not make sense because we
know that only one condition at a time
can be true here because we are
evaluating and checking for a constant
value which is an integer value so
that's the reason we put a break in each
case if intentionally if you want to
check multiple cases do not put a break
statement but the program can become
really confusing in that case so take
your wise call so here we put a break in
each case similarly case 3 the month
string becomes march case 4 the month
string becomes april case 5 becomes may
case 6 becomes june case 7 we have one
string as july case 8 month string is
august case 9 we store the monstering as
september case 10 as october case 11 as
november and case 12 as december after
that you will also see an interesting
block called default this is the another
capability of switch statement that what
if none of the above conditions hold
true what if we specify a value which is
not between 1 and 12 and it will not
match any of the cases which we saw just
above and if you want to execute some
code in that case if none of the
conditions matches you may want to
execute some default execution also in
such cases you are going to use default
default is the code block which will be
executed if none of the case matches so
here you can see that if none of the
cases match then we are going to store
the value of month string variable as
invalid month and then we'll eventually
break out and once we break out of this
program we just want to print the month
string that's all we are doing in this
program that we take an integer value as
the month number and then we print the
corresponding month name here by looking
at the case blocks and we also default
define our default case block if none of
the conditions hold true so let's run
this program we have specified the value
as 6 which should result in the month
name as june and yes we can see we get
june let's change the value and let's
put the value as 10 and see what do we
get so right click run as java
application and we got october yes
exactly correct let's put an invalid
value as 13 and let's see what happens
now now we get invalid month so our
default code block just got executed
because we entered a value which is not
matching any of the case conditions
which we have specified so this is how
you are going to use the switch and case
statements while writing your conditions
whenever your condition evaluates to
multiple constant values remember the
the key here is to understand if your
expression is evaluating to multiple
constant values which do not change and
in those cases using a switch case block
is a better idea than writing if else
statements let's get started with
understanding arrays in detail we have
been talking about arrays throughout
this course of java in the previous
sessions as well and we have covered
some basic understanding of how to
create arrays how to declare them how to
fill values in the array and how do we
print the array with positions as well
as the array as whole but whatever
examples which we took previously were
one dimensional arrays because arrays
can have more than one dimensions as
well you can create a one-dimensional
array you can create a two-dimensional
array you can create even a
three-dimensional array and you can go
up to as many dimensions as you can
handle in your java program so it
depends upon the kind of complexity you
want to have in your program and the
kind of values the kind of structure you
are going to store in your arrays and
based on that need you can choose
whether you want to use a 1d array or
one dimensional array or a 2d array or a
3d array and so on in these sessions we
are going to talk about 1d arrays 2d
arrays and 3d arrays and after that
we'll leave up to you to try out more
dimensionals if you want to we have
already covered the basic array
structures which were one-dimensional
arrays so i will just give you a quick
walkthrough of how we actually handled
one-dimensional arrays so this is a
sample program to demonstrate
one-dimensional arrays if you remember
this is how we use to create arrays we
write the data type of the array and
then we write the square boxes which
denote that this is an integer array
data type we assign a variable to this
and then we initialize the array with
the size 4. so new is the keyword which
is used to initialize anything in java
and we are going to use this heavily
when we talk about classes and objects
and even collections literally any
object which you want to create in java
requires a new keyword so here i'm
writing new and then int4 which means
create an array of size 4 and then i'm
filling the value of the four positions
which i have created as part of this
array and if you remember when we create
these kind of arrays we store them in a
zero index based position the first
value gets stored at zeroth index
position and then so on so forth so it
will always start from zero and never
start from one remember that and after
that we just print all the values of
individual positions of the elements in
the array and if i just run this program
all of the elements of this particular
array should be printed one by one so if
i just show the full console of the
output we can see that element in index
0 was 10 element index 1 was 20 element
at index 2 was 30 and element at index 3
was 40. so this was just a quick
refresher of how one dimensional arrays
can be written and whenever you declare
a very simplistic array it will
generally be a one-dimensional array now
let's look at the two-dimensional arrays
and how do we write them when do we need
them for that i have created another
example which is says two-dimensional
array i just created a class and it has
a public static void main method and
i've created a two-dimensional array
this time so let's understand this
two-dimensional array in a bit detail
and when do we need that generally you
would need to use two-dimensional arrays
whenever you are trying to do any matrix
calculations
if you if you understand what do you
mean by matrix it's basically a two by
two structure which stores the values in
the form of rows and columns so imagine
a table of two rows and two columns then
it will be a two by two matrix so if you
want to store that particular table in a
java program you would need to store
that as a matrix as a two-dimensional
matrix rows being the one-dimensional
and column being the other dimension and
that's what we are doing here and if you
want to
store that 2d matrix in a java program
the approach and the procedure for it is
pretty similar to how you create a
one-dimensional array with slight
changes
the first change is instead of a single
square bracket you are going to write
two square brackets because it is a two
dimensional array so remember the number
of square brackets you are going to put
while initializing and declaring the
array is the number of dimensions which
your array is going to have since this
is a two-dimensional array example
that's why you see two brackets here if
this was a three dimensional array
example you will see three array three
square brackets here and so on so forth
so that's the first part of it second
part to understand is to how to store
the data remember i told you always
imagine the structure of rows and
columns whenever you are trying to store
a two-dimensional array in java so what
are rows and what are values and how do
you represent them while you declare and
initialize a two-dimensional array so
you start with the curly braces as a
normal 1d array but inside the curly
braces you create nested curly braces
blocks we can see three blocks here they
start with their own curly brace and end
with their own then this curly brace
starts here and ends here and then this
curly brace starts here and ends here
idea is that you provide this outer
curly braces to define the overall
structure and then inside each of the
curly braces is going to represent a row
in your two dimensional array so each of
these
values these blocks is going to
represent a row so i can say that this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and if i try
to visualize it in terms of columns then
this is the first row first column
first row second column first row third
column similarly second row first column
second row second column second row
third column and third row first column
third row second column and third row
third column so individual values are
going to be represented as columns and
the whole curly braces is going to be
represented as arrays that's the basic
mental idea or mental image you should
have while declaring a two dimensional
arrays remember to declare the rows
inside the nested curly braces and
whatever elements you have will
automatically be indexed as columns
another thing to remember that since
this is an array data structure
everything starts from 0 and nothing
starts from 1 so this will be row 0 this
will be row 1 and this will be row 2 i'm
talking about the position we can still
call it as first row second row and
third row but the position of this
particular row element is 0 the position
of this particular row element is 1 and
this particular row element is 2.
similarly for column as well this is
column 0 column 1 and column 2.
similarly column 0 column 1 and column 2
and so on so forth once you understand
this data structure well and you have
defined it correctly then everything
should fall in place if you want to do a
matrix addition or if you want to do a
matrix multiplication or a dot product
all of the kind of calculations can be
performed using the 2d array concept
here in this program what i'm doing is i
am printing the values of this
particular 2d array into a matrix style
and you see some strange code here which
is for etc don't worry about this i'm
going to cover in detail what this 4
means and how do you write this for now
what we can understand that we just want
to print this you might not need to
print this in your java programs when
you write a production grid application
but you might want to do manipulations
on these
arrays as metrics maybe you want to
create a transpose of a matrix or you
want to do a dot product or addition or
subtraction or whatever be your use case
in this case just for demonstration
purpose i am printing the values as rows
and columns nothing else so this all of
this code from line 8 to line 14 or in
fact line 13 is just showing how to
print the values you can see some system
dot out and you can see some construct
here and like i said don't worry about
this i will cover this in detail let's
run this program and see if my java
array is stored correctly and how can i
represent this so you can see i have
represented it in a style of a 2d matrix
where this is the first row this is the
second row and this is the third row
similarly this is the first column
containing the value 237 so column 0
will have value 2 and column 1 will have
this value 3 and column 2 will have this
value 7 for row 0. let me also do
something here which can help you
understand this concept better let me do
a
system.out.println and let's print an
individual value because like i said the
for loop can be confusing here to
understand so let's say i want to print
arr of zeroth row first column and see
what kind of values do we get let me
comment this code comment is control
backslash and this code will be
commented and this code will not be
executed and now only line 15 will be
executed instead of the four block so if
i run this i get the value 7 so row 0
and first column row 0 first column is
seven let's try with one one i want to
print the
row at zero one position remember not
the first row but the one position row
which is basically technically the
second row so second row second column
and see what kind of values value do i
get in this case i get six so second row
second column similarly if you change
this value to two then third row second
column which should point to four yes we
get 4. similarly you can write a value
here as 0 and you can write a value here
as let's say 2 this will print the
zeroth row and the second column so
similarly whatever kind of value you
want to write you or you want to access
you can access it in this fashion and
remember the column and row indexes will
always start from zero so this is a
simple demonstration of how you can use
two-dimensional arrays let's get started
with how to create and use a
three-dimensional array or how to go
about using multi-dimensional arrays in
java so as you can see from this image
we talked about 1d array which is having
just one access then we talked about 2d
arrays in the last session where we had
rows and columns basically an x axis and
a y axis and then we can also have a 3d
array which will have three axises which
will have an x
a y-axis
and also a z-axis
think of a simple box which every box in
this world will always have at least
three dimensions and from from here you
can go even build more complex arrays
which can have four dimensions or five
dimensions or as many dimensions as you
want it to have and today we are going
to look at an example of how can we
build a 3d array and how do we access
those elements but this picture is just
to show you the mental model of when you
will be creating a 3d array so for
example generally an image data is
stored in in three dimensions so you can
you might want to store the image data
into a 3d array and there can be many
other use cases in the mathematical and
research computational use cases where
you might want to use a 3d array so but
remember there is an x axis there
there's a y axis and then there is a
third axis which is called the z axis
so let us look at a java program to
understand how we can build a three
dimensional array and for that i have
created this class which is called
multi-dimensional array it has a entry
point method which is the public static
void main method and then i have created
an integer array and this time instead
of one or two square brackets i have
three square brackets and if you
remember i mentioned this in the
previous session as well the number of
square brackets which you're going to
put while initializing the array is the
number of dimensions of the array and
since in this particular program i'm
going to demonstrate a three-dimensional
array that's why you see three square
blocks boxes let me just minimize this
yep so we have three square boxes here
and we have created the variable name as
ar
or short form as ary then we start with
the outermost curly braces as is then we
put another curly braces which starts
from here and it ends here then another
set of curly brace which starts from
here and end here so this is the this is
the first dimension this is the second
dimensions and these are the third
dimensions that's how you're going to
define the different dimensions remember
this is the first dimension when the
first curly brace starts then you have
the second dimension which covers this
hole and this hole and then you have
third dimension which are these so
that's how you're going to visualize and
and put the three dimensions in use
while declaring a three-dimensional
array and the values work in the same
fashion it's it's a zero index based
position so since we do not have an
official name for the third dimension so
i'm just gonna use x-axis y-axis and z
axis to refer to the three axises so
this would be x of 0
this would be
y of 0 and this would be z of 0.
similarly x of 1 y of 1 and z of 1 and
so on so forth
so now if i try to access the value
which is at zeroth x position
first y position and second z position
what's the value do we get here let's
run this program and understand and
interpret the output okay
so when we ran this program we got the
output as 11 so let's understand this
output so when we say the zeroth
position on x the first position on y
and the second position on z
so this is the zeroth position on x
and this is the first position on y
and then
this element is 0 1 2 is the second
position on the z axis so to to describe
it in a nutshell this defines the x axis
so we have two elements on the x axis
here this one and this one then we have
two elements on the y-axis on each
x-axis so this is one this is two on the
first x-axis and this is one and this is
two on the second y and second x-axis
so 2x and 2y and then on the z-axis i
have three elements each
so hope this helps you understand and
visualize this so x-axis and this one is
other x-axis and then y-axis
y-axis and then elements inside this are
z-axis
so i'm saying zero with x-axis in this
block first on the y-axis which is this
block and then second element or the z
or second position element on this
particular axis in this particular block
which is 11 and that's why we get 11. if
i print
0 let's say
i change this particular value as 1. so
now the output should be coming from
this side so second x position because
it's one second y position so this will
go here and then the two position which
is the third element of the z axis which
is 13. so let's see if we get 13. yes we
get 13 here
so this is just to show you how you can
interpret this particular array and
always be mindful of how you are
structuring this array if your structure
is gone wrong then your program will
become useless and it will give you a
lot of unpredictable outputs which might
not make sense and which may introduce
errors in your program so be very
careful how you define the structure of
the elements here that's the key and
after that you just need to understand
the x-axis the y-axis and the z-axis
always remember all the accesses start
from 0 so when i say 2 i'm basically
referring to the third element and not
the second element so this is all i
wanted to cover in this particular
session where we describe how we can use
a three dimensional array and from here
you can go to any lens like i said you
can add more square brackets here and go
to four dimension or five dimension or
six dimension but remember the more
dimensions you add the more complexity
of the program will be having the
program will become more and more
difficult to debug and understand so
always try to take a wise call as to how
many dimensions you want to use in your
array let's get started with how to use
do while loops now in the previous
session we covered the usage of while
loops but we have another type of while
loop which is called a do while loop so
let's understand when do we need that
and how do you actually use that let me
switch to the java documentation and if
i can find some syntax of it as well yep
so as you can see here if i just
highlight this portion this is how you
actually write a do while statement
block
so you write do you start a code block
you write some executable statements and
then after the code block ends you write
a while expression and end it with
semicolon this is the syntax basically
it starts with do or curly braces some
executable statements a while block or a
while statement basically with an
expression ending with a semicolon let's
understand this with the help of a
program to understand the structure
better so for this i have created a
sample program here which is called do
while demo again having a public static
void main method and it has a variable
which is count and it is initialized as
one then i write do i write this code
block or the curly braces and then i am
just printing the value of count then i
am incrementing the value of count
and then i am writing a condition which
says while count is less than 10 and
semicolon if you compare this with the
previous demo we ran if i just put them
side by side we had while condition
statement
and
the state change condition here we have
do statement condition change statement
and then we check the condition at the
end so the idea is that if you have a
use case
where before you even evaluate the
condition you want to print something
even before you evaluate the condition
if you want to do something in that case
you will use the do while loop even
before the while actual while loop
starts if you want to execute a
statement you will use do while loop for
example if you want to print the initial
value of the count even before the
condition checks then you can use do
while loop if that is not your use case
you can use a simple while loop which is
described here in this program so coming
back to the do while so i say do and
then i'm saying print this particular
statement without checking anything this
condition will be executed for the first
time without any condition check at all
this will just work as is like a normal
java statement after that i am
incrementing the value of the count and
then i am checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked the first increment has
already happened but in the while case
we did the comparison before even the
first increment the first comparison
happened with the original value of
count but here the first comparison is
happening with the incremented value of
the count hope you get the difference in
a better context now that you will use
this when you want to do some write some
initialization code before you actually
hit the condition so this condition will
be evaluated with 2 less than 10 and
then the value will be printed let's
print this example and we'll also try to
play around with this example a bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better
if i run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it will go back
to statement number 9 again print this
again do an increment on the count and
again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say 3 less than 10 now similarly print
the value increment check this will
continue to happen till this particular
condition becomes false and once this
condition is false it will exit out of
this whole blue while loop and it will
go to the line number 12 and if you have
any statement written there you can that
statement will be executed in this case
so let's try to change some values here
and let's see if if if we can make sense
of this program if you change the value
let's say if i put 11 here what will
happen now let's run this program you
will see the
now you will see that this particular
output is displayed which says count is
11 so what happened here that count was
11 it entered the do while block it went
to this particular statement which said
count is 11 then it incremented the
value so the value became 12 and
obviously 12 is not less than 10 so it
did not print it again it only printed
once even if the first time the
condition was checked the first
condition execution itself resulted in
false
still line number nine got successfully
printed and that's the whole that's the
whole idea behind using the do while
what if i change this value to 10 let's
see what happens
and after that we'll run one more
combination to just make it more
interesting this time again count is 10
line number 10 will be printed as count
is 10 then at line number 10 the count
is incremented to 11 and 11 is not less
than 10 so in this case
the loop ends and it will move out now
what happens if i do this
if i say less than equal to here let's
run this program and interpret the
output now again only one statement is
printed because in this case the count
is 10 10 is printed here and we are
saying 10 plus 1 11 11 is still not less
than equal to 10 and that's why the loop
just exits let's make it nine and see
what happens
now you see two values so count is nine
it enters the do-while loop goes to
statement number nine prints the current
value of count which is nine then
increments the value to 10
then at line number 11 this while
statement is executed and the condition
is checked is 10 less than equal to 10
yes 10 is not less than but 10 is equal
to 10 so this condition will hold true
it will go back here print count is 10
make count 11 again check the condition
is 11 less than equal to 10 no it's not
and then the condition will return to
false and loop will be exited so hope
this will give you a better
understanding now since we ran different
permutations and combinations of the
values and we saw when this will be
executed and when this will not be
executed but the bottom line is very
straightforward that whenever you want
to write some pre-processing logic even
before checking the very first condition
of your loop then in that case you will
be using a do while loop otherwise a
normal while loop or a for loop will
absolutely work fine let's get started
with understanding the loop statements
in java so first of all understand why
do we need loop statements so generally
whenever you are dealing with some data
structures in java
which can store multiple elements for
example we saw array which can store
multiple elements string is also
basically technically a character array
which is storing multiple characters so
whenever you have these kind of data
structures where you have multiple
elements being stored in the same uh
then in that case you would like to have
a way to iterate or access all of the
elements in a seamless fashion one of
the ways is to access them individually
one by one but that's too much of work
that's too much of code there has to be
a simpler way of accessing all the
elements one by one if i want to and
that's where the majority of the use
cases for using loops coming to picture
now java provides multiple constructs to
write loops in java there is a while
loop there is a do while loop there is a
for loop there is also an enhanced for
loop and in the previous versions of
java a use case of iterator was also
very popular so there are multiple ways
in which you can actually iterate over a
collection and access all the elements
of the collection one by one and you can
use it to multiple useful cases for
example if you have a huge i of employee
salary and you want to give bonus to
each of the employees and add the bonus
to the salary then you need to do this
edition for all the employees it would
be nice to have to return a while loop
and the while loop can automatically
access all the employees salary one by
one and keep adding the bonus to the
salary this would be an easier way to do
this rather than individually updating
each employee salary and the first loop
statement we are going to understand is
a while loop so
the syntax of while loop is very
straightforward you write the y keyword
you enter the actual condition which
will be evaluating to a boolean true or
false so you write the expression which
will be a boolean expression exactly
similar to the conditions which you are
used to write in your if statements so
you write your condition which will
evaluate to either true or false and
then you write your statement and these
statements will keep executing till the
time this particular expression
evaluates to true so generally the way
it works is that it will enter the while
block it will evaluate the expression if
the expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed and after the
execution of the statement it will again
go back again evaluate the expression we
call them steps basically so it will go
to the next step again evaluate the
expression if this again if this still
holds true it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the ide and look at an example of it so
i have already created while demo for it
here it is it looks very small and
simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why we
will be using the while loops so i've
created a wild demo class i've added a
public static void main method here
which is the entry point i have declared
a variable which is int count equal to 1
so the count value is 1 right now and
then i'm writing a condition here i'm
saying while count is less than 10 do
this
so it will print the current value of
count and after that i'm using the post
increment unary operator if you remember
we covered this in the previous sessions
what is the meaning of this it basically
will increment the value of count by one
this expression is e is equivalent to if
i write it in this way if i write count
equal to count plus one this is exactly
the same as this no difference so this
will have the same impact i will just
remove this line because we already have
the count plus plus here so if we try to
understand this we are basically
incrementing the count and then checking
the condition again so at first time it
will be 1 less than 10 yes that is true
it will go inside and print the count
value the current count value which will
be 1 and then it does count plus plus so
now the count value becomes 2 it will
again go back here again check the
condition saying is 2 less than 10 yes
that is true so the while condition
again becomes true it will again go
inside this print the current value of
count which is 2 then do count plus plus
so it will again increment the value of
count so the now the count value becomes
3 again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10 yes that is
still true again come here print the 3
again go here make count as 4 4 less
than 10 prints 4 again count plus plus
count becomes 5 and so on so forth it
will keep doing that till the value
becomes 10 so at a step when count plus
plus results in the count value being
updated to 10 it will go here and say is
10 less than 10 now that is not true
because 10 is equal to 10 but 10 is not
less than 10 so this condition will
become false and it will exit of this
while loop and it will come here and it
will execute if there's if there was
anything written after the while loop
that will be executed so that's the idea
that you want to do something till a
particular condition holds true then you
can use the while loop define your
condition and execute the statements and
try to do something which changes the
state of this condition here i am
changing the count so that every time a
new evaluation happens if i comment this
this will result in an infinite loop
because 1 will always be less than 10 i
will not be incrementing the count here
and it will keep running forever it will
never stop it will just keep printing
one one one every time till your
computer program runs out of the memory
so always remember not to end up into an
infinite loop that's probably one of the
biggest mistakes any beginner programmer
does so please try to be aware of that
particular loophole not try to run an
infinite loop always try to write
something in the code block which can
change the state of the condition and
also make sure that that state condition
sometimes sometime should become false
you should also make sure that that all
that always becomes false because if i
do this if i do this then this condition
will always remain true because it is
already 1 then it will become 0 then it
will become minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 so
and so forth but that value of count
will forever be less than 10 and again
you will never be able to exit this loop
your program will be stuck in this loop
till your program runs out of the memory
so always remember to write a statement
or a statement of execution in your in
your code block which can change the
state of the condition which results in
some eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and that's
it after 9 the moment the count plus
plus resulted into the count value
becoming 10 it checked that condition
and then it just came out of the loop
because 10 is not less than 10 and the
condition became false so always do
something inside your code block which
results at least of one scenario where
this condition becomes false and that is
how you can use the while loop now you
can see this is a pretty generic code
and you can write any kind of condition
here write any code you want to execute
here and then do something to change the
state of the condition as well in a
positive way in a way which results this
particular condition to be false at some
point of time and then your while loop
will run fine so this is all i wanted to
cover in terms of the while loop let's
get started with for loops in java so so
far we covered about while loops and
do-while loops and we also saw different
examples of using different types of
data structures like arrays but one of
the core requirements whenever you are
working with any kind of collection is
to iterate over it exactly similar to
what i explained in the do while and
while lectures that you would often
require to iterate over a collection or
a data structure and for that one of the
most sophisticated and easiest way to do
that is using for loops so let's
understand the syntax of for loop first
and then we will also look at an example
of it in the in the eclipse ide
so i have just opened the official java
docs here so if you see this is
basically the syntax of a for loop
statement so let's understand it and
let's also try to compare it with a
while loop so that we can understand how
it compares with the while loop so if we
see the syntax we first see the term
initialization
then we see the term termination and
then we see the term called increment
now if i try to compare it with a while
loop
there also you basically did these three
things you first initialized a variable
outside the while loop which is called
initialization and then you wrote a
condition
which is your termination condition you
wrote a condition saying let's say while
i is greater than 10 or while i is less
than 10. so that is the condition which
is also the termination statement the
loop will continue to execute till that
condition
evaluates to false and that's when the
loop terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the i plus plus
which we used to do in the while loops
so these three portions together
make or constitute any kind of loop in
any kind of programming language and for
loop if you see the the kind of code
which you use to write in a while loop
in multiple lines where you first
initialize a variable then you write a
condition in the while block and then
inside the while block you use to
increment the variable all of that can
be done in a single line in the for loop
and that's why i said it is the most
sophisticated and easiest way to write
loops in java so you write all of these
three things the initialization the
condition and the increment or decrement
values in a single line and then you
start with a curly braces and you write
the code which you want to keep
executing till the condition evaluates
to false that's the basic syntax of it
so let us try to understand this with
the help of an example so here i have
opened a class which is called for demo
and this is a class which will
demonstrate the usage of a for loop so
again we have a public static void main
method which you can see here which is
the entry point and then i use the
keyword for i put standard
braces for the brackets and then i do
the initialization so this part is the
initialization part you initialize the
variable so i just say in try equal to 1
initialization done you end it with a
semicolon so that it is a single
statement understood by java and then
you write this condition which is your
evaluation slash termination condition
so this condition is basically the the
deciding factor of how long your loops
should run it's exactly similar to what
you use to write in the while block if i
just show you the example this is what
we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while uh syntax or the
construct and then we did the increment
here so we are doing all of these three
steps but we are doing it in a single
line so this is the condition and then
we write our increment or decrement
values which are going to change the
evaluation condition every time at every
step so we are saying i plus plus
so technically what i am saying here is
that start with i equal to 1 and then
check the condition i less than 10 so in
the in the first step it will be
checking if 1 is less than 10 if the
condition holds true go inside the for
loop execute the statement at line
number 7 and then go back to this
particular statement so we do y plus
plus so i becomes 2 and then you again
go back to the condition and again you
check if 2 is less than 10 yes it is so
again you go inside inside the for loop
and do whatever is written there there
can be multiple statements here for now
i have just written one
system.out.println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
does the increment so two plus one
becomes three again does the evaluation
exec and if the if the condition holds
true it will again go inside so this
will continue this condition checking
execution and increment will continue
till the time this condition holds true
the moment this condition becomes false
the control will come out at line number
nine so that's the basic anatomy and
control flow it's very important to
understand the control flow of a for
loop otherwise you might end up into a
program which is forever running and
which will just eat up all the memory
available in your jvm so be very sure of
what you write in your for loop be very
sure of specially these two parts the
condition and the increment or decrement
so this is very important piece the
initialization happens only once and
then this condition evaluates if the
condition holds to true some code
executes
goes back to the changing statement
which can be an increment to decrement
whatever and again compares the updated
value with the condition so this will
keep happening let's run this code to
interpret the output
so i will right click go to run as java
application
and if i
interpret the output here i can see that
it started with count is 1 2 3 four five
six seven eight and nine it stopped at
nine so what happened there let's try to
evaluate the termination condition so
let's say i has become nine and nine is
less than ten so it goes inside and it
prints count is 9 which is i then it
goes here and it says 9 plus 1 i plus
plus means 9 plus 1 the current value of
i plus 1 it becomes 10 and then it again
compares the condition so now 10 is not
less than 10 10 is equal to 10 but it is
not less than 10 so the condition
becomes false and count is 10 is never
printed because this condition has
become false it will jump out so let's
say if i do this
if i put an equal to here and if i now
execute the same program
this time i will see 10 here and because
i have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the i will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite loops for
example if i say i equal to 1 i leave it
that and i say i minus minus so what
happens i equal to 1 1 is less than 10
yes it goes here prints the value and
then i decrement the value i don't
increment the value i decrement the
value so whatever value comes out will
always be less than 10 and this loop
will run forever for fun let's try to
run this and i will i will have to kill
this program manually but just to show
you what happens and what you should not
do in your inner java program so you see
it will continuously keep printing the
values till the program runs out of
memory till it eats up all the available
memory it is cut it is forever running
it will never stop because the condition
will never remain never never evaluate
to false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever so i'm
just gonna kill the program but this is
something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers let's get started with
enhanced for loops in java so we covered
about the for loops and the structure of
it and the control flow of it in the
previous session and today we are just
going to talk about another way of
writing for loops which is a bit even
more smarter than the traditional for
loops which we call as enhanced for
loops we generally use the enhanced for
loops for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for loop and this for loop is
even simpler like i said it's even
simpler than writing a classic for loop
and the syntax is
simply like this you again start with
four put the standard brackets and then
let's start from the right most because
then i will be able to explain it better
you specify the collection in the right
most side of the bracket the collection
can be an array it can be a list can be
a map so whatever different kind of
collections which are available in java
and we are going to cover collections in
detail so don't worry if you don't
understand what are lists and what are
maps and what are sets we will go into
detail of each of these one by one in
the upcoming sessions but the idea is
that you put the collection to the
rightmost then you put a colon and then
you put a representation of the member
of this collection so for example here
this numbers is basically an int array
so this int array means that this array
can only hold integer numbers and that's
why we write int here because this array
is only having integers then we put any
placeholder variable name this can be
anything you can even write it as i if
you want to you can write it as anything
any variable name which you want to
write this is a temporary variable so
now this code is going to execute in a
manner that it is going to iterate over
this array one by one starting from the
first element going till the last
element you don't need to write any
initialization code you don't need to
write any termination condition code and
you don't need to write any increment or
decrement code also and how these threes
how these three values are actually
taken care of let's understand that as
well so when we talk about the
initialization as i have put an array
here a data structure here the automatic
initialization index is going to be the
first index so when we do the iteration
when this for loop is going to execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable with the value at
the first index which is the index 0 as
you know that array is a 0 index based
structure then comes the condition part
so the condition evaluation is going to
be again based on the size of the array
or the size of the data structure which
you are using it is going to start from
the first index which is the index 0
and it is going to iterate till the
arrays last element is reached so
technically start from the index 0 and
go till the last element that's your
evaluation condition and then comes the
increment part so at each step after it
has
successfully accessed the first element
automatically the index is going to be
updated to pointing to the next element
so if it starts from here once the first
step iteration is complete i is
automatically going to be incremented to
index one and then it will basically
this i will be holding two then in the
next iteration the same i is going to be
holding three similarly i will keep
holding the new value of the collection
item one by one till the collection
items last element is reached so this is
the basic premise that you can write a
collection variable here and keep
iterating over it and this whatever
variable you write here will hold the
current item's value one by one so in
the first step this i is going to hold
one in the second step this is going to
hold two in the third step this i is
going to hold 3 and so on so forth
that's the basic idea so now let's run
this program to see what kind of output
do we get so you can see we
basically are able to print all the
elements of the array and that's
probably one of the most popular usage
as well that if you want to just print
all the elements or access all the
elements of
array or a collection one by one then
just use enhanced for loop so you can
see at each step it is printing the
value of i and the value of i is
basically the subsequent elements of the
array that's the whole idea with
enhanced for loop under the hoods if you
talk about how does it work under the
hood it is actually using the classic
for loop construct itself but for
developers it is making it easier
because it knows that if you are
iterating over a collection you will
start with the first element and you
will go till the last element so it
knows the initialization value the
termination condition and it also knows
the increment condition and that's the
reason you will use enhanced for loops
in java for iterating over collections
let's get started with nested for loops
in java so we talked about the while
loops the do-while loops the classic for
loop also the enhanced for loop so now
we are going to look at a variation of
the classic for loops in a in a
condition where we have to use more than
one loop in a nested fashion and how do
we do that what are the use cases when
we use that so in front of you you can
see an example which i have prepared for
nested for loops and in this particular
example i have created a two dimensional
array as you can see on the line number
six i have created an integer array and
i have put two square brackets here
which are basically symbolizing that
this is a two dimensional array so this
two dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for loops
to print this 2d array in a 2d matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly let's first try
to
interpret this particular 2d array so we
have a curly braces outside and then we
have these three inner elements which
symbolizes three rows basically so this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and then each
of the rows have three elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values so it's basically a 3
into 3 2d array which has 3 rows and 3
columns so so we can say that this is
basically a 3 into 3 array which has 3
dimensions on the row side and 3
dimensions on the column side or just a
three by three matrix or three by three
2d array so as we know that in case of
arrays everything starts from zero so
technically if we talk about the indexes
it would be the index 0 index 1 and
index 2 on the row side and similarly
index 0 index 1 and index 2 on the
column side so that's that's something
which you should remember because we are
going to use this particular concept
when we write the for loop so let's try
to write the for loop now if you look at
line number 8 we put this keyword called
for and then we write the initialization
so we say int i equal to 0 then we are
writing the termination condition and we
are saying
run this particular loop run this whole
loop which ends at line 13 till i is
less than 3 and keep incrementing i at
every step that's what i'm doing in the
line number 8 then inside the for loop i
am writing another for loop which has
another different variable called j it
can be anything you can name it anything
you want and this also starts with zero
and this also has a similar condition
which is which says run this particular
loop the line 10 basically or this loop
which is signified by this curly braces
run this particular loop till the time
the value of j is less than 3 and keep
incrementing j at every step and at line
number 10 print the element of array
which has the current value of i and the
current value of j these are basically
the positions these are not the elements
the element would be represented by this
hole but print the element which is at
current i and j's position values that's
what this code means so let's try to do
a dry run on this particular code to
understand how this is going to work so
at first we have i equal to 0 0 is less
than 3 and it goes inside it initializes
j as well with 0 and j is 0 is also less
than 3 so this condition went through
that's why we went to line number nine
and line number nine condition also went
to true so we went to line number 10.
remember that
in this particular case at line number
10 the values of i and j are 0 and 0
respectively and we are saying print the
array of 0 and 0. so 0th rows 0th column
element should be printed so this is the
0th row because this is the first first
sub block and this is the first element
so in this case in line number ten two
should get printed then it goes here and
it increments the j to one so zero plus
one becomes one it again checks the
condition is one less than three so yes
one is less than three it goes here
remember it did not go up at line number
eight it just came back from line number
nine so when it comes here i is still
zero but j has moved from zero to one so
now we are trying to access the element
which is at 0th row first column which
is going to be
7 so 7 is going to get printed similarly
on the next iteration j is going to get
incremented from 1 to 2 and again the
condition will be evaluated so 2 is less
than 3 all good it will again come back
to line number 10 and now it will say
print the value of zero row third or the
second column or the third element so
zeroth row third element which is the
nine so nine will get printed then again
j will be incremented and j will become
three two plus one three and now the
condition will be evaluated is three
less than three no it is not less than 3
the condition becomes false so it breaks
out of the loop goes to line number 12
prints an empty line because we are not
writing anything here so it will just
print a blank line and now it will go
back to line number eight's condition
and it will do an increment of i and now
i will move from zero to one and now the
evaluation will happen is one less than
three yes one is less than three so it
will again go to line number nine again
initialize j with a fresh zero the
previous j got destroyed the moment you
came out of the loop so this is a new j
so this j again gets initialized to zero
zero is less than three it goes here
remember i was 1 in this time so now it
will print the value of this 2d array
which is sitting at
0 basically second row first element so
second row first element which is 3
again j is going to get incremented and
it will become from 0 to 1 so 1 is less
than 3 yes it will again come here and
it will print the value of the array
which is sitting at array of 1 comma 1
for row equal to 1 and column equal to 1
which will be 6. similarly j will get
incremented again again 2 is less than 3
come back here we'll print 1 then again
we'll increment j j will become 3 3 is
less than 3 no it's false the condition
is false so it jumps out of the loop
goes to line number 12 prints a blank
line again goes back to
8 line number 8
increments i and i now becomes 2 2 is
less than 3 yes it will again go here
initialize j again with 0 and again does
the same thing for the row 2 and column
0 1 2 and again it will come out of the
loop this time again when it will go
here the value will become from 2 to 3
and 3 is not less than 3 so then it will
break out of the outer loop so the idea
is execute the inner loop for every
value of the outer loop remember this
line because that is how
you will be applying your knowledge of
nested for loops to be used in certain
condition so whenever you have a
scenario where you have to iterate over
a collection based on a certain value of
another collection then you can use
nested for loops or you have a scenario
where you have to iterate over 2d or 3d
arrays for example if we were dealing
with 3d arrays then you would have seen
three nested for loops here and where it
will apply the same logic that iterate
over all the collections all the values
of the inner loop on our particular
value of the outer loop then increment
the value of the outer loop and do the
same thing again iterate over all the
values of the inner loop based on a
fixed value of the outer loop so let's
run this program and let's see what kind
of output do we get
so like i said our motive our target was
to print this in a style and you can see
that it is printing in it in a sort of a
matrix representation so the first row
gets printed here then the second row
gets printed here and then the third row
gets printed here if you try to decipher
it it will work exactly the same way as
i explained
so i equal to 0
0 less than 3 condition becomes true
comes here j equal to 0 j less than 3
condition becomes true comes here prints
the array of 0 comma 0 which is 2 then
prints the array of 0 comma 1 which is 7
0 comma 2 which is 9 then j becomes 3 it
breaks out of the loop goes up here i
becomes from 0 to 1 1 is less than 3 yes
again comes here re-initializes a fresh
for loop with a new j setting to zero
and it will it will print the array of
one zero one one one two then similarly
array of two zero to one two two so
that's basically what we are doing we
are iterating we are picking the first
row and iterating all elements of it
picking the second row hydrating all
elements over it and so on so forth you
can do this for any n-dimensional kind
of array or a collection let's get
started with collections in java or the
collections framework in java i must say
that this is probably the most important
concept of the java programming language
which you will be using heavily whenever
you are working in any production grade
application so let's understand the
collections framework and the different
classes and the utilities available
inside the collections framework this is
going to be a theoretical lecture
because there is a lot of ground to
cover in this lecture so we will only
focus on understanding the relationship
between the classes why those classes
are created because each class has a
different purpose in this framework and
we will obviously talk about the
hierarchy as well in the upcoming
sessions we will go into the hands-on
exercise of some of the most popular
collections we will not be able to
provide hands-on of all the collections
classes which you which you can see on
the screen because then it is going to
take a very very long time to complete
this concept but we will cover the most
popular ones or the most used ones out
of this particular framework so let's
get started as you can see
let's first understand some of the
symbols here and let me just zoom this
in a bit so that it's visible yep now
that i have just increased the
resolution a bit so you can see there
are three different symbols or legends
here you see this oval shape which is
called interface so you can see some
interfaces here then you see this
rectangular blue box which is called
abstract class and you can see some of
these blue boxes and then you see the
purple box which is called the class and
you see some classes here these ones so
for now we are currently we haven't
covered the concept of interfaces and
abstract classes but we will cover that
in the coming lectures and for
understanding the collections hierarchy
right now the at least the concepts of
it you don't need to be fully aware of
the concept of interfaces or abstract
classes so let's dive deeper into the
framework i table is basically an
interface
to give you a very simple definition of
an interface interface basically is sort
of a declaration which will tell you
what kind of classes will be present
under the interface for example if you
have to let's just store all the cars
and all the bikes and all the bicycles
and all the trucks from all around the
world then you can create an interface
called vehicle and create all of these
classes under the interface and these
classes will be about cars
about trucks
and about other kind of vehicles so an
interface is a generic blueprint of
specific class implementation that's a
very simple definition of an interface
and like i said we will go deeper into
this concept in the upcoming lectures
so that was about interfaces similarly
when we talk about abstract classes the
next legend here abstract classes are
also similar to interfaces where they
provide you a generalization but at the
same time abstract classes provide you a
way to also write some concrete
implementation
for example if we take the example of a
bank account so there
in a bank you have different kinds of
accounts you have sales accounts you
have recurring accounts you have current
accounts and there are many other
different types of accounts so
there would be some common
implementation and logic which will be
applicable to all the account types for
example an account must have an account
holder that account holder must have a
valid kyc done for example so there
would be some sort of common logic which
will be applicable to all of these right
so that common logic so you have two
options either you can write that common
logic again and again in the savings
account class in the current account
class in the loan account class etc etc
or you can write it at a central place
and just refer it from there so that's
where you will you will use abstract
classes so you will create an abstract
class of an account and then you will
create these child classes under this
account class which will be the savings
account class the loan account class the
current account class etc so this is a
very lightning introduction to you about
interfaces and abstract classes and
class as we know is basically a concrete
blueprint which holds data and logic
together so here i table is an interface
which will just specify that all the
kinds of data structure which can be
iterated which can be looped over should
be present under this particular
interface that's why we created this
interface
so
under i table we have this collections
interface and this will govern that
everything which will present under the
collection interface will be
holding
some sort of a collection of items now
we look at the next set of interfaces we
see a set interface we see a list
interface and we see a queue interface
when we talk about the set interface
these three different types of
interfaces represent three different
properties of collection and these
properties are exclusive of each other
for example if we talk about set so set
has a property that everything which you
put into set will be unique it will
never ever tolerate or contain any
duplicate elements that's the property
offset so now you can see whenever you
have a scenario where there is a strict
constraint that your collection should
never have duplicates you will use sets
when we talk about lists list is
probably the most lenient representation
of a collection it can store anything it
can store duplicates as well it will not
raise an error or a warning if you store
same element multiple times it will
happily store it but at the same time
the list is basically an index based
collection you can access the elements
starting from the index 0 till the last
element that's the basic value
proposition so whenever you have a
requirement where you want to access the
elements into a predefined sequence and
one by one then you should use list also
the order is fixed here the first
element will always come after the
zeroth element the second element will
always come after the first element so
whenever you iterate over this
particular list you will never have a
scenario where you do not know the order
of the elements being accessed they will
always be accessed in a predefined order
so it's basic we can call it as an
indexed ordered collection which can
hold duplicates then the third one is
cue here so q is basically as you can
this is basically inspired from real
world so think of any queue if you if
you go to buy something at a grocery
store or if you go to buy a ticket at a
railway station or you go to the
check-in counter at the airports so you
stand in a queue and the concept of
queue is that it works on a concept of
first in first out the person who first
went into the queue will be the person
first being served and coming out of the
queue and if the second person come that
has to be standing behind the first
person and once the first person is
served and goes out of the queue the
second person comes at the front of the
queue and that that particular person is
served so you can see it's
if you have to store that kind of
behavior or if you have to implement
that kind of behavior in a java program
then you would use queues
so so this was about the top level
interfaces which are set list and queue
and out of these list and set are very
very popularly used very heavily used in
any kind of java enterprise grade
application now there are more
interfaces like sorted set navigable set
and dq sorted set is basically
forcing additional constraint on the set
that the elements will be unique at the
same time you can also have the elements
into a sorted order the sorting can be
an incremental sorting or decremental
sorting that depends but the whole idea
is that it will be sorted similarly
navigable set brings another navigation
kind of properties dq is basically a
double ended queue where the elements
can be inserted and removed both from
the front and from the back so there are
the different properties of these
interfaces but like i said the most
popular ones are these three ones now
let's talk about the abstract classes so
the abstract classes you see here are
abstract collection abstract set
abstract list abstract queue abstract
sequential list generally you will not
be using these directly you don't need
to use them directly but you should be
aware that they exist if you have a very
specific case where you want to use
these abstract classes you can use them
in java program but most of the time you
don't need to use them and most of the
times you will be dealing with either
the interfaces or you will be dealing
with the concrete classes now this
lecture is getting a bit long so i will
like to stop this lecture here so we
covered about the interfaces part of the
collection and we also understood a bit
about the abstract classes though we are
not going to use abstract classes in
much detail in the programs let's get
started with discussing the concrete
classes in the collections framework in
the previous session we talked about the
interfaces part of it where we discussed
about sets the lists and the queues and
we also touched a bit upon the abstract
classes and like i mentioned earlier you
don't need to generally use these
abstract classes directly in your java
program but you must be aware that they
exist you see some arrows here right if
you see if i just scroll up you see
multiple kind of arrows here these
arrows mean that if the arrow goes from
bottom to top it means
this particular element is a type of the
parent it's basically a denoting a
parent child kind of relationship so for
example here you see tree set is
basically
a navigable set and also extend extends
abstract set which extends sept so
similarly you can see all kind of
complex relationships here and generally
you don't need to remember all of those
you only need to remember the few and
those few are basically easily can be
spotted for example whenever you see a
tree set it means it's basically a type
of set whenever you see a word called
list that means that it is a type of
list and you all whenever you see a word
called q then it means that it is a type
of queue so let's understand these
classes let's first go to the list
interface so you can see list interface
has the relationship with abstract list
and from there it goes down to array
list abstract list has another child
which is called abstract sequential list
which is another abstract class and
which has a concrete class which is
called linked list so let's understand
these two collections or these two
types of list right now so when we talk
about arraylist let's understand this we
already have covered arrays
so what are arraylist they are very
similar to arrays in in a way that they
are also indexed based collections so
you can store elements and access them
based on the index position starting
from 0 going till the length minus 1
index and this is an ordered collection
you can access the elements only in a
predefined sequence it can obviously
accept duplicates as well and these all
are properties are also applicable to
arrays the differentiating factor here
is that arraylist is a dynamic array
it's not a static array if you remember
when we talked about arrays we had to
initialize it or we had to specify a
fixed size of it while we initialize it
once you have initialized the array size
you cannot change the array size it is
static it is fixed so if you have
created an array of elements 10 and if
you are trying to store the 11th element
you are going to get an array of array
index bound of exception but in case of
array list it dynamically updates its
size based on the number of elements
stored you can still initialize it with
some some initial size let's say you
initialize an array list and you say
that you want to initialize it with a
size of 10 elements absolutely fine but
the moment you start you try to store
the 11th element array list is going to
dynamically update its size from 10 to
something else so it will keep updating
its size based on the number of number
of elements which are coming to the
collection that's the whole property of
arraylist so remember it's it's used in
the cases when you have an ordered
collection to store and you want to
access them based on the index
and you want a dynamic update of the
size the second sibling of it which is
linked list is also a type of list but
it has slightly different properties
than arraylist in case of arraylist it
was an indexed based collection you
access the element based on the indexes
but in linked list you access the
elements based on the previous and the
next element that's pretty much what it
knows so an item can only be accessed in
a particular sequence starting from head
to the tail and when we talk about
linked list the idea is that you have an
element which will have a data and it
will also have a pointer or up basically
a reference that reference will be
pointing to the next element in the
linked list similarly the next element
will store the value the actual data and
it will also store a reference to the
next element so you can see if you have
to go to the fifth element you cannot
directly say link list of five the way
you can say this in arraylist because
arraylist is an index space position a
list right so you can access the zeroth
element or the fifth element or the
tenth element directly just in one line
for one go but in case of linked list
you cannot access the fifth element or
the last element of the linked list
directly you have to start from the
first element and keep jumping the
references till you reach the last
element that's the property of linked
list so these are the two types of list
now let's talk about the type of
set a type of set which is not mentioned
here is hash set which is a very popular
type so a set generally has two popular
types hash set and preset so let's talk
about both of those if i talk about hash
set the property is that it will inherit
the existing properties of set which is
that element should be unique that's
good but along with that hash set will
not remember or honor the order in which
the elements are inserted into it it
will if let's say if you insert 15 or 20
different elements inside hash set and
then if you try to iterate over the hash
set every time the order in which the
elements are accessed and printed will
be different every time the order of
accession will be different every time
the act the way in which the elements
are accessed their order will be
different
you cannot predict that and that's the
property of hash set whereas when you
talk about reset in case of tree set you
can have a sort of fixed order and a
tree hierarchy so a tree hierarchy if
you know about the tree data structure
from the data structure and algorithm
section you already would know what a
tree looks like basically it has a root
and it has child this is basically you
can call this all tree as well right so
whenever you have to store the values in
a in a tree fashion where you can
navigate through the parent and childs
then you would use the preset and
remember since it is a set it will still
inherit the uniqueness property of set
so that's about hash set and preset so
we covered about list we covered about
sets now let's talk about these ones
which are vector stack and parity queue
so let's first understand about priority
queue so you would use a priority queue
when you need a fifo arrangement but at
the same time if there are few elements
in the queue which cannot wait to be
executed or processed when their turn
comes they wanted to be executed on
priority so whenever you have such use
case where you want to to maintain a
fifo fashion collection but at the same
time you also want to allow few elements
of it to override this fifa arrangement
and get processed ahead of their queue
number so you can use priority queue in
those cases talking about stack let's
understand stack first and stack is a
leaf arrangement last in first out
so remember in your house when you when
you put plates uh the the normal dinner
plates over one or one over each other
you are basically creating a stack so
the property is that the plate which is
put first on the table
will be picked up at the very last and
the plate which is put the last on the
stack let's say you put five plates on
top of one uh one on top of other then
the fifth plate will be consumed first
anybody would pick the plate from the
very top they will not pick the bottom
plate because it's it's almost
impossible if you have a big stack you
cannot pull out the bottom most plate
the stack will fall down so you will
always pick out the elements from the
top so it has a leaf arrangement so
whenever you have to create a last in
first out kind of arrangement in your
program for storing collections you will
use stack talking about vectors vectors
are very similar to lists they are
exactly similar there is basically one
major difference is that vectors are
thread safe and lists are not thread
safe now list has provided a way to be
thread safe we will cover that later but
for now you can understand that whenever
you have a program in which you want to
access a collection in a thread safe
manner where two threads cannot modify
the same element at the same time then
you will use vectors so we covered about
the complete collections framework
classes the interfaces and the abstract
classes and always remember the uh the
reason why you will use arraylist or
linked list or a hash set or a tree set
or a vector or a priority queue or a
stack that is the most important concept
i want you to take away from this
session let's get started with array
lists in java so when we talk about
error list we are technically talking
about a list in the previous session i
covered in detail about the various
implementation of list interface which
were error list and link list and in
today's session we'll be focusing only
on the array list i have opened the api
documentation of the arraylist class so
if we just scroll down we will see a
nice description which is provided by
java and it broadly covers all the
points which i described in the previous
session which were that an error list is
basically an array-based implementation
of a list it's an indexed-based
implementation so you can access the
elements based on their index position
you can directly access any element if
you know its index it accepts any kind
of duplicates as well and by default it
is not thread safe if two threads are
trying to access the same collection at
the same time or may be trying to modify
the collection then you will get
inconsistent behavior so that was about
the basic description of arraylist there
are it provides lot of interesting
utility methods as well for adding
elements for adding multiple elements
for removing elements for fetching an
element from the error list and we will
cover those methods in detail in the
demo and with that maybe let's switch to
the demo so for this i have created a
class which is called arraylist demo it
has a public static void main method and
it has an error list example written
inside it so at line number 10 you see
that there is an initialization
happening for the error list and this is
how you basically initialize the array
list to start with you write the
interface name you can obviously write
arraylist as well here instead of list
you can write error list that is
absolutely acceptable but the reason i
have written list here is because it is
a better practice or i would say it is a
best practice to always initialize the
concrete implementations with the
interface type i'm making a very generic
statement which is applicable to
collections and at any other type of
classes and objects you might be
creating in your program always try to
declare it with the type of interface
and then define the concrete
implementation on the right hand side so
the lhs on the left hand side will
contain the interface declaration and
the right hand side will contain the
concrete implementation the reason for
this is that if tomorrow if you have to
change the representation of this error
list to let's say a linked list then you
don't need to do a lot of work because
the linked list is also a child of the
list interface so since list understands
and knows about both of the classes you
can interchangeably use this reference
to point to any of those implementations
that's why it is considered a best
practice to basically
write the left hand side as the
interface and the right hand side as the
concrete implementation that's the first
bit of it second interesting thing you
notice is this so you see
these
expressions here and this basically
encloses any kind of generics or class
type what are generics we will cover
this in detail in the upcoming sessions
for now what you can understand and what
you should know that these are denoting
a class type of which the objects will
be stored inside this particular list
so once i say list of integer it means
that this particular list is only going
to hold integer objects if you try to
insert a string object or if you try to
insert a character object or if you try
to insert a float object or any other
kind of object it will create an error
because it remember in the very first
lecture we said that java is strongly
typed language
it has very strong checks for these kind
of data type mismatch so if that's why
it will expect you to specify the object
type here and whatever type you have
specified here that's the kind of
objects which are going to be stored
inside this list i have been using these
terms called classes and objects inter
interchangeably but for now what you can
understand that this is a type how how
we write classes and how we write
objects and how we create objects again
i will cover this in detail in the
upcoming sessions so we have specified
the list interface and i'm saying that
this particular variable should hold any
list of integer type then on the right
hand side i am specifying what type of
list
this error list is and this error list
will be an arraylist class type and
again i have to specify the class type
or
specifications and then i'm specifying a
size here this is the size of the array
list the initial size of the error list
you can obviously write it without this
as well this is also a perfectly fine
statement in java and in this case the
error list is going to be initialized
with its default size if you specify a
value then the error list will be
initialized with only that size it is
also considered a best practice to
always initialize the array list with a
some known initial value let's say if
the serialist is going to store only two
elements and the default size is
definitely way way bigger than two
elements then you're going to waste lot
of memories so that's why it is the best
practice to specify explicitly specify
some sort of an initial size
this is also acceptable because it is
automatically inferring the type from
the declaration you don't need to
specify it again here in fact some of
this modern ides will also show you a
warning if you write it here so the next
thing i'm going to do is basically going
to add some elements to this error list
so i've created an error list which
should hold only integer values and it
should hold to start with five values
but it will not complain if you try to
add the sixth value so for that i have
just written a small loop here let me
just put curly braces around it for
readability so i am saying in thai equal
to 1 i should be less than equal to 5 i
plus plus and i keep doing array list
dot add so this add method is the method
which is used to add elements to the
array list so whenever you have to add
an element to the error list remember
you need to use the method add and then
specify the actual element which is
supposed to be added so i'm adding one
two three four five in this error list
one by one using this loop and then i am
just printing the whole error list
that's what i'm doing here after that to
showcase another operation of this
arraylist i am removing an element and
if you have to remove an element from
error list just simply call
errorlist.remove and specify the index
from which you want to remove the
element remember you need to specify the
index and as i said in the beginning
this is an array based implementation so
this is going to start from 0. so when i
say remove the element at index 3
technically it's the fourth element of
the array list after that once we have
removed the element i'm again displaying
the modified error list and then
printing all the elements of the
error list one by one and for for
fetching the element if you see here if
you if you observe this particular for
loop i'm using couple of more
interesting methods of the error list
let's understand those methods as well
and then i will run the program so here
you see that i'm saying i
int i equal to 0 and then i'm saying i
less than error list dot size
so if this error list has
a capacity initial capacity of storing
five elements and i've just added five
elements to it then the error list dot
size will be five but it says less than
so it will start from 0 and run till i
equal to 4 because the moment i becomes
5 5 is not less than 5 and it will come
out of the loop so basically i'm trying
to start this loop where i i's value
starts from 0 and goes till 4. and here
i'm calling another error list method
which is used to fetch an element from
the error list so whenever you have to
get an element from the error list just
called dot get on the error list so
arraylist dot get and i'm specifying the
i value so arrow list.get of 0 get of 1
get of 2 get of 3 and get of 4 and
that's technically the 5 elements which
are stored in this array list so let's
run this program
so and now let's observe the outputs
here let me just bring the outputs down
yeah so at first i'm just printing the
error list so nothing nothing
i'm just adding the elements and
printing the complete error list so if
you want to just print the whole error
list just put that inside
system.out.printlet and the whole
arraylist will be printed that's line
17. then i remove the element at index 3
so if i traverse through this particular
list this is index 0 index 1 index 2 and
index 3. so index 3 has an element which
has a value 4. and i'm saying
arraylist.remove the element at index 3.
so this particular element should be
removed from this particular list when i
call the line 20 and then if i print the
modified error list at line 24 i can see
that 4 is gone now it's only one two
three five that's the remaining list you
also need to notice that whenever i call
system.out.println
with arraylist i get this square
brackets which is the representation of
an arraylist if you don't want that you
might not want that always right if you
want to print this nicely without the
square brackets then you have to iterate
over the error list and that's what i'm
doing here i'm going from 0 to error
list.size and i'm doing get of 0 get off
1 get of 2 and get of 3 and that's how i
get these values without 4. we can also
write the same loop using for enhanced
loop so let's say if i write for
int i
colon array list and then inside it i
can just say
system dot out dot print ln
i and if i comment this particular loop
for for a moment and run this program
i see the values one by one because it's
ln so every output comes on on a new
line but you can pretty much see the
same output if i remove
this
and if i write it like this just adding
an extra space
it will look a bit more nice a bit more
formatted like this
so as you can see that we can get the
pretty much the same output either using
a classic for loop style which is a bit
verbose or you can use an enhanced for
loop which is a much simpler and shorter
and
less verbose way of doing exactly the
same thing you don't even need to call
the arraylist.geti but i the reason i
put this example because i wanted to
show you the get functionality as well
let's get started with linked lists in
java in the previous session we talked
about array lists and today we are going
to talk about the another type of
implementation of the list interface
which is called linked list if you
remember from the previous sessions we
discussed about the properties of the
linked list and all those properties are
listed here as well so basic idea is
that whenever you want to have a kind of
implementation where the order of the
elements is strictly maintained where
the first element can refer to the
second element the second element can
refer to the third element and so on in
those kind of cases you are going to use
linked list
another property of linked list is that
you cannot randomly access an element
directly as you as you could do in case
of error list in case of error list you
just say you just write a list dot get
and you provide the index location and
you get the element right away that's
not possible in linked list in linked
list if you have to access the let's say
the second last element or the fifth
element in a 10 size element
list in that case you have to start from
the head which is the first element and
keep traversing till the fifth element
that's the only way possible to access
the fifth element or any random element
so that's the property of linked list it
is also not synchronized so if multiple
threads are trying to access a linked
list concurrently at least one of the
threads and and one of the threads tries
to modify the list then it must be
synchronized externally by some other
ways otherwise you will get
unpredictable results
and again this also provides a bunch of
utility methods and we will cover some
of those methods as you can see add
method for adding an element add all add
first contains get first get lost we
will cover some of these methods in the
demonstration which follows this
particular documentation and with that
let's jump to the implementation
so i have prepared an example here for
the linked list which is called linked
list demo i've just created a class for
it and we have created a public static
void main method here and here you can
see at line number 10 i have declared a
linked list so this looks very similar
to the way we declared an error list you
see if you have notice on the lhs i have
wrote i have written the concrete class
and have not written the interface
reason being i'm using some concrete
methods and actual methods which are
only available in the linked list class
so i am not looking at the reusability
aspect in this particular example if you
are then you have to add extra code for
it but here i'm just writing linked list
and again in this particular linked list
i'm saying that i would only store
string objects so that's why inside
these braces i write string and then i
say new link list string
again i have not specified the size so
it will take the default size as per the
jvm implementation now i have declared
my linked list and it's time to add some
elements to the link list for that i
have the method add which is available
in this linked list class
which will provide me
with the capability to add elements
so at line number 12 and line number 13
i'm adding two elements
and if you remember i told you that it
works in a reference based
implementation so at first an element a
will be added and when you try to add
element b element a's reference will be
updated to point to b
that's what will happen in this linked
list and then at line 14 i'm using
another interesting utility method of
this linked list class which says add
last
what this method does that specifically
it will add the element at the very end
of the linked list
so that was about add last and if i talk
about line 15 i'm using another
interesting method of linked list class
which is called add first
so what this will do that this is going
to insert this element d at the very
beginning of this linked list like even
before a d will be inserted so whatever
your linked list looks like whenever you
call add first
that element is going to be inserted at
the very head of the linked list or the
very beginning of the linked list linked
list also provides another variant of
the add method so there is one way to
just add the string element directly
because this is a string a linked list
you can also add it based on the
position so you can say add e at the
second position
inside the linked list so let's observe
this output let me comment all the code
below line 18 because we will be using
some more methods here
so we'll cover that in a while but let's
first understand the output at line 18
if we run this program so right click
run as java application and this is the
output we get so let's understand the
output or maybe let me do this let me
put this here one by one so that we can
interpret the output
so i'm adding two elements and printing
the list then calling add last and
printing the new list then calling add
first printing the new list and then
calling list.add2 comma e and printing
the list again so let's observe these
outputs one by one i'll comment this and
let's run this now
so if i run this particular program the
program till line 14 is executed because
rest of the code is all commented let me
comment this as well and if i run it
again yes this is the output i get so at
line 12 and 13 i've added two elements
and i print the list there are only two
elements and they are printed in the
fashion a comma b everything is good
here now let's uncomment this code and
now i'm calling add last method and add
adding an element with string c which
should be added at the very last of this
particular list so let's see now what
happens let me comment this one so that
we only see one list at the output
we see a comma b comma c so c has been
successfully added to the end of the
list
now let's interpret this particular
method which is called add first so i'm
going to uncomment this
and comment the previous out so now
there's only one sis out here so i'm
adding two elements adding c at the last
and now adding b
at the very beginning and printing out
the list
let's see what happens
okay so the d has been added at the very
beginning of the list even before a so
now it looks like d comma a comma b
comma c so far so good now let's move to
this particular code
and now i'm saying add an element call
called e
at the second position inside this list
remember second position so let's run
this list now this program now
so now i see d comma a if you remember
the previous output was d abc if i just
uncomment this for a while just to make
it more clearer and if i run this
program the previous list was d comma a
comma b comma c and the new one says d a
e e has been inserted at the
position 2 so 0 1 2 position 2 has been
added with this new string e and my list
is modified now it's time to
find some interesting operations about
the removal so what happens if i try to
remove elements from this list and then
we will observe the output again
so let's say if i say list dot remove b
and so i'm saying just drop this
particular element so you can directly
specify that particular element's value
and that element will be removed from
the list
and let's see what output do i get if i
just call list dot remove b and i
comment the rest of the code we should
see a new output here which should not
have b
so running the program again yes
so this was the
old collection and this is the new
collection from which b is gone because
i've called list dot remove b
now you can also remove elements based
on the index position instead of
specifying the element explicitly you
can specify the index position and what
happens if i call list.remove3 let's
observe the output here as well so i'm
just going to copy paste this out
and we'll see what output do we get if
we remove the element at third location
okay so this was the previous output
after removing b and if i called list
dot remove 3
so 0 1 2 3
c is the element which is at third
location and it is gone when i call list
dot remove three c is gone and d comma a
comma e
is only remaining
now let's try to understand this
particular line which says list dot
remove first
expectedly this is going to remove the
element from the very beginning so
whatever element is present at the
beginning it is going to remove the
element and then we are going to print
the list the modified list so we were
here till d a e and d was the
element which was at the beginning and
if i called remove first d is removed
and now only a comma e is
available and now i use another
interesting method which is called list
dot remove last and then i print the
list the modified list
so this is the list remaining and i'm
calling remove last so e should be
dropped and only a should be
left in this particular list
yes we only see a here so this is
basically what i wanted to show you in
this program that we can perform
different kind of operations
using different methods like add add
first add last remove remove first
remove last obviously there are more
interesting methods available in this
particular class do check out the api
documentation for it and there you can
see all the different interesting
methods which you can use while
implementing linked list let's get
started with hash set in java if you
remember i covered in the collections
framework session that has set is part
of the set interface hierarchy and sets
have a property that they keep the
collections element unique if you try to
add duplicate elements to the asset it
will not accept that and it will still
maintain the uniqueness property of the
collection hashset provides some
additional features to the set which is
that in this case the elements would be
accessed in a random fashion they will
not be accessed in a fixed sequence
rather they will be accessed in a random
fashion hence the name hash set so if
you read about this particular class in
the documentation it will basically
cover all the things which i just
described it also accepts null elements
if you want to insert null but why would
you try to insert null that's the first
question which you should ask it again
provides similar kind of utility methods
to the list interface collection
hierarchy we covered like some utility
methods to add the elements to remove
the elements to check the size of the
collection and to check if an element
exists in the collection or not etc etc
and we will cover some of these methods
in the demo this is again not
synchronized so this is not a thread
safe collection which you should know so
let's look at a demonstration of hash
set and how do we actually create a hash
set how do we operate upon a hash set
using different utility methods
so as you can see i have created a class
here which is called hash set demo there
is a public static void main method and
then at line number 10 you will see that
i have created the hash set and again it
starts with the concrete class here
which says hash set and you can
obviously write it as set as well which
will also work fine so we write the set
type as string so this particular set is
going to hold only and only string
objects and nothing else and this set is
basically a type of hash set again this
is not mandatory so you can remove that
it will still not complain and the
program will run fine if you want to
specify a size please do that if you do
not want to specify the size nothing
goes wrong and it will be initialized
with the default memory footprint but
remember doing this wastes a bit of
memory so if you are running this
program on a machine which is really
tight on memory always put some kind of
initialization size based on your
knowledge of how many elements are going
to be stored in this collection so after
that at line number 12 we start adding
elements to this collection and for
adding the elements the method which is
provided by the hash set class is add so
you use the add method to add new
elements so at line number 12 line
number 13 14 and 15 i use the method
again and again to add some elements if
you observe the line number 14 and the
line number 15 these two lines are
adding the same element so i'm trying to
add c twice to this particular hash set
and we will observe the output to see
what happens if we try to add duplicate
elements in the hash set because if you
remember the sets are supposed to be
unique they should not be storing
duplicate elements that's the property
of sets so that's what i demonstrate by
by adding duplicate elements to see how
it behaves and let's do that let me
comment the rest of the code for a while
and let's run just this part of the code
where i add c twice and i print the hash
set and let's see what happens
so i go to run as and i click on java
application and i only see three
elements even though i added four i only
see three and c has been added only once
not twice
now you might be wondering whether the c
is
the c added at line 14 or the c added at
line 15. so
to understand that we need to understand
how hash sets add method works
so this add method is basically
returning a boolean value if the element
is added successfully this ad is going
to return true and if the element could
not be added successfully this add
method is going to return false so let's
do that let's store the result of these
add methods let's call this r1 and let's
call this one as r2
okay and now we will try to print r1 and
r2 and see what happens
so if we write system dot out
dot println and i say r1 and then i just
copy this
after line 16
and write r2 and now we will observe the
output of these to see which
when we did the add at 14 and when we
did the add at 16 which actually
resulted in c getting added did c get
overwritten or did c did not add twice
what happens
so we see that uh when we do the add at
line 14 we get true so it means that
this ad was successful and c was added
here and when i did the add again at
line 16 this returned a false it means
the hash set rejected this ad operation
so this c was not added so the actual c
was never overwritten the original c was
maintained and when you try to add a
duplicate value with the same value a
duplicate element with the same value
hashtag is going to reject that
so that actually
proves that the set will maintain the uh
the uniqueness property and it will
reject all the duplicates subsequently
that was about the ad
property now let's understand another
interesting property of the contains
method contains method of the set class
is used to find if an element exists in
the set or not so you can just use the
set variable name dot contains and just
type the actual element and this is
going to return true or false based on
whether this element is present in the
hash set or not present in the hash set
if it is present then this contains
method is going to return true otherwise
it is going to return false
so let's run this method and observe the
output at line 21
so it says list we are writing this
particular string which says does list
contain c or not and it returns true
because yes my hash set does contain c
now coming to line 23 i use another
method of the hash set which is the
remove operation which you can use to
remove an element from the set and then
i'm again doing a sound and i'm asking
the to print the set this should be set
and not list
so then i'm checking if
what happens to my hash set if i call
the remove method and i'm just printing
the modified hash set at line 24. so
let's see what happens with the effect
of remove operation okay so after
removing a this is what remains in my
hash set and a has been successfully
dropped if i call the remove method and
then i try to just iterate over the hash
set to show you how does this iteration
work it again works on exactly the same
way it has been working for the list
implementations that on the rhs of this
column you write the collection name so
hash set and on the lhs of this colon
you write the representation of the
element so this hash set is going to
contain string and this is just a
placeholder it can be anything this is
just a temporary variable to store the
current value at the current step of the
hash set iteration and i'm printing all
the items one by one so if i run this
i'm able to print b and c because that's
all which is remaining in this hash set
so this was a very quick demo to show
you the functionalities of the hash set
how does hash set maintains uniqueness
how do you remove elements how do you
add elements how do you check for an
element's existence using contains
there's also a method to get the element
of the hash set if you want to so these
are all the different properties and
methods available in the hash set and do
check check out the api documentation of
the hash set to learn about more methods
let's get started with presets in java
and if you remember when we talked about
this collection framework i discussed
briefly about preset that the main
reason you will use tree set is
basically when you want to maintain
natural ordering of the elements if you
are adding your custom elements then you
need to tell java how to compare and
sort and order the elements but that's
for another day when we'll cover about
the detailed comparable and comparator
interfaces for now what you can
understand that whenever you have to
maintain the natural order of the
elements automatically then you should
use preset along with that the set
property still holds true that this tree
set cannot have duplicate elements
we should also know that reset is not
synchronized so it is not a thread safe
collection so be remember be aware that
whenever you are trying to use preset in
a multi-threaded environment you need to
write more wiring code around it so that
preset works as expected okay that was
about the brief theory about the preset
you can read about
about it in detail in this tree set
documentation class and with that let's
switch to a demonstration of the tree
set class
so i have prepared a class here which is
called reset demo as you can see it has
a public static void main method and at
line number eight i'm initializing that
reset again it's again the standard
representation of initializing a
collection which we have been using
throughout the different examples of the
collections so preset of string so this
particular preset is going to hold only
and only string elements if you try to
add another element it is going to
through a compilation error and the on
the rhs i'm just saying new tree set and
again this is not mandatory so i can
remove that and it will still work you
can specify the size whenever you know
about the scope of the collection you
should always specify the size for this
demonstration it's a lightweight program
so it's fine after that from line number
10 till line number 13 i'm again going
to add some elements and again if you
see i'm adding elements in random order
i'm adding b and then i'm adding adding
a then i am adding c twice just to show
you the uniqueness property of the tree
set does it still hold true or not we
will be able to figure that out from
this particular example and we will also
see
if i'm adding b before a will it be
printed in a fashion called bac or will
it be printed in a fashion called abc we
should also know that so let's try to
run this program and understand the
output
so if we look at the output we see a
before b
but here when we added the elements we
saw b before a we added b first and then
we added a and then we added c twice and
as per the uniqueness property of this
set the second uh addition statement at
line number 13 returned false and set
rejected this edition because it could
see that c was already present in this
particular collection so c is added only
once but what's interesting is that b is
added first but b is added b is printed
after a so the natural order of the
elements in this collection is
automatically maintained by tree set so
what under the hood reset does here that
it looks at the type which is a
predefined type in java string is a
predefined class in java so it will use
its own sorting algorithm to sort the
strings based on their natural order of
sequence and in the natural order of
sequence a will always come before b and
b will always come before c so it will
automatically apply that sorting and
will present the result to you if you're
using a custom class here let's say your
own student class or your own customer
class or your own account class in that
case that account class or student class
or customer class needs to tell java how
to sort elements and for that you need
to write comparable and comparator
implementations which we will cover in
detail in the future sessions but for
now you you must understand that
whatever the type of class you are
specifying here should
tell java how to sort the elements
either java should know it automatically
if it's a predefined class like string
or integer or float or double then java
would automatically know by default how
to sort the elements but if you are
creating a custom class of yours in the
tree set and specifying that as a tree
set type then you should also tell java
how to sort the customers whether you
want to sort them based on their first
name whether you want to sort them based
on their age their salary java doesn't
know that so you need you need to tell
java about that if you're trying to use
a custom class as the type entry set in
this particular example i'm using string
here and it will apply the natural
ordering
let's put c here in the very beginning
to see what happens
and i can comment this as we have
already maintained and verified that c
is only printed once and added once so
i'm adding c b a and let's run this
program
i still get abc because again the
natural order is implemented contrary to
this when we talked about hash set
remember i told that hash set is a
random access
element collection list so if you run
the hash set if you try to print the
hash set again and again and again you
might see a different order sometimes if
i use a hash set here sometimes it will
print abc sometimes it will print bac
sometimes it might print cab any kind of
sequence any kind of random sequence it
will pick automatically that's the
property of hash set but in case of tree
set no matter how many times you run it
you will always get the same order based
on the sorting implementation available
in the class type so that's all i wanted
to cover about preset please read about
read about its java documentation in the
api docs to understand what all other
methods and utilities tree set provides
but it's pretty much similar to what we
saw in the hashtag example like remove
or get etc etc and contains etc so all
these all similar methods are available
in the tree set class as well and that's
all we'll focus on on this particular
session and in the next session we're
going to talk about an interesting
framework called maps let's get started
with maps in java
so first of all before we understand
this particular diagram and the classes
in this map framework let's understand
why do we need map
so
there would be instances when you would
write a java program or any kind of
program there would be always be
instances where you would need to store
a key value kind of arrangement a very
simple example can be that you want to
maintain a company database and you want
to just bring the whole mapping of the
employee id to the employee name into
the java program
how do you do that you need a key value
sort of arrangement where you can store
the employee id as the keys
and each of the employee id key
would correspond to an employee name
which will be called the value so you
need a key and value
arrangement in a java program to store
that kind of information and use that
kind of information in your program and
that's where map comes into picture
whenever you have to store a key value
arrangement remember you would always
think about maps maps should be the
right collection or the right data
structure to be used if you want to
store any key value arrangement in your
program so that's about map and here you
can see a nice framework representation
of map and this is going to be a
theoretical lecture where we will
understand how this map framework works
what is the property and what are the
different implementation classes and
then in the future sessions we will
again look at some examples of the most
popular map implementation classes which
are used in the java world
so again
the orange oval are interfaces the blue
boxes or the light blue boxes are the
abstract classes and the purple boxes
are the concrete classes so map is an
interface which will provide this kind
of a blueprint that every class
underneath it would be working on a key
value arrangement when we talk about
this key value arrangement so we have
these keys and we have the values
so the keys here
are supposed to be unique the values can
contain duplicates
remember this is a very important
concept then in map the keys will be
unique and the values can have duplicate
and because we want to maintain the
uniqueness in the keys part that's why
the keys are technically stored as a
set because we know that set cannot
contain duplicate sets are by design
made to be storing only unique elements
so map uses the set class to store its
keys and to store the values it
generally uses a list class so you can
see map is basically reusing the classes
from the collections framework sets for
storing the keys and lists for storing
the values that's the basic anatomy and
basic idea of how map is working now you
see some classes here called abstract
map and sorted map and again similar to
the set hierarchy whenever you see the
sorted world and if you look at the
concrete class which is called tree map
this is going to provide you some sort
of an order sorting order automatically
and then you have the hash map class and
this class is going to be providing a
random access this will not maintain the
insertion order this will not provide
you a natural sorting order this is just
to store elements in random order and
the element here a single element here
is basically consisting of two parts
which is key and value always remember
that you also have hash table here hash
table is basically a synchronized
representation this is a thread safe
hash map and tree map are non-thread
safe so multiple threads if you try to
work in a multi-threading program with
these hashmap and premap you are going
to get very unpredictable results but if
you use hash table then it is inherently
thread safe so it will only allow one
thread to be to access the hash table at
a particular time
you will also you will also be thinking
then then it's always better to use hash
table right because
you will never get into those weird
errors and you don't have to migrate
your program uh to a multi-threaded
environment whenever you are trying to
use hash tables yes that is true but
hash tables are slower for the same
reason because only one thread can can
access it at a time and that's why hash
tables are slower and hash map and tree
map are way way faster because they
allowed multiple access at the same time
so you have to always
be mindful of what kind of collection
type you are using there are some
external ways as well to make these
hashmaps and tree maps and hash set and
preset and
array list and link list as synchronized
as well and we will talk about that in a
future session but for now you can
understand that hash map entry map are
non-thread safe and hash table
are thread safe there is another class
which is
which is coming out from the hash map
class which is called linked hash map
and linked hash map as the name shows it
will basically carry two properties it
will carry the property of hash map
where the elements are stored or
displayed or accessed in random order
and at the same time it is also
providing the linked uh property of the
linked list where the sequence is
maintained so you can see you can
actually get the insertion order if you
use a linked hash map the way in which
you insert the elements would always be
the way in which the elements will be
accessed so you are getting sort of a
ordering property but the order is the
insertion order it's not the natural
sort order it's the insertion order
that's why the name linked hash map
because it brings the linked list part
of the link property inside the hash map
where the elements would be presented to
you
in the order they are inserted when you
call the add method so that's what we
covered here we covered about map
interface we covered about hash map
class which is going to store the values
and the access will be random the value
means the element means a key and value
we sometime also call this as an element
you will see that representation
sometimes some some uh people also call
it as i table element it's all the same
thing but it's a key and value
arrangement pre-map also stores the key
value arrangement but it will provide
you a sorted representation and here the
sorting will happen on the keys
not on the values the sorting will be
happening the natural order of salt
which will be maintained by the tree map
is only applicable to the keys here
similarly link hash map it will insert
the elements but when you try to access
it it will maintain the insertion order
no matter how many times you access it
it will only be presented to you in the
order the elements were inserted and
hash table is very similar to hash map
with the difference that hash table is
thread safe multiple threads cannot
manipulate the hash table at a time it
will only let a single thread access
itself at a time so that's the property
of hash table the most popular classes
are generally these ones hash map tree
map and linked hash map
very rarely you will also see hash table
but since we have some
ways to
get these synchronized so generally you
would not see much of the hash table
implementation let's get started with
hash maps in java
in the previous session i covered about
the theoretical concepts of map and the
key value arrangement and the keys being
basically are set and the values
basically being a list
and now we are looking at the api
documentation of the hashmap class you
can see the k comma v here these are the
types of the key and the value which the
hashmap will accept you can see k is
basically the type of keys and v is
basically the type of mapped values
like i explained it's basically keys are
stored in a set fashion and values are
stored in a list collection fashion this
is not by default synchronized so if you
want a thread save collection then you
would have to do something else which i
will cover in the future sessions this
is a very brief overview of what hash
map is but let's look at the example to
understand better and then i will be
able to explain it in bit more detail so
now we are looking at an example which
is basically a class which is called
hash map demo i have a main method here
and then at line number 10 i am
initializing the map
and as you can see that on the lhs we
see the concrete class hash map and i
can do this
and this will still work provided you
have the import here i had the import
here so it will work fine and i'm saying
that this map is going to contain a key
value arrangement where the keys are the
string type
and the values are of the type integer
and it's ultimately a hash map here i i
don't need to again provide the generics
because i have already provided the
generics here
the name of the map is just simply a map
and again you can specify a size or you
can skip the size based on the memory
requirements and the program
requirements
now coming to the point where you want
to add elements to the map now since
this is a key value arrangement here the
name of the method through which you are
going to add elements is
put so you call map.put
and then you provide the key
comma you provide the value
that's the syntax for adding an element
or we technically call that element an
entry this key value together is called
entry so if you have to add an entry to
the map you have to write it in this way
where key comma value is the convention
so i'm adding three elements or three
entries here which is
a comma 10 b comma 20 and c comma 30.
abc are basically the keys and 10 20 and
30 are the corresponding values of these
keys respectively
after that i'm showcasing another
utility method of this particular class
which you can use to find the size of
the map so you can just call map dot
size and it will print the size of the
map after that i'm printing the actual
map the whole map and then i'm using
some more methods but again let's
comment this code and let's understand
this code one by one so that there is no
confusion
so to start with i'm going to add some
elements some entries and i'm going to
print the size of the map and the map
itself let's run this program
so here
you can see the size of the map is
printed as three because i've added
three entries and then when i call
map inside the
system.out.println method i get the
whole map printed here and this is how
the map will look like when it is
printed we can see key equal to value
syntax here where a equal to 10
b equal to 20 and c equal to 30 are the
key value representations or the entries
here separated by comma enclosed by the
curly braces that's how our map looks
like so far so good the next thing which
i am going to showcase to you is the
contains method
and since the map has this set which is
the keys basically that's why map
provides a method called contains key
basically you can check if a particular
key is present in the map or not and if
you know the key is present then it's
very easy to get the value from the key
map will provide a method also where you
can supply the key and get the value so
knowing the key is the most important
part and that's why map provides a
method called contains key so you can
call this method specify the key which
you want to check for the presence in
the map it is going to check whether a
is present in this maps key set or not
if the a is available in this keys we
can see a is available then this
condition is going to hold true and then
like i said if you want to fetch the
value then you can call the get method
providing the key you can fetch the
value from the key that's the that's the
core idea which you should remember so i
call map.get specify the key and this is
going to spit out the value which is
being pointed by this particular key in
this case a is pointing to 10 when i say
pointing it's not pointer remember it's
just a reference so map dot get of a is
going to get the actual value which this
key is pointing to which is 10 and then
i am printing this integer a which is
the actual value pointed by this
particular key so let's run this program
and see if this works so we get these
two outputs from the above and then this
is the output which is coming from the
if block so it checked whether the map
is containing a key with the name a yes
it was able to find that and then we
asked the java program to fetch the
value corresponding to this particular
key so we just called map dot get off a
and it fetched 10 and it printed 10 here
that's why you see 10 here okay so
that's how you can basically use the
contains key method and the get method
now what if you want to iterate over all
the keys
what if you the what if you have to use
the
all the keys and you have to make some
pattern or make some observation about
all the keys in your map you can do that
by iterating over the key set and for
that map provides a method called key
set so you just called map dot key set
and this is going to fetch all the keys
in a set representation and will be
provided to you so here when i call
map.keyset this is basically
giving me a set which is containing all
the keys and then i'm iterating over the
keys one by one you would be familiar
with this syntax by now which is the
enhanced for loop syntax and inside this
i am printing the key which is the
current temporary variable holding the
current key and the value pointed by
that particular key at that particular
step and i'm again using the same method
get which i which i showed you uh here
same method so you provide the key and
you will get the value so i'm going to
get all the keys hydrate over the keys
and then print the key and the value
let's see how this looks like
so till this we were good and here you
will see the output which is coming out
from this particular for loop from this
particular for loop line 25 to line 27
where i'm iterating over the key set
printing the key and value one by one so
this is how to show you if you just have
access to the key set you can still
iterate over the whole map but what if
you know everything you have access to
the key set you have access to the
values and if you was if you just want
to iterate over it then you can use this
particular
way and instead of map dot key set
you're going to use map dot entry set if
you remember map treats each key value
arrangement as a single entry entry is
the keyword here so map dot entry set is
going to give me all the entries in the
map
and then
each entry is basically of type entry
class
this is the representation of each entry
and we know how this representation
formed entry is the class basically
which is coming out of this map
collection hierarchy and then let me
just save this and then string is the
key and integer is the value held by
each entry inside the map so that's what
we are going to do we are going to pick
up all the entries in the map and going
to iterate over the entries one by one
by writing this enhanced for loop and
entry is the temporary variable which is
going to hold each entry one by one at
each step and then it's very simple you
call entry.getkey you will get the key
and you call entry.getvalue and you will
get the value so it's much much simpler
than this one where you had to do
map.get to understand here it's very
implicit get key is going to get you the
key and get value is going to get you
the value so you just need to call map
dot entry set hydrate over the entry set
and get each entry is key and value and
print them or do whatever your program
requires to be done that's how you will
use it so let's run this one as well to
verify if this works okay so this is the
output which is coming from the last
loop this loop basically you can see key
i did not put any space that's why you
see key a key b and key c together let
me put a space here and put a hyphen so
that the output looks better and let me
rerun this yeah this is much better so
you can see the key a value 10 tb value
20 and key c value 30. this is coming
from this particular for loop which i
just showed you so this is all i wanted
to cover in this particular session we
went deeper into the hash map
representation and we saw bunch of
methods contains key key set entry set
get put etc and we showed how we can use
the hashmap for different purposes in
the program in the next session we'll go
deeper into the tree map concept and
we'll also look at a demo of tree map
and we'll understand how it works let's
get started with tree maps in java now
if you remember in the last lecture we
talked about hash maps in java and we
also had a look at an example where we
saw how a hash map works and how we can
use a hash map we also had a look at
different utility methods of the hashmap
as well now in today's lecture we are
going to focus on tree maps which is an
another type of map as we discussed when
we were discussing about the map
framework and the main property of a
tree map is that when you enter elements
into a map they will naturally be sorted
or naturally be ordered now when i say
naturally ordered what it means that if
you put the
keys as let's say integer then the tree
map will automatically sort all the map
entries in an integer sorted fashion
where you'll see the natural number
sorting behavior like 1 2 3 and so on
similarly if you
store alphabets or strings then they
then those will be sorted in a natural
sorting alphabetical order starting from
a to z so these are the uh these are the
data types which the java is already
aware of on how to sort them like
integers doubles floats strings etc but
there can be a case where you have your
custom key this particular key is your
own custom class if that is the behavior
or if that is the scenario then in that
case you will have to provide an
implementation to java to know how to
sort those elements because java doesn't
know for example a student class or an
account class java doesn't know how to
sort that so if you have that kind of
scenario then in those cases you will
have to provide your own sorting
implementation and we will cover about
what kind of sorting implementation you
can provide in those kind of scenarios
in the upcoming lectures for now we will
look at have a look at an example of
tree map where you can see that i have
created a class which is called tree map
demo and i have initialized a tree map
with the keys as integer and the values
as string so this means that each entry
of the map will have key as the integer
value and the value of that particular
entry will be of string type so
basically an integer to string mapping
is what each entry of this tree map is
going to store so nothing different here
you would have already seen this kind of
this kind of initialization for any kind
of map and after that at line 11 i use
the standard put method of the map and i
i started storing the values so at line
11 i'm saying store 3 and a so 3 is the
key and string a remember this is not a
character this is a string because i
have specified string here if you
specify a character here and if you try
to store a string this is going to throw
an error and you need to fix that so i
store 3 as the key and a as string as
the value similarly at line 12 i store 2
as the key and
b as the value
and at line c i store 1 as the key and c
as the value so these integers are the
keys and the string are the values
and if i just put them and if i just try
to print them what happens
what kind of order can we expect let's
try to analyze that so i right click on
this i go to run as
and i go to run as java application
it will run the program because i have a
static void main method and now you see
that the map is printed in a different
fashion
than the way it was added we added the
map elements in this sequence that we
added 3 a first 2b second and one c as
the third element
but when we started printing them we saw
1c printed first 2b
printed second and 3c 3a printed third
so what this denotes that this tree map
because the key was integer here it
automatically
sorted these keys into a natural order
sorting and it provided when i tried to
access the map it provided the access in
that sorted sequence only no matter how
many times you run this particular
program it is always going to return the
map in the
same format in the same sequence the
sequence of representation of the
elements is not going to change and you
can basically do the similar behavior
for example if i just
change this to string and integer let's
do it like this
and if i again swap the elements here as
well i say a comma three and i say b
comma 2
and here i can say c comma 1. if i do
this i just switch the keys in values
position now the string is the key and
the integer is the value and let me just
put these two before a
so that
we can demonstrate the behavior of the
tree map properly so i'm inserting b two
first and c one second and a three third
and i just save this file and now let's
run this file and let's see how the
output comes so now you can see that
since the key is now string it has
applied it has automatically applied the
natural sorting ordering of strings
which is starting from a going till z
and that's why you see a entry as the
first entry b entry as a second entry
and the c entry as the third entry again
no matter how many times you run it or
you iterate over it you try to access it
you will always get the sequence in the
same fashion so this is a basic overview
of how tree maps work now you can and i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read about all the other methods which
are available in the tree map which you
can use for example how can you remove
elements how can you uh how can you
iterate the elements of the tree map etc
in fact the iteration is is going to be
exactly the same way as we have seen in
the case of hash maps because iteration
behavior doesn't change but to uh if you
want to see what all different kinds of
methods pre-map support it supports a
lot of different methods we can't cover
all of them in this short tutorial but i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read the javadocs api of the tree map to
get familiar with those methods so that
you know what kind of functionalities
pre-map can provide let's get started
with access modifiers in java so when we
talk about access modifiers let's
understand what is the underlying
philosophy of the reasoning behind this
and the reasoning is very
straightforward it can be even wrapped
into a single word which is called
security the reason is that you will be
creating multiple kinds of objects and
variables while you write your java
program and you should always write your
java program or any program in a manner
that only the intended classes packages
modules or applications should be able
to see what they are supposed to see
so as a consumer application i should
only be able to consume the variables
which i am expected to consume i should
not get any variable or i should not
even have access to any variable which i
am not supposed to access so the idea is
providing the least privileged principle
give access to different functions
different variables different programs
only by providing them the the kind of
access which they need to run
efficiently and do not give them
complete access so with that notion in
mind java created the concept of access
modifiers and it created these three
modifiers which are called public
protected and private if you do not
provide any modifier then it goes to no
modifier or some people also call it as
default modifier which is also a type of
access modifier so let's understand
theoretically first how it works and
then we will try to have a look at an
example
let's understand the first one
first of all these modifiers are
keywords and you can use these keywords
in front of classes in front of
variables and also in front of methods
and you might have already noticed this
particular keyword called public in
front of all the classes i have created
or even when we talked about the public
static void main method we saw this
public as a keyword it is basically an
access modifier and whenever you put
public in front of a class or a variable
or a method that particular component
becomes available to the whole of the
program it will be available to the
whole world basically any subclass or
any package or any other class which
might have been written in your java
program will be able to access that
particular class or variable or method
if you put public in front of that the
second modifier level is protected one
of the other thing which you you will
understand as i explain this is that as
you move down into this particular table
the access level will start getting more
and more restricted by restriction i
mean that less and less components will
be able to get access to those modifiers
so if you write protected in front of a
class or in front of a method or in
front of a variable then everything
within that particular class will still
be able to access it
everything within the package will still
be able to access it i still haven't
covered the concept of package but i
briefly touched upon it showing you how
whenever we write a class we have a
package in front of it and package is
technically is just an aggregation of
the classes if you have to write write
multiple classes and wrap all of those
classes into a single logical bundle
that would be called a package just to
show you an example these all are
packages which you see here you see this
square box here and you see that these
names these all are packages and these
packages contain multiple classes and
technically that's all the packages mean
that you can wrap multiple related
classes into a single package so coming
back to the access modifier whenever you
write protected in front of a class or a
variable or a method then that
particular component will be accessible
to everybody within the same class
everybody within the same package
it will also be accessible to everybody
which is a subclass of the class this is
again a new concept which i have not
covered but this basically means a child
of this class now what is a child of the
class we will cover at
that concept in detail when we will talk
about inheritance but for now you can
understand that it is basically an
extension of the class so
when the moment you declare something is
protected it can easily be accessible
within the same class in which this
protected component was declared it can
be accessed in the package it can also
be accessed in the subclasses of the
class but anything outside the package
will not be able to access it because
you see an n here then we have the
default access modifier or no modifier
if you do not write anything in front of
a class or a method or a variable it
gets the default access modifier
privileges and that privilege mean that
anybody within the same class will be
able to access that default variable or
a default component anybody within the
package will also be able to access it
the sub classes of the class where the
default component was declared those
subclasses will not be able to access it
and anybody outside the package will
obviously not be able to access it
then comes the last one which is the
most restricted privilege which is
called private so if you put private in
front of a class or in front of a method
or in front of a variable
that component will only be accessible
within the class where it was declared
it will not be accessible in the package
it will not be accessible in the
subclasses and definitely not be
accessible to anybody outside the
package so private is the least
privileged or least access permission
level you have in java
once you write private in front of any
component that only the the classes
other variables the the same class in
which you declare this particular
private variable only that class itself
will be able to access it and nobody
else will be able to access it and as
you move above the accesses become more
and more lenient you can see there's
just one y and three n here the moment
you move a bit above to the default
modifier you get two y's so everybody in
the class and everybody in the package
will be able to access that particular
component rest of for the rest of the
other world it is still unknown when you
write something as protected then
everything in the class everything in
the package and everything in the sub
classes will also be able to access it
rest of the world cannot access it and
if you write something as public then
anybody can access it it's like why
everywhere so that is how the access
levels work now let us understand this
with the help of example
so i will go here and i've just written
a very simple dummy class here which has
uh which is a class called test and i
have a method here which is a display
method so very simple class nothing
fancy here and if you if you notice i
have not put any kind of public private
or
or protected modifier in front of the
class so this will get the default
privilege if something has default
privilege then the whole world will not
be able to access it so let's go to a
different package let's go to this
package which is here
and let's try to access this particular
test class so we will try to access this
test.java here in the main class
so let's try to do that let's say test t
equal to new test i'm just initializing
the same class
so what do i get i get a compile error
let me try to fix it if i can and i
cannot fix it if you see i'm just trying
to use this particular test class into a
different package but that package is
not able to see the class at all i'm
getting a compilation error and if i try
to click on the error generally eclipse
provide me suggestions to fix the to
import this particular class but eclipse
is not able to find and find any class
with the name of test which can be
imported in this package which is a
different package than the one of the
test class so we cannot access it
because it's in the default access
now let's go back to the test class and
let's make it public
so i've just made it public here and now
if i click on this again i get the
suggestion if you see this suggestion
was not there earlier now it says import
test and if i click on this double click
it gets imported and everything is happy
so you can see the whole access modifier
in effect here the default walls is
versus public you can also try the other
other kind of
access modifiers let's try private as
well i think private will also have the
same effect because it will still not be
accessible from the package or from the
subclass from or from the uh from the
whole world we already saw this
particular in effect but we will see the
private in a in a different way now
so going back to the test class i have
made the class as public but the method
here is default i have not exposed this
method to be used outside the class
let's see what happens if i try to call
this display method from the main class
so i have successfully initialized the
class and if i say t
dot
and if i look at the suggestions here
i do not get suggestion of the display
method
why because it is default
if i go back
make it private
can i now access it let's try again nope
still we can't access it eclipse is not
even able to find it inside this package
because it is private
let's go back and make it public
so i've made it just public now going
back to the main class and again saying
t dot now i get that display suggestion
as the first suggested method here and
now i am able to use the display method
once i have made it public so you see
the moment you change the access
modifiers the changes are propagated
immediately and you can see the public
versus default versus private in play
here we can even go into further detail
by using the protected but for protected
i have to explain the concept of
subclasses so i will cover this
protected versus subclasses concept when
i talk about inheritance and there we
will see the usage of protected
variables and the protected access
modifier but we saw the usage of public
the default modifier and the private
modifier do check out the documentation
for these access modifiers and i would
strongly suggest you to play around with
this get more comfortable with this
concept of different kind of modifiers
let's also run an example for for
understanding the default modifier in a
better sense because we can see that for
the package it says why right so let's
go back to eclipse and within the same
package where we created test class
let's create another class let's call it
test
demo
so i will just click finish i get a new
class let me also
write the public static void main method
here so i get the public static void
main method here and let's try to access
the test class here within the same
package so let me again go back to the
default privilege here
so i put the test class access as the
default class or default access and same
goes for display so can other classes in
the same package access the test class
now let's see that if i go to test demo
and here if i try to get the test class
initialize does it work or does it give
me a compilation error yes it works it
works because the test class and the
test demo are in the same package and
test class has that default access
privilege
so let's try to run one more variation
of it to understand the usage of the
private method better going back to the
test class this display method has the
default privilege right now so going by
that logic if i say t dot i should be
able to get access to the display method
and yes that is possible if i run this
particular program i will be able to get
whatever is given out by the display
method which is hello world
now let's try to make this particular
method as private and let's try to
access this method from one of the other
class in the same package as of the test
class so the class is default the method
is private and if you see this class has
already turned red there is a
compilation error because now the
display method is not accessible to the
testdemo class even if it was in the
same package it's not accessible because
the display methods privilege or access
modifier has gone to private now exactly
the same as explained here because it
has become private so the package level
members cannot access it there's an n
here so this is this was another
variation to show you how you can use
public protected and private together to
only expose the members methods and
classes which are supposed to be exposed
to the consumer this is a very critical
and very important concept to be used in
java and it is used from a very simple
program to all the highly complex
application this is sort of the bare
bone or the for laying foundation for
any kind of basic security level premise
which you need to build your application
let's get started with inheritance so
inheritance is basically one of the most
important properties of any
object-oriented programming language
it's basically a concept and the concept
says that what if you have a scenario
where you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior and similar properties
let's understand this with the help of
an example let's take the example of a
bank
when you go to a bank to open an account
there are multiple types of accounts
there can be a savings account it can be
a type of current account there can also
be a different offering for personal
account and commercial accounts such as
for businesses
then you may also have loan accounts
which are having different kind of
properties so all of these types of
accounts are still
technically accounts and they will share
some similar properties for example all
of them will have to maintain some sort
of an interest rate for example all of
them will be used to either deposit
money or withdraw money so there would
be some kind of similarity across all of
these types of account classes but at
the same time there will also be some
sort of differentiality amongst these
classes the way you will calculate the
interest rate for a current account will
be different from the way you will
calculate the interest rate for a
savings account and the same applies for
commercial account personal account loan
account etc so you see that we have some
common behavior but at the same time we
also have some different behavior so
whenever you have such scenario always
think about applying the concept of
inheritance in your application there's
another simple way to spot whether
inheritance can be used at a particular
place or not
inheritance is also called is a
relationship so whenever you read the
requirements from a customer just try to
find the words which use this particular
phrase is a
for example
car is a vehicle savings account is a
type of account
similarly you will find many other types
of similar examples so whenever you will
see that is a relationship between two
different kinds of objects or two
different kind of entities that means
that there might be an inheritance
relationship being applied between them
and that's how you will spot the usage
of inheritance
so so far we have understood this
concept that there would be some sort of
relationship between the two classes
what will be this relationship the
relationship will be of parent child
type there will be a parent class some
people also call that as base class and
then there will be a child class so the
child class will be inheriting the
properties and the behaviors from the
base class or from the parent class i
will be using base class and parent
class terms interchangeably during this
session but the basic idea and basic
premise is like that only that there
will be a child class and there will be
a parent class and the child class class
is extending from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and i've just shown
you the uh what you see here is
basically the official definition which
is given by javadocs here we can read
the definition as well and the basic
idea which i told you lies in the parent
and child relationship and this is how
you can conceptualize it that you will
have a base class or a parent class and
then you will you can have multiple
children of it and then those children
can again have their own children and so
on so forth so this hierarchy this whole
inheritance hierarchy can go as deep as
you want it to be and that's the basic
idea and basic conceptualization of how
you understand and how you visualize
inheritance now let's move to eclipse
ide and try to understand this with the
help of an example so for this
particular case i have created a set of
classes basically which we will be using
to demonstrate the relationship of
inheritance and i've taken the simple
example of a bicycle so a bicycle is
again a very generic definition of any
two wheeler and bicycles can have
multiple types there can be an
all-terrain bike there can be a mountain
bike there can be a city bike there can
be a bike which is specific specifically
made for ladies and similarly there can
be multiple different types of bikes but
all of these bikes will have some
similar properties
for example all of them will have two
wheels all of them will have a seat all
of them will have brake all of them will
have some sort of some sort of a
speeding mechanism whether they can
accelerate or de-accelerate so there
will be some commonality but at the same
time a mountain bikes features might be
very different from a city bike feature
a mountain bike features might ah which
mountain bike might have gears for
example whereas a city bike might not
have gears because you don't need that
much of a variation in
in inclination and declination when you
drive down the road so i'm trying to
conceptualize the same example here
where i've created a class called
bicycle and this is my base class
i define two properties in the in the
bicycle class which is
gear and speed we will come back to
protected in a while but
let's let's leave that there so i have
two properties which is gear and speed i
have a constructor where i'm
initializing the starting speed and the
starting gear and then
i have three methods here which says set
gear apply brake and speed up when i
apply break the speed is going to get
reduced so that's why you see minus
equal to unity operator
and when i'm trying to speed up the
speed is going to increase that's why
i'm using the plus equal to unary
operator so when you use the method
speedup the speed is going to be
increased by the value you supply in the
method similarly when you apply the
break the speed is going to get reduced
by the amount you supply in the method
argument and that is my base class
bicycle gear speed and three methods now
let's have a look at the child class
so the way you will define the
inheritance relationship in java is by
using this extends keyword remember i
told you to remember the extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual and then you
will use extends keyword and then you
will use the parent class name or the
base class name so here i'm saying class
mountain bike extends bicycle and here i
am providing an additional property
remember the whole commonality versus
differentiality equation so a mountain
bike might have an extra property to
adjust the seat height so that's the
extra property which mountain bike is
having
and then
since this mountain bike is extending
the bicycle class
this mountain bike class has the
responsibility to initialize the bicycle
class as well
and the way it will fulfill that
responsibility is by taking all the
arguments of bicycle class plus the
mountain bike class in its constructor
and that's why you see three different
properties here you see the start height
property which is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class but this class is inheriting those
properties from the base class remember
the keyword inheritance here and then
once you do that how do you initialize
the base class constructor is by calling
the super method this is again a keyword
in java and you will use this super
keyword to refer to the base class
constructor in this way so what you will
do technically is that you will write
super and you will supply the arguments
which is required by the base class
constructor if i go back the base class
constructor requires two arguments start
speed and start gear
so i write super and then i write start
speed and start gear so whatever i got
from here in the constructor of mountain
bike i'm supplying those values as is to
super and java will automatically take
care of invoking this particular
constructor the moment it
encounters this kind of statement
another another thing to notice is that
the super keyword or super statement has
to be the first statement inside your
constructor remember that whenever you
are dealing with inheritance and
whenever you have to initialize the
super class constructor or the base
class constructor use the super
constructor invocation as the very first
statement inside your child class
constructor otherwise java will not
compile the program and then you will
initialize the local variable i should
call this as this remember i we
discussed about this in this in the
classes session
okay and then it just has a method of
set height so there's no extra method
which this mountain bike is providing
but this mountain bike will have access
to all the methods which have been
provided here and all the properties
which have been provided here this
mountain bike can access everything from
the bicycle class and that's the whole
idea of inheritance that the child class
can access the properties of the base
class by extending the base class
now let's look at how do we invoke this
particular class so for that i have a
simple class name as inheritance demo
which has a public static void main
method and then i am initializing the
mountain bike plus
i'm supplying three values as 20 10 and
one
so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to
start speed
and one here goes to gear or the start
gear and that's how i'm setting the
values so when i call this particular
constructor here the mountain bike
constructor is going to this mountain
bike constructor is going to get called
and which in turn is going to call the
base class bicycle class constructor as
well and everything will be set
accordingly and then let's try to access
the gear property remember gear is not
directly available in the mountain bike
class but i'm still able to do mountain
bike dot gear because child class can
access the parents class properties
similarly the same thing goes for speed
as well and seat height is the local
property of this particular class
mountain bike so it will anyways be
accessible so i can access all the
properties of the base class and the
child class itself seamlessly without
any differentiation now let's try to
call a method so here i'm calling the
method apply break remember apply break
was defined in the base class not in the
child class it's defined here so i'm
calling the apply break method and i
want to reduce the speed the current
speed by one and then i'm printing the
current speed saying that bike speed
after applying break is mountain bike
dot speed so let's run this particular
program and observe the outputs
okay
so the the first statement which gets
printed is at line number seven which
says gear is
one because it's coming from here then
the seat height is mountain bike dot
seat height which is 20 which is the
first argument here and then the bike
speed is 10 which is coming as here and
getting printed here and then when i
apply the break
let's go back to the apply break method
the logic is that whatever is the
current speed reduce it by the value i
supply in the method
so if i supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed if i
supply 5 here the current speed will be
10 minus 5 equal to 5. let's assert that
particular assumption as well yes we can
see that and similarly you can access
other methods of the base class as well
if i just do control space here and you
can see apply break is accessible set
gear set height speed up all the methods
which are defined in the base class are
accessible in the child class as well
this is the power of inheritance one
more thing which i said i will come back
to is around the usage of protected
access modifier
remember when we discussed about the
access modifiers in the previous session
i said that protected is used when you
are dealing with inheritance that
whenever you define something as
protected it will be available to be
accessible in the child classes of the
base class so if i define this
particular variable as as protected then
this particular property will be
accessible in the child class mountain
bike as well
let's play around this let's make this
as private and see what happens
so if i make this private now when i say
private the scope of this particular
variable is within the class only and
nobody outside the class will be able to
see it
and you can see the effect of it i can
see an error being coming here in my
inheritance demo class because now
mountain bike object cannot access the
gear property because the gear property
is defined in the base class and now it
is private that's why the child class
now mountain bike class cannot access
the property gear
and the moment you make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected access modifiers it is always
always recommended to use them when you
when you write any kind of inheritance
logic and in inheritance logic as well
intentionally if you want to hide a
particular
property from the child classes just
make it private and that's all i want to
cover in this particular session where
we
dive deep into the concept of
inheritance we had a look at an example
using the bicycle and mountain bike kind
of construct and you can apply the same
kind of construct on any kind of other
other kind of business requirement
remember that is a relationship let's
get started with encapsulation so again
let's understand what is encapsulation
in general and then we will apply that
concept to java encapsulation if you try
to break that word if i just write it
here in the form of a comment
it's en
capsulation just trying to break this
word into to make it more visual so you
see you see a word called capsule here
so if you try to imagine a capsule why
do you create that and what's the
concept of a capsule capsule tries to
pack a lot of things inside a small
tube-like shape and the concept of
encapsulation is sort of inspired from
that not exactly not literally but
that's the basic idea of of this root
word which is called encapsulation so
encapsulation basically means
to restrict
accessing the properties of a class to
the outside world if you want to protect
the properties of your class how do you
do that you do that with the help of the
concept called encapsulation so here you
this is a sort of a security feature you
can think of a think of it as a security
feature that you want to protect the
properties of your class
and you will use encapsulation
to protect the properties how you
implement encapsulation let's have a
look at that now so basic idea is to
encapsulate the objects create sort of a
capsule around the object which can
provide that protection layer and you
will define how the outside world is
going to access the properties of the
class if needed so i've created a simple
class here
and
it's if you if you remember one of the
previous examples when we discussed
about classes i used the same class
which was the student class and i'm just
using the same class for continuity so
i've created a student class here and i
have created three different properties
of this particular class which is name
name of the student age of the student
and address of the student you see
intentionally i have used the keyword
private
in front of these three properties and
that is the first thing which you need
to do to implement encapsulation on your
object that you hide all the properties
from the outside world remember the
moment you make anything is private only
the class which is the student class
itself only the class itself can see
these variables or these properties
nothing outside the student class will
be able to
access the name or age or the address
directly from the student class it's not
possible that's the whole idea of making
it private because you don't want the
outside world to access these properties
so you make those properties as private
then you create a constructor the
constructor has to be public so that
anybody can initialize the student
object because you want your object to
be accessible remember so you want the
objects to be accessible but you want
the restriction on the access
of the properties of the object
and these are the properties of the
object so you have restricted them by
making it private but that doesn't solve
the problem because there will be some
illegitimate consumers of the student
object which should not have access to
the student properties but there will
also be some legitimate consumers of the
student object which should be having
access to the properties of the student
for example the payroll
application will need access to these
particular
properties the examination application
will require access to these particular
properties so how do you do that
you create getters we call them getters
because they start with the keyword
get so you create a getter method for
each of the property you create the
method called as get name and this is
the naming convention with java promotes
that you write get and then you write
the name of the property in camel case
so you write get name and this property
is supposed to return the name property
of this particular object and you here
you say return name so you are returning
the the name which is being stored by
the current student object whenever
somebody calls student object dot get
name and this is the way you have
restricted the access of this particular
object as well so remember you made it
private so that nobody can access it and
then you defined your own way of
providing access to the
name property of this particular class
now if anybody wants to access the name
value of your student object there's
only one and one way to do that which is
via calling get name so you have
provided restrictions and you have also
provided prescriptive guidance on how
you are going to expose the properties
of your class that's the second
thing which you need to do to implement
correct form of encapsulation on your
object that that is to provide the
getter methods with the right visibility
you want to make them public so that
anybody can call them but
since you are governing which is what is
written inside the method you have full
control on what kind of exposure you
want to give for this particular
property similarly you create a getter
for age calling getage which returns the
age and then you call get you write get
address and return the address here it
is simply returning it but if you want
to do more stuff here feel free to do
that like i said you govern the control
of how do you want to return the name
maybe you don't want to return the
complete name and you want to just
return the initials then you can split
the string trim the string and return
only the initials so that's the basic
idea of getters
now after you have created the object
there might be use cases where somebody
needs to overwrite the values of the
properties like name age or address
whatever student's name was incorrectly
mentioned when they called the
constructor and now they want to
overwrite the name or fix the name so
basically they have to replace the
existing value of the name with a new
name
so in that case you need to provide what
we call as setters and they start with
set that's why we call them setters and
we follow the same kind of logic that
you provide the setters for all the
properties of your class so you had
three properties which were named age
and address and you provided the setters
for all three of them and how do you
provide that you write you again make
them as public because you want the
outside world to access this setter
method to overwrite the values of the
name this method is not going to return
anything so it is going to be void then
you write the name of the method which
starts with set and then the property
name in camel case and then you provide
the new value which is the value which
should be which should be the new value
and this is the value which should
replace the existing value so whatever
new value you want to supply you supply
that as the argument of the setter
methods for set name for set age or for
set address and then you write this
particular line which says
set the current name property of this
particular object with the name which is
coming in from the argument so this dot
name remember this dot name represents
the current objects property because
this represents the current object so
whatever is the current object property
value of the name is just overwrite that
value with the argument coming in do the
same thing for age and set age method
and do the same thing for set address in
the in the set address method so this is
how you are going to provide the setters
and the getters
so setters and getters can also be
generated in smart id is like eclipse so
you just right click you go to source
and here you will see the option of
generate getters and setters if you
click on this it will give you the list
of the fields which are available to be
had to be having getters and setters
currently it says no fields or all
fields have getters and setters already
yes because they have it let me just
comment this and show this how this work
so for example let me comment all the
getters and setters
so i'm commenting them and if i right
click
source
generate getters and setters i get all
the fields available
for which setters and getters can be
generated so you can select them and
leave everything as default hit generate
and it is automatically going to
generate the getter and the setter you
see all the code of the getter and
setter is automatically generated you do
not even need to write it and this is
the power of the smart ides let me just
uh revert what i did
so you created everything as all the
properties as private and then you
define how you want to replace the
values by providing the setters and you
define how you want the outside world to
access your properties so you have full
control of the class now you you control
the visibility you control how they are
going to get initialized you are you are
controlling how the properties are going
to be overwritten or set and you control
how the properties are going to be
returned so you have complete control of
the class so you have created a perfect
capsule here a perfect form of
encapsulation in this class and this is
how you can implement encapsulation
let's get started with abstraction let's
first understand the definition of
abstraction before we relate this to
java abstraction generally means hiding
something when you want to hide some
details of of a particular object from
the outside world you apply the concept
of abstraction for example when you
drive a particular car you just hit the
accelerator and the car speeds up now
it's not only one action when you hit
the accelerator the whole machinery of
the car and all the components different
parts of the car work together to speed
up they would be engine there would be
propulsion there would be fuel there
would be there might be some if it's an
electric car there would batteries uh
there would be whole different kinds of
pistons and plugs which will make the
car speed up it's not only a single
component it's a lot of different
components under the hood and that's the
concept of abstraction that we only show
the relevant parts to the user and we
hide all the internal details from the
user that's the basic idea of
abstraction so a car manufacturer
abstracts away all the inner technical
details from the driver and just gives
the driver a single pedal to speed up
the car for a user it's a very good
experience because he doesn't need to
know about all the internals of the car
but the car manufacturer can hide all
the details and provide a very simple
interface for the driver to interact
with which is just a gas pedal and
that's the basic idea of abstraction and
we try to apply the same kind of concept
to java in the form of abstraction and
java provides this kind of concept
implementation with the help of a
keyword which is called abstract now
abstract is a keyword which can be used
in front of a class or a method when you
use it in front of a class the whole
class becomes abstract abstract class is
a type of class so the class itself
becomes an abstract class one of the
things to remember is that abstract
class cannot be instantiated but can be
subclassed remember we talked about the
concept of subclass and the parent class
when we talked about inheritance so if
you make a class as abstract class you
cannot call the constructor of the class
because you cannot instantiate it but
you can extend the abstract class and
create a child class class out of it
that's the concept of abstract class
another concept is abstract method you
can also use the abstract keyword in
front of a method and when you use
abstract keyword in front of a method
then that method is only declared
without an implementation you are not
going to provide any implementation of
the method and you are just going to
declare the method something like this
we will see a similar example in the in
the hands-on as well but that's the
basic idea that you just declare the
method you are not providing an
implementation as to what does move to
method actually does because that's the
whole concept of abstraction and it is
the responsibility of the child classes
which inherit the particular class in
which the abstract method would be
sitting so that child class will be
having the responsibility to provide a
concrete implementation of the declared
method let's understand this better with
the help of an example so here i have
created a class called graphic object
and i have made the class as abstract
class this is the keyword which you need
to use in front before the class keyword
and the task becomes an abstract class
now when you create an abstract class it
automatically gets some properties the
first property is that this particular
class must have at least one abstract
method and this is how you define the
abstract methods where you just provide
the declaration but you do not provide
the implementation of the draw method or
the resize method and the way you will
create the abstract methods is by using
the abstract keyword before the actual
method declaration starts so general
method declaration would look like this
and if you use abstract in front of it
this becomes an abstract method
declaration abstract class can also have
concrete methods so that is the liberty
which abstract class gives you that you
can have abstract methods which are just
declared but you can also have normal
methods which are which
where you can also provide the
implementation so you can have normal
methods and abstract methods as well in
an abstract class
so this is the abstract class now if if
you want to provide an implementation of
the draw and resize method you have to
extend this abstract class so we extend
this abstract class by creating two
child classes out of this particular
abstract class which is circle.java
where you can see i create a normal
class and i use the extends keyword for
inheritance and i'm saying that circuit
class is inheriting from the graphic
object class which was my abstract class
and once i use this extends keyword then
i have the responsibility of providing
the implementation of the abstract
methods actually java will force me to
provide the implementation of these two
methods if i do not provide all the
declared methods so there are two
declared methods here so if the circuit
class does not provide that the
implementation for both draw and resize
methods then java will throw an error
and it will ask you to take an action
which can be either define all the
methods meaning provide implementation
for all the methods or make the circle
class itself as abstract let's see if i
just comment this particular out i get
an error you see a red line here and if
you click on this particular balloon
here it will say either you can add the
unimplemented methods or you can make
the circle type as abstract these are
the two options which you will get to
fix this particular error so an abstract
class can be extended by another
abstract class if the child abstract
class is not implementing all the
methods of the parent if you want to
implement all the methods then just
implement them and keep keep it as a
normal class and that's what i've done
here i've just created a normal class
here and provided the implementation and
once you provide the implementation of
both of the methods the error is gone
similarly i have also provided another
child class because it's
there can be
there can be multiple children of a
particular parent so rectangle also
extends from the graphic object and it
also provides its own implementation of
drawing and resize because generally the
way you will draw a rectangle and you
resize a rectangle will be different
than drawing or resizing a circle here
i'm not doing anything in the methods
because this is just to show you the
demonstration i'm just printing a cis
out saying drawing a circle and resizing
or drawing a rectangle and resizing a
rectangle and in the circle class
drawing a circle and resizing a circle
so one abstract class is the parent
class which is the graphic object and
two children circle and rectangle both
providing the implementation of the
abstract methods which were declared in
the base class now let's go to the main
class where i've defined defined the
public static void main method and here
you see i have created two different
kind of blocks of code here one block is
where i'm saying graphic object creating
a reference of the graphic object named
as circle and initializing the circle
object now you see a difference here
here is the abstract class and here is
the concrete class so whatever you
define on the right hand side whatever
is the type of object will be the type
of methods being caught so if you
created a circle object and then if you
call the draw method and resize method
these methods will be called from the
circle class if you initialized it as
new rectangle then you are creating a
rectangle class object and then the draw
and the resize method will be called
from the rectangle class that's the
basic construct and that's how you will
initialize
a particular class which is using an
abstract class so i i call a graphic
object circle new circle and i call
circle.draw and circle dot resize
similarly graphic object rectangle equal
to new rectangle and rectangle.draw
rectangle.resize
let's run this program and observe the
output so when i call this particular
block of code circle object gets
initialized and then circle.draw method
prints drawing a circle and
circle.resize method prints drawing
resizing a circle similarly when i
create the rectangle class object
referencing it with the graphic object
class rectangle.draw prints this
particular line drawing a rectangle and
rectangle.resize
prints this particular line which is
resizing a rectangle and this is how you
will use the concept of abstraction
there's another very interesting thing
which which is which is going on here
remember i told if i do this and i i
create i just put a system out here
base
abstract class so if i do this here if i
create if i still write a constructor
though java says that it cannot be
instantiated if i still write a
constructor of it and i do not do any
changes here and if i run this
particular program let's see what
happens you will see the base abstract
class being called here let me just
reformat it by putting ln here so that
we get a better output so if i run this
particular program you see base abstract
class is getting printed somehow though
we said that abstract classes cannot be
instantiated but still the constructor
of this is still getting called somehow
when i create a circle class the base
class constructor gets called and when i
create a rectangle class again the base
class constructor gets called this is
this is the power of inheritance because
in inheritance remember how it works
when you call when you initialize a
particular child object referencing it
with the parent object see the
references of the parent class and the
object is of the child class so whenever
you do it like this
first the default constructor because
i'm calling the default constructor here
the default constructor of the circle
class will get called which will go here
remember i told you that java provides
the default constructor automatically if
you don't provide it so the default
constructor of circle gets called but
java sees that you are writing this code
here which says circle extends graphic
object so java is automatically going to
call the parent class and going to
initialize the parent class as well
because that's how it will be able to
see these methods and so so that's why
it will automatically call the base
class constructor even if you don't call
it explicitly in fact you cannot call it
explicitly java will not allow you to
initialize the graphic object class
explicitly it can only and only be
called by java itself indirectly via the
concept of inheritance if you try to do
this let's try to do this for fun and
and also for better understanding so if
i write graphic object
go equal to
new graphic object you see i don't even
get an option but let's write it and
let's see what happens so you see that
this particular it gives basically an
error because it's not able to find the
constructor of the graphic object class
though even i have defined the default
constructor here but still java is not
able to find it because this class is
abstract so hence proved abstract
classes cannot be instantiated
explicitly they can only be instantiated
by the child classes through the
internal mechanisms of java itself and
that's all i want to talk about in this
particular session where we looked in
detail about the concept of abstraction
couple of more things which i did not
cover in the previous session i just
want to call them out for clarity java
does not support multiple inheritance
when i say multiple inheritance what it
means that you will not have a scenario
where a child will be extending from two
base classes java does not support it it
does support it with the with the help
of interfaces but i will talk about
interfaces in the coming sessions but
here just understand this that you
cannot use multiple inheritance with
classes in java a child cannot have two
parent or two base classes in java java
will not allow that it is also called
the diamond problem because the child
class does not know whether to follow
the route of base 1 plus or the base 2
class if it is extending from 2
different base 1 and base 2 classes so a
class can only extend from one class in
java we can find a workaround of it by
using the concept of interfaces but
that's something which will be coming
later another thing to understand is
that when you create an abstract class
here these variables you can declare
declare these variables as well and
these variables will be accessible by
all the child classes as you access them
let's get started with interfaces in
java now again let's understand what do
we mean by an interface in general and
then we will see how do we apply the
concept of interfaces in java so imagine
let's let's take the same example of
vehicle industry because that's
something which we see every day around
ourselves and we can relate to it so
imagine if all the car manufacturers
were creating a different way of driving
a car what if in one car you have a
steering but in other car you do not
have a steering but you have something
else which is which may be called
something else in one car you have the
gas pedal to speed up in other car you
have a button to speed up similarly in
in one car you may have
different kind of doors and in other
cars you may have different kind of
doors which are completely different
looking it's not even a single simple
handle to open it so you see the problem
here the problem here is that all the
car manufacturers are not working on a
single contract they are not respecting
a single interface which will create a
poor user experience because the users
whenever the users have to buy a new car
or they have to switch from one
manufacturer to other manufacturer they
are completely clueless as to how to
drive that particular class because the
interface they were using in the
previous car is completely different
from the interface they are being shown
in the other car and that's that's the
basic need for the concept of interface
think of it as a contract agreement you
see it is also mentioned here that
if you apply the same kind of concept to
programming world imagine if every
programmer was writing their own logic
in their own way without following a
single contract or a single guideline
soon it is going to create a problem and
that's the kind of problem uh interfaces
try to solve so interface is again a
keyword in java and the basic idea or
the basic construct is that the
interfaces are going to define the
specifications
of how a class would act let me repeat
this in a more generic way interfaces
are going to define the contract or the
specification which is going to govern
how an application or code or
programming logic will behave that's the
basic idea of interfaces
so interfaces are their own type and the
basic property of interface is that it
can only contain constants method
declarations similar to abstract classes
and some default methods or static
methods or nested types what is nested
type we will cover that later default
methods will touch upon a bit here and
the static methods as well but the basic
idea is that when you create when you
create an interface in java you cannot
write anything concrete in terms of the
behavior of the interface when i say
behavior always think of that as method
so you cannot define a concrete method
in an interface you can only declare
methods you can also declare constants
you can create a particular type of
concrete method by using the default
keyword but use it in very special
circumstances you can also create static
methods as well which are only going to
belong to the interface and nobody else
now let's look at an example
and and also before we go to the example
let me also phrase this here that if an
interface cannot define a concrete
implementation of the methods then
naturally the interface is going to be
extended by a child class a concrete
class which is going to provide the
implementation of the methods declared
in the interface it does sound like
abstract classes but there is a
difference let's understand the
difference with the help of an example
this is how an interface will look like
i've used the same construct of bicycle
and mountain bike just to maintain some
continuity and less context switching
but this is how an interface would look
like you will not use the class keyword
but instead instead of that you will use
the interface keyword you can only
declare methods you cannot define
methods remember when we looked at the
abstract classes example we were able to
define concrete methods as well but in
interface that's a strict no no you
cannot define concrete methods let me
show you the abstract class in the case
of abstraction which we used this was
the abstract class and it did have a
concrete method right but bicycle.java
here which is because it's an interface
it is not going to allow you to create a
concrete method another thing is that if
you try to declare a variable inside the
class they will have to be constant you
cannot just declare them without any
value for example i cannot do this
if i do this it is going to give an
error you see an error here and it says
initialize field x at declaration
something like this public static final
so interface is going to force you to
declare all the variables as public
static final with some value if you try
to use them inside interface
so that is also something which
interface will mandate so you see
interfaces are more strict they are more
strict in terms of what you can do you
can only declare public static final
variables and you can only declare
methods you cannot define methods so
abstract class is less restrictive
interface is more restrictive and that
is the differentiation which you have to
keep in mind whether to use abstract
classes or whether to use interfaces
that is also a very common confusing
question in the interviews as well and
remember that interfaces are only for
contracts or specifications where in
case of abstract class you can write a
concrete behavior as well in terms of a
concrete method in the base class
interfaces there is no concrete
implementation in the base class
abstract classes yes there can be a
concrete implementation in the base
class that's the basic difference moving
on i have created a child class here
which is again mountain bike and it has
three properties seat height gear and
speed similar to the previous example it
has a constructor and remember in again
interfaces cannot be uh initialized
directly so you don't even need to call
a super method here because there is
nothing to initialize you initialize a
class to create a state state is denoted
by the properties but interfaces will
force you to write a public static final
property and initialize its value
automatically so you do not need a
constructor for the interface because
there is nothing to initialize
everything has been initialized in terms
of the variables and the methods are
anywhere just declared that's why you
don't need to call super here after that
the moment you write this particular
keyword here implements and that is how
you will basically extend from the from
the interface you will use the
implements
bicycle keyword here implements is the
keyword and bicycle is the name of the
interface if you write this here then
java is going to force you to provide
the implementation of these two methods
if i
if i do this implements bicycle and if i
comment out these two methods which is
coming from the base class it is going
to give an error and if i read out this
error it says either you add the
unimplemented methods or you make the
mountain bike class as abstract there
are two ways to fix this particular
class similar to abstract classes it
will force you to write the
implementation of the base class
declared methods another thing which
java will will suggest you and will will
also force you via some ides as well is
that you use this particular annotation
we use this particular annotation to
tell java that we are overriding this
method from the base class since apply
break and speed up methods were defined
here in the base class and this child
class is supposed to provide the
implementation of the methods by
overriding them overriding is again a
concept which we will talk about in
detail in the coming sessions but for
now remember that you need to write this
annotation here on the
methods which have been taken from the
base class to provide an implementation
and the implementation is similar to
what we have seen before so whatever
value you supply in the apply break the
speed is going to get decremented by
that particular value and in case of
speed up whatever value you supply in
the argument that value is going to be
added to the current speed and the speed
is going to go up
let's look at the main class here which
is called interface demo it has a public
static void main method and here i'm
again initializing the child class
nothing's nothing strange here and then
i'm using the getter method here because
i have made everything as private here
and rest of the things are just here as
is i have the getters and setters here
for all the properties and i'm using
those here so i'm using the getters to
just get the value of gear seat height
and speed and then i'm applying the
brake and then i'm printing the current
speed after applying the brakes
let me just
expand this a bit more and then i'm
using the speed up method trying to
increase the current speed of the bike
by 10 and then printing the new speed
again so using the apply brake and speed
up methods which are concretely defined
in the child class by using this
override annotation and these were the
methods which were declared in the
interface in the base interface and
that's all it which is happening in this
particular class let's run this
particular program
and these are the values i get i get the
gear as one which is coming from here i
get the seat height as 20 which is
coming from here i get the current bike
speed as 10 this was the value which it
was initialized with then i'm applying
the brake and after applying the brake
the speed of the bike gets reduced and
it becomes 10 minus 1 which becomes
9 and that's what gets printed here and
then i'm speeding up the bike by 10 so
the current value of the current value
of the speed of the bike is
9 and if i incremented it by 10 it
becomes 19 and that's what gets printed
here let's get started with multiple
inheritance in java using interfaces if
you remember in the previous sessions i
said that multiple inheritance is not
possible in java and it is not possible
because of the diamond problem or simply
put a one child cannot have two parent
classes that's what java says and let's
understand why this is a problem so i
have created a very simplistic diagram
to to demonstrate the problem of
multiple inheritance and then we will
see how we can solve that so let's say
you have a class c a normal class then
you created two parents of class c so
basically class c is extending class a
and you also want the class c to extend
class b first of all it is not possible
in java and why it is not possible is
because of there can be a super class
which is
extending class a and class b as well so
you started with class c you wanted to
have you wanted class c to have two
parents which is a and b but a and b
also had a common parent which is super
class so now as you know that the child
classes can see the properties of the
base classes as well then if class c
wants to access something from super
class which route should it take should
it take this route or should it take
this route that is the problem which
will be called as the diamond problem
and that is the reason why java
prohibits using multiple inheritance
using classes so that's the problem
statement
that we don't have a clear route to
reach to the super class from class c
and we try to solve it using interfaces
so let's jump right into the eclipse ide
to understand how we can solve it so
here i have prepared an example for this
particular problem and the solution of
it so
again i'm using the same bicycle and
mountain bike example for the sake of
continuity i have created an interface
of bicycle which has two declarations
which is for applying break and speed up
this is my simple interface and then i
have a mountain bike class which is
implementing the bicycle interface and
providing the implementation of apply
break and speed up this is something
which we have already seen in the
previous example so nothing new here and
then you have other getters and setters
and you have a main class where you can
initialize the mountain bike and get the
gear get the seat height get the speed
we have covered all of this there's
nothing new here but now let's say you
have a requirement that you have another
interface
which is called vehicle and your
mountain bike should extend or implement
this interface as well is that possible
let's try that remember mountain bike
was already implementing bicycle
interface what if you want to have two
parents of this mountain bike using
interfaces like i said previously that
interfaces does solve the problem of
multiple inheritance so let's see if it
does solve that problem so i can just
say vehicle here and see if the code
compiles the code doesn't compile here
and the reason is pretty expected it's
because vehicle has a declared method
which is called can drive and mountain
bike now needs to provide the
implementation of that particular method
so if you click on this balloon and hit
on add unimplemented methods just double
click on that and you will get an empty
method definition of that can drive
method and let's put asys out for
simplicity and say
mountain bike can
be
driven so this is how you can see this
this code is working fine and now this
particular child class has two parents
it has a bicycle parent and it also has
a vehicle parent so if bicycle and
vehicle would have been concrete classes
then this would have caused an error let
me quickly show you that if i can so let
me go to bicycle and i just change this
to class and i
put an empty definition for both of the
methods and then let's go to the vehicle
class and convert interface and convert
that into class as well and again
provide an empty implementation so i've
just converted the vehicle interface and
the bicycle interface into classes and
now if i go back to the mountain bike
and if i change this to extends
i get a whole lot of errors
if i go here it says multiple markers
and it doesn't give you the right error
but the right error is happening because
you cannot extend from two concrete
classes now bicycle and vehicle are both
classes and mountain bike cannot do that
because java does not support multiple
inheritance from classes but if you go
back to the previous state if i just
quickly do control z here
and ctrl z here in case of vehicle as
well
converting both of them back to
interfaces and putting the implements
back here everything goes fine so using
interfaces you can implement multiple uh
inheritance but using classes you cannot
do that let's cover one more interesting
scenario what if you have a need to
extend from let's say one interface and
one more class is that possible because
we saw the comp we saw the combination
of two classes that was not possible we
are seeing the combination of two
interfaces
which is possible now is it possible to
extend from a base class and implement
an interface
let's see what happens if you try to do
that and i have another class this is
not an interface but this is a class
called two wheeler so technically
speaking mountain bike is a two wheeler
and at the same time mountain bike is
also a vehicle and mountain bike is also
a bicycle so what if you have a
requirement that your mountain bike
should also extend from two wheeler
class can you do that let's see if i can
do that i will just write extends uh two
wheeler and let's see if that works it
doesn't work here
but let's put it here if i put it here
does it work now yes it works there's no
compilation error here which means java
does accept this particular construct so
what happened here first thing when i
put this extends together after
implements java did not allow which
means that the extends keyword has to
come right after the child class it
cannot come after the implements clause
it has to come right after the child
class that's first thing second thing is
a normal class a normal child class
can extend from one concrete class
and can also implement any number of
interfaces you see i have two interfaces
so now technically this mountain bike
has three parents it has a concrete
class two wheeler as the parent it has
bicycle interface as the parent and it
also has vehicle interface as the parent
so three parents
so this con this basically uh justifies
the philosophy or justifies the concept
that a class can extend from only and
only one base class
but can implement any number of
interfaces you can have more interfaces
here as many as you want so
number of interfaces is not a
restriction but number of concrete
classes is a restriction a child class
will have only one concrete base class
but can have any number of interfaces
being implemented from this particular
class that's the basic property and then
the main in the main method
you can access any of the vehicle or two
wheeler or bicycle interfaces methods
and the classes methods as well if you
want to so for example if i want to
just type this and if i just to dot here
i can see i can access can drive as well
now can drive was implemented in the
vehicle interface or declared in the
vehicle interface
similarly if i look for the two wheeler
method can i see the two wheeler method
as well let's see if i can yes and this
you can see this is the two wheeler
class method which says can rotate two
wheels so i can call this particular
method which is coming from the two
wheeler class i can call the vehicle
class declared method which was can
drive
so this is also
possible and this is possible because in
the angle so let's run this particular
program and understand the output
so stylize mountain bike class and i
print the gear the seat height and the
bike speed values you have already seen
this
then i apply the brake and i speed up
applying the break
the speed becomes 10 minus
9 and after
speeding up
the new speed becomes 9 plus
as 90. then i call
mountain
bike
dot
can rotate
two wheelers
which is going to invoke
the
which is printing a simple sound so i
get the same sysout here this method is
being invoked from the mountain bike
object due to the concept of inheritance
similarly when i say mountain bike dot
can drive the scan i was declared in the
interface vehicle and then when mountain
bike implemented this interface java
forced it to provide a definition of
this particular method and this is the
definition which is again assist out and
you can see that says out being printed
here so this is how you can implement
multiple inheritance in java using the
power of interfaces
exhibits that kind of behavior then we
say that polymorphism is in action that
entity can be a class or an object or
even a method and in today's session we
are going to talk about that type of
polymorphism which is exhibited by
methods so we will see how a particular
method in java can take many different
forms containing different logics but
still having the same name
and that concept is called method
overloading so whenever you hear the
word that you need to overload a
particular method or this is method
overloading happening technically or
conceptually it's basically polymorphism
in action and polymorphism is being
applied on a method here and that
phenomena we call as method overloading
so in today's session we are going to
have a look at how we can implement
method overloading in java so the basic
idea of method overloading is that the
name of the method should remain the
same so you see in this particular class
which i have created to demonstrate the
method overloading so this is the class
name and the method name which i am
going to overload is called multiply and
that is probably the first thing which
you need to remember to implement over
method overloading correctly that the
method name is going to remain the same
the type of the return of the method may
change here you see it's returning in
here in the first instance in the second
instance also it is returning int but in
the third instance it is returning
double so the return type of an
overloaded method can change another
another thing which which can be varied
between same method being defined again
and again is that the number of
arguments and the type of arguments the
first multiply method takes two
arguments of integer type the second
multiply method takes three arguments of
integer type and the third multiply
method takes two arguments of double
type so by using method overloading you
can vary the number of arguments and
also the type of arguments so the basic
idea is that you declare you define the
method using the same name but you do a
variation in the arguments or the return
types and that's how you technically
implement method overloading in this
case in this particular case the
multiply is the method being overloaded
and in the first case it is accepting
two integer arguments and returning the
result of multiplication of those
arguments in the second case the same
method name multiply here the same
visibility public and the same return
type but this time three different types
of integer values can be accepted and
this method multiply method is going to
return the multiplication of three
integer numbers in the third case at
line 15 i again use the same multiply
name the method name but this time the
return type becomes double and this
method accepts two double arguments and
returns the result of the multiplication
of these double values so the method
name is same but the arguments vary and
also the return type may also vary
that's the basic premise of how you
implement method overloading so whenever
you want to implement it keep the method
name same vary the
arguments and the return types and after
that i'm just created a public static
void main method here i have initialized
the class here this particular class
itself method overloading demo and then
i am calling the multiply method on the
object and based on the number of
arguments i supply the corresponding
method will get invoked that is
something with java will take care
automatically that whatever type and the
number of arguments you supply in the
call in the invocation based on the
number and the type of the arguments
java will try to find a matching method
in the overloaded methods if it is able
to find a method it's going to get
invoked if it is not able to find the
method you will get an error in fact you
will get a compile error itself while
you invoke a method which for which the
definition is not available for example
if i try to just copy this and make an
invalid invalid method invocation let's
provide four arguments and if i do that
here itself i will get the error because
java is not able to find a multiply
method in this particular class which is
accepting four integer arguments so you
will get the compilation error itself
before you can even run the program but
the basic idea is that you use
overloading with multiple different
types and the number of variables so i'm
calling multiply three times let's run
this particular program and observe the
output
so let me just bring this output down
yep so first i call demo.multiply and
pass two integer values 10 and 20. when
this happens this particular method gets
invoked and it results it returns a
result of 10 into 20 which is 200. in
the second invocation i'm calling again
the multiply method but this time with
three arguments three integer arguments
specifically and this call is going to
match this particular method signature
and it is going to execute whatever is
written inside this particular method
which is the multiplication of the three
arguments being supplied so 10 into 20
into 30 which is 6 000 the third case
let's go back here at line 25 the third
case of invocation of the multiply
method is accepting two decimal based
arguments 10.5 and 20.5 so java is going
to look at the class and trying to find
a method which can accept decibel values
and there it is this is the method
signature which is going to match the
invocation java is going to do this
matching automatically for you and here
whatever logic you have written inside
this particular method we will get
executed so 10.5 into 20.5 returns
215.25 and that's the output you get so
this is how you can use method
overloading in java this is a rather
fairly simple example but you can make
it as complex as you want but a word of
caution do not use it too extensively in
fact lot of expert programmers do not
recommend using method overloading
because it becomes very confusing use it
only when you do not have any other way
out use it only where this is the only
way to write correct form of methods
with the right readability otherwise
generally there would be other ways to
avoid method overloading by writing
concrete purpose friendly method names
themself maybe you don't need to use the
multiply name again again we can call it
as multiply two numbers multiply three
numbers multiply doubles so that the
method name itself is more explicit and
understandable rather than juggling
around different signatures of the same
method especially it becomes more
confusing if you are creating an
interface which is to be consumed by a
third-party developers or third-party
application so try to use it with
caution that's what i'm trying to stress
here let's get started with method
overriding in java now in this session
we'll focus on another interesting
concept by which you can have the same
signature of the method again and again
be used in your code but in a different
way and this concept is called method
overriding method overriding basically
is used together with the concept of
inheritance you won't you will not be
able to use the concept of method
overriding without using the concept of
inheritance remember when we talked
about inheritance i spoke about the
subclass and the parent class concept
sometimes we also call the parent class
as super class so the basic idea is that
if a super class defines a method
remember i'm using the word define here
if the super class uses the uh defines a
particular method and then the subclass
again tries to define the method with
the exact same signature this phenomena
is called method overriding now when you
do method of method overriding there are
some rules to follow and i'm showing you
a tabular structure here a table
basically which will show you what is
possible and what is not possible when
it comes to method overriding so let's
try to understand this table so if you
try to define a method with the same
signature as a superclass method the
rules follow as per this table let's go
with the first one if you have an
instance method defined in the
superclass instance method is the normal
method which you define in your in your
classes so if you have defined an
instance method in your super class
and if you define a method in the
subclass with the exact same signature
then that concept is called method
overriding and it will be a successful
override override also let me also
explain what override means here
override means that once you try to
initialize the subclass object you will
be able to invoke its own overridden
method definition if you call that
particular method the subclasses own
instance method is going to get invoked
rather than the super classes instance
method we'll look at that when we look
at the example as well but that's the
normal scenario when where your
superclass defines an instance method
and subclass also defines the an
instance method with the exact same
method signature that concept is called
method overriding what if your
superclass defines a static method
static method is is basically a method
which belongs to the class but not to
the object instance method is called
instance method a normal method is
called instance method because it
belongs to the object you can call the
method on the object but static methods
are called by class so you say class
name dot static method name but when you
when you call instance methods you just
call object name dot instance method
name so that is the basic difference the
static methods belong to the class once
you have defined our static method the
same static method will be available to
all the objects of the class but
instance method are unique to each
object so that was a short tour of what
static methods mean so if you define a
static method in the super class and
then if you try to define an instance
method with the same signature in the
subclass you will get a compilation
error it will not be allowed it's not
allowed in java to override a static
method from super class that's what it
says next one if your super class has a
normal instance method and then the
subclass tries to use the same signature
but creates a static method out of it
then again you will get a compilation
error so that the overriding of an
instance method to a static method is
not allowed and the last concept is
again a very interesting concept and a
very popular interview question about
method hiding so if the super class
defines a static method and the subclass
also defines the static method with the
exact same signature then the superclass
static method gets hidden it basically
hides the superclass method so that's
the basic idea behind over method
overriding so if you see technically
it's a form of polymorphism because the
same method is having multiple
definitions
but when we looked at the previous
example the multiple definitions were in
the same class here the multiple
definitions are in different classes and
those classes are having a parent-child
relationship that was about the theory
of it let's go to an example of it to
understand it better and i've used again
the same construct of bicycle and
mountain bike which we have been using
in this in this series just to maintain
continuity so i have a parent class
called bicycle here which has two
properties gear and speed it has a
constructor nothing unusual there and
then it has defined three methods
set gear apply break and speed up set
gear is just setting the
new value as the gear value apply break
is going to decrement the speed by the
value you supply and speed up is going
to increment the speed by the value you
supply simple this is exactly what we
have seen before now mountain bike tries
to extend bicycle so mountain bike
becomes a child class it defines a
variable called seat height defines a
constructor called super here nothing
unusual so far also defines a setter for
height etc for the seat height not
exactly following the setter construct
but this is just to set the height but
here things just get interesting let me
just bring this down a bit yeah so here
it is overriding all the three methods
of the base class and by overriding it
is providing its own implementation of
the same methods let's compare them here
when it overrides the gear and whatever
value you supply it adds 2 to the plus 2
to that value and then sets that value
as the gear value but in case of base
class it was just setting the new value
as the gear value so for its for
instance if you supplied 1 here the gear
value becomes one but here if you
supplied one the gear value becomes
three similarly when you apply brake on
the mountain bike class whatever value
you supply will be subtracted from the
current speed and 10 would be subtracted
even more so if the speed is let's say
50 and your decrement you supply the
decrement value as 10 so it will be 50
minus 10 minus 10 equal to 30. but in
case of bicycle if the speed was 50 and
you supply 10 then it would be just 50
minus 10 40. so there is
and there is extra 10 being subtracted
from the speed when you apply brake in
case of a mountain bike similarly for
speed of its increment of 10 in addition
to what's what value you supply so again
if the speed was 10 and you supplied 10
here in the argument so 10 plus 10 plus
10 30 will become the new speed in case
of mountain bike but in case of bicycle
if you supply 10 and if the current
speed was also 10 then it becomes 10
plus 10 only 20. so that's the
difference so the basic idea i hope you
get the basic idea here is that you
override the methods and your own class
provide its own implementation of those
methods that's the basic premise of
method overriding all good so far and
you do not have a an
obligation to override all of the
methods because here we have the
concrete implementation of the methods
so here in case of mountain bike you can
skip overriding one of the methods if
you like to this is also fine there will
be no compilation error because speed up
has a concrete implementation in the
bicycle class as well so it's up to you
how much you want to override
so let's move to the main class now so
in the main class we have created the
public static void main method here and
let's look at what is happening inside
the class first we initialize the
bicycle class so bicycle class reference
and bicycle class object nothing unusual
here we supply the gear value and the
speed value then we print the gear and
the speed value we apply brake on the
bicycle and then we observe the new
speed of the bicycle after applying the
brakes let me comment out the rest of
the code and let's observe the output
for only this part of the code which we
just walked through for this section so
if i run this as a java application and
if i show you what i'm getting what i'm
getting here so bicycle gear is one
which is what you supplied in the
constructor bicycle speed is 10 which is
again what you supplied in the
constructor then you applied brake and
when you apply brake this logic gets
executed and you supplied 1 here so
current speed was 10 so 10 minus 1
becomes 9 and the new speed becomes 9
which is what you are printing here so
far so good let's move on to the next
section let me comment out the previous
section now and let me uncomment this
section so here i have a bicycle
reference but the object is of mountain
bike remember this concept this is this
is called dynamic object binding concept
or dynamic binding concept again this
might be asked in your interviews so
here i am initializing the mountain bike
with a reference of bicycle remember
whatever is written on the right hand
side will govern the variables and the
methods usage we'll we'll we'll see how
that works out what i just said so i'm
supplying three values here 50 50 and 3
in the mountain bike uh if i go here in
the mountain bike constructor so the
start height start speed and gear are
the three values which is supplied as 50
50 and 3 then i am accessing the gear
and the speed now remember gear and
speed are declared in the bicycle class
but they are accessible in the child
class due to the inheritance phenomena
which we have already covered so if i
print only this part i should get the
expected values
mountain bike gear is three which which
is what i have supplied here and
mountain bike speed is 50 which is which
is what i have supplied here then i
apply the breaks now let's move on to
this section i apply the break supply
the value as one and then i want to see
what would be the new speed after
applying the breaks so let's see what
happens when we run this particular code
so if i run this code after applying the
brakes the speed becomes 39 before
applying the brakes the speed was 50. so
what happened here is 50 minus 1
basically this this logic is getting
executed here 50 minus 1 minus 10 which
becomes 39 that's why you get the value
as 39 as the new speed similarly if you
want to call another method as speed up
speed up method was also defined here
where i'm saying speed plus the argument
supplied plus 10 so the current speed is
39 right now then i'm speeding it up by
10 so
by this logic 39 plus 10 plus 10 which
will become 59 and then i'm printing the
new speed after speeding up so let's see
what happens so if i go to run as java
application and if i observe all the
outputs the speed was 50 initially after
applying the brakes the speed became 39
and after speeding up the speed became
59 so this was a quick demo to show you
the power of method overriding and how
you can override the behavior which is
defined in the base class let's get
started with the static keyword in java
now let's first understand the need of
the static keyword and then we'll talk
about how java implements the static
keyword imagine a scenario let's take
the example of a class which we have
been using in our in our different
tutorials in this particular series
which is about the student class so if
you are building a college management
system you have a student class there
and if you have an entry a property in
the student class which is storing the
name of the college then the name of the
college is going to be the same for all
of the students of that particular
college it's not going to change another
example let's say you are building a
employee management system for our
organization and you want to maintain
the employee numbers for the first
object the employee number should be one
for the second object the employee
number should be two for the third
object the employee number should be
three so on so forth so when you
initialize all the employee objects the
last employee object has the final total
employee count and you can also treat
this employee count as let's say the
employee number as the employee id so
starting from the first employee to the
last employee the employee number is the
employee id which is a way to uniquely
identify an employee so we talked about
two different cases in the first case we
had a particular value which was same
for all of the objects which was the
student and the college relationship and
then in the second example which i
quoted where all the employees objects
have to share a particular property
amongst them because if the second
object did not know the previous value
of the employee number it will not be
able to get to the new number it needs
to know what was the previous value so
that it can do plus one so each of the
object needs to know the state of the
previous object two different cases two
different scenarios one single solution
which is static keyword so the static
keywords are used for those members
which belong to the class now apply this
definition to the examples which i gave
you if i make a member of the student
class let's say the college is the
property of the student class and if i
make that property as static now that
static on that member that static member
becomes the property of the class and
not the property of the object it means
it belongs to the class it also means
that all of the objects will get the
same copy of this static member variable
and that's that's one of the first usage
and you can you can make any property or
any member of the class as static by
just putting the static keyword in front
of it we also call the static member
variables as class variables like i just
described so use it for the cases where
the value across the different objects
doesn't change you can make those class
variables those variables as class
variables or static variables similarly
also try to identify the cases where a
particular value has to be shared in
terms of knowing the previous state in
those cases as well you can use a
particular member in that particular
class and make that static for example
in this case we have a bicycle class and
we have a static variable which says
number of bicycles so every time you
initialize the bicycle object this
number will be shared and you can see i
mean this is here it is incrementing the
number of bicycles so every time you
create the object the id becomes plus
one to the previous count of the number
of bicycles exactly same example as they
gave you for the employee number so
every time you create an object you do a
plus one to the previous value next
object will take the previous value plus
1 and so on so forth so you can use the
static
keyword in front of a property of the
class and make it a class level variable
which will be tied to the class and not
tied to the objects we can also make the
methods as static as well and the same
kind of rule will apply on the methods
as well that the methods will become
will belong to the class instead of
belonging to the objects let's say you
have again a common functionality which
you want to share amongst objects just
make that common functionality as a
static method and that would be shared
amongst the objects for example you want
to get the total number of bicycles for
the previous example which i just shared
in this particular dock here so you can
just create that method static and any
object which will call this method will
get the latest count of the number of
bicycles you can also make these uh
these uh static variables as constants
by putting the final modifier in front
of it so if a variable in a particular
class is static and final both then
technically becomes a constant so these
are some of the interesting use cases
and
constraints of the static methods and
static variables there's also a thing
called static block which is just a code
block which you can write inside your
class and we will have a look at that
example as well so let's shift to the
ide and let's have a look at how we can
use this static keyword so i have used
again the same class which i have been
using using in other examples which is
student.java and you can see i have this
same class you have you would have seen
these properties earlier as well and the
code below is exactly the same just
setters and getters and constructors and
it has an additional property which is
college and the college name xyz is the
same for all the students so i have just
hard coded it but you see what is
happening here is that every time you
create a student object this variable
gets initialized even though the
variable for all the objects has the
same value still it gets initialized
again and again and again so technically
it's a waste of memory you're just
wasting memory of an of a new allocation
every time even though the value is same
what if we create this object once and
this member variable once and just use
it across objects you can do that by
just writing static in front of it if
you do that then you see this becomes
sort of italic here and that's java's
convention to show that this particular
variable is a static variable you can
also see the static keyword in front of
it and then whatever value you have
specified this will be initialized only
when the class is loaded remember i'm
not talking about the object
initialization i'm talking about the
loading of the class in the jvm
so the first time the class is loaded
this particular variable will be
initialized and that's it after that no
matter how many student objects you
create the same college reference will
be used again and again and the college
variable will not be initialized again
it will be initialized once and the same
college reference will be used again and
again that's the power of static
variables for example if i want to
access this particular college variable
how do i do that so let's look at a main
class where i have initialized this
particular student class with an object
named as john and i've specified the
name the age and the address and i'm
printing those values how do we access
the static variable if i say john dot do
i get access to the college variable
yes i do have access to it but does it
work let's see you see a yellow line
here and we will come to that yellow
line in a while but let's first see if
this works
yes it works i can see that the college
name is printed here as xyz which i have
set now let's look at the error or the
warning it says the static field student
dot college college should be accessed
in a static way because the way you are
accessing it right now is the instance
way of accessing a particular member
this is not a static way of accessing a
member so if you want to access this is
going to raise a lot of violations and
lot of questions for you as to why you
are not accessing it via the class name
so this is the correct way of accessing
it and you will get the same output now
no matter how many objects you create of
the student class you can always access
the student.college and you can always
get the same value of the college name
that's the first use case second thing
is about static methods so you will use
the static methods in a case where i
described about the counting the
employee numbers and let's say if we
have the same kind of scenario where you
have to count the number of students
because you can use that particular
count as let's say the role number of
the student so if you have that kind of
requirement then you need to create a
static method because you need to share
the state of the object across objects
remember that so what you can do simply
is create a static method so let's say i
create a normal method and then i just
put static in front of it saying static
void student count and now i want to
count the student so i can let's create
a simple count variable and let's start
it with 0 and then i can increment the
count variable again and again in the
static method right but you see i get an
error here the error is if you go to the
balloon it says cannot make a static
reference to a non-static field count
this is one of the properties of the
static methods the moment you make a
method as static then that particular
method can only access the static member
variables of the class the static
methods will not be able to access the
non-static variables count is a
non-static variable count is a normal
instance variable so a normal instance
variable for that matter name or age or
address nothing would be accessible here
if i try to access let's say i try to
access name here so if i just say this
out and i say name it will also give me
give me the same kind of error if i go
here it gives me the exact same error
because static method cannot access the
non-static member variables of the class
so you have to make this count variable
as static as well and then only this
compilation error will be fixed i can
remove this one and now this method is
fine now i can
increment the count every time that
object is created
and that is one of the use case of using
the static method that you can share the
state across the different objects
and if you want to fetch this particular
variable then you can simply write a
getter for this
saying end count return count and then
you can return the count you can see
that but a static method cannot access a
non-static variable remember that a
static method can not access a
non-static variable but a non-static
method can very well access anything
including the static variable that's
second thing the third concept is of
static block
and static block also has a similar
usage that if you have a block of code
it's not just a variable it's not just a
method but you have a block of logic
which you want to execute only once when
the class is loaded into the runtime if
that is your requirement then you can
write a static block and the way you
will write it generally we write it at
the beginning of the class and the way
you will write it is it as you write
static and you put curly braces and you
start writing code here as to whatever
you can say initializer
and you can write whatever code you want
to write the only caveat is that in the
static block you will only be able to
access
only the static member variables of the
class so you will not be able to access
these variables you can only access
these two variables you can very well
move these two variables here if you
want to so if i go here i can paste this
and i can drop the static keyword
because everything in the static block
is automatically static so i don't need
to explicitly call out static variable
and now this code is fine you get some
warning because it's not used anywhere
in the class but that's fine because
this is just a simple demo but the whole
point is that you can write the static
block and you can write all these
initializer code which you want to write
here which you only want to execute once
during the whole execution of your
program just to show you the the reason
and
the way it works let's try to see if the
static block works
and let me comment all the static code
which i wrote here and let's go back to
the static demo and let me remove this
one as well so now i just will run this
student dot java i will i will create an
object of student.java and i will see if
the static block gets executed or not so
let's run this particular class which is
the main class and i have a main method
i have a student object initialized and
i'm printing the name agent address
if i run this you see the first line of
code which gets printed in the output
console is the static block code
which is what i wrote here and let me do
one more thing just for fun sake let me
create more objects of it
let me just call them one
two
three and four
and let's see and let's see how many
times the initializer code gets printed
you see that the code still gets printed
only once even when i created five
different objects of the student class
and that's the property of the static
block that it will be executed only once
when the program is loaded into the
runtime and that's all exceptions in
java let's first understand what are
exceptions and why do we actually need
this concept the simple reason for
having exceptions existence is that
developers make mistake we do create
bugs and errors while we write code it's
natural it always happens that whenever
you write code you might miss out some
condition or the other which creates a
bug in the application which creates a
defect in the application and then the
testing team finds that defect and then
we fix that defect and that's how a
normal software development life cycle
works so to handle those kind of
exceptions and errors every programming
language provides their own exception
and error framework to support the
developer in spotting those errors and
fixing those errors and handling those
errors instead and java also provides
its own exception framework so what you
see on the screen right now is basically
the a snapshot of the exception
framework of java and you see it has a
long hierarchy of different classes here
this is also an inheritance hierarchy
just to give you context and the whole
exception framework hierarchy starts
with a class called throwable so
throwable is is the class which is the
root or the parent class of handling all
types of exceptions and errors and
that's where the next differentiation
comes exceptions and errors java treats
these two things differently and i will
go in detail as to what is an exception
and what is an error but let's first
understand the hierarchy further under
the exception hierarchy you see some
exceptions like io exceptions which is
an exception which comes when something
goes wrong in the file writing or file
reading or the file handling operations
then you have sql exception which comes
whenever you are talking to the database
writing sql queries and something goes
wrong you also have class not found
exception which comes when a class is
not found in the in the run time or in
the or at the time when the class is
being loaded in the jvm and then you
have also run time exceptions which are
the arithmetic number format and there
are a lot and lots more of this type of
exceptions as well on the right hand
side you have the error
type and then you have some errors like
jvm error memory error and framework
error so now coming to the
differentiation between exception and
error exception is a type of problem
which
can be recovered in a program from which
the program can be recovered which the
developers should handle so exception is
a type where the developer focus is the
developer is responsible to make sure
that none of these exceptions occur in
the program and if these exceptions
occur in the program then the developer
has the responsibility to handle these
exceptions properly we will look at the
examples of how the developer can handle
these exceptions on the right hand side
is the error type where the developer
does not have any control you cannot do
anything if the jvm has an error or if
the underlying memory of the computer or
the jvm memory gets an error or the the
whole framework or the java itself
library itself has an error you can't do
anything about that and those are the
kind of problems which go into the
category of error that's why java has
created these two different categories
one is exceptions which is the
responsibility of the developer and
other is error which are not the
responsibility of the developer and in
fact developer cannot do anything if
this happens
so this was a quick tour to you to what
kind of the exception framework is
present in java do read about this
framework in detail in the java docs as
well but just to extend this
understanding further we'll have a look
at some examples of the exceptions and
how these exceptions occur so with that
i'm going to switch to the eclipse ide
and i have created bunch of classes to
show different types of exceptions so
let's go through the first class which
is named as simplexceptiondemo it has a
main method it has a variable of int
type the variable name is data and what
i'm doing here is i'm dividing hundred
by zero so if you see this carefully you
know that this is going to result in an
infinite value you cannot divide any
number by zero and java also prohibits
doing the same because it doesn't make
sense to divide anything by zero so if
you run this particular line if you
execute this particular line this is
going to throw a runtime exception these
are the runtime exceptions remember
so let's try to comment rest of the code
and let's quickly try to run this so i
run this program and there you go i get
an exception which says exception in the
thread main main is the main thread
which the exception type is
java.lang.arithmeticexception
and this is the exception type divide by
zero and it will also give you the line
number at which the exception happens if
you click on this it will directly take
you to the exact line at which the
exception happened and this is you know
if you see now this helps the developer
a lot this
information which is printed here is
called exception stack trace and you can
look at the stack trace go to the last
line and this would be the line from
where the exception actually originated
if you click on that particular line it
will take you exactly at the place where
the exception might have occurred and
then you can look at the line fix the
code and rerun the program to see if the
exception is gone that's why i said that
developer has to handle this exception
now as far as handling these exceptions
is concerned i am going to cover that in
the next session but in the in this
particular session we are just going to
focus on the types of exceptions and how
they occur this was an example of
arithmetic exception where we are trying
to divide something by zero let's take
another example let me uncomment this
particular line of code and comment back
this one so here i am creating a string
a but the string is null and null means
nothing it's it's a it's a void
reference it has nothing in it and now
if i try to do some operation on this
particular string so remember a is null
and whenever you are trying to operate
something on a null object java is going
to throw an exception because you can't
operate on null because null means
nothing empty it is it is a dummy thing
so you cannot do anything on this
particular null reference and if i run
this program i get an exception which
says null pointer exception java dot
lang dot null pointer exception and it
will give you the exact reason cannot
invoke string dot care at int
string dot this is a string type string
dot care at int because a is null so it
will give you the exact reason as to why
this program failed and then again if
you click on this particular line it
will take you the exact line where the
problem is and then you can fix the
problem maybe you need to initialize the
string properly to make sure that this
error doesn't occur so these are all the
runtime exceptions which the developer
has to take care of which the developer
has to fix
to make sure that the program runs
smoothly if they don't handle it the
program is going to fail and the program
will actually force them to fix because
the program will not run unless they fix
those exceptions now these are the
examples of runtime exceptions you can
also create these kind of exceptions
which are called checked exceptions
runtime exceptions are also called
unchecked exceptions you might hear this
term as well some some people use the
term runtime exception instead of
unchecked exception and use both of them
interchangeably so runtime exceptions
are also called unchecked exceptions and
these exceptions are called checked
exceptions why do we call them checked
and unchecked is because
these exceptions are something which you
do not have to explicitly specify in
your program in this program i did not
have to explicitly specify this
particular because i don't know if this
line of code is going to result into a
null pointer exception or not but these
exceptions are something which java will
force you to handle let's look at an
example of this so i have created one
more class which is named as checked
exception demo and i'm doing some file
operations basically reading a file
writing to a file etc i'm using some
classes of java named as file reader and
some methods like readline and close and
if you see the moment i'm trying to read
a file
this line has a
has a red marker there's a compilation
error if you scroll over it it says
unhandled exception type file not found
exception so java is forcing you to
handle this error this particular
exception because file not found is a
checked exception so if your expression
your line of code is throwing a checked
exception then java will force you to do
something about it it will not compile
the code until you either handle this
exception or you re-throw this exception
again how do we handle this is something
which we will cover in the next session
but you can you can always re-throw this
exception but you have to do something
about it you cannot just skip it so what
i can do if i don't want to handle this
is i will pass on the responsibility of
handling this exception to the
program
so whoever is going to call this method
has the responsibility now to handle the
file not found exception because i have
just thrown it i just passed it on i've
just passed my responsibility to the
colleague and you can do similar thing
here as well if i go here you see it
says unhandled type exception i o
exception and if you remember i
exception is here it is a checked
exception so i can do one more throws
here comma v and now if i just resume
the import whoever is calling the main
method has the responsibility of
handling the file not found or i
exception you can also handle it like i
said or you can just add throws clause
to the method signature and then the
caller has the responsibility to fix or
handle the exception so this is how the
checked exceptions work remember in the
unchecked exception in the runtime
exception
we we can see that these two lines do
throw exceptions but there is no
forced way by java to tell us that you i
have to fix it because java doesn't care
about unchecked exceptions at the
compile time it will only encounter
those runtime exceptions at the run time
that's why they are called runtime
exceptions but checked exceptions are
compile time exceptions and you have to
fix them handle them or throw them right
at the time of compiling the code so
that was about checked exception now
there's also a possibility that you can
create your own exception if you want to
so for that i've just created a very
simple class here called my exception
and the way you create your own custom
exception is by just extending your
class with exception class you just
write this extends exception and you can
write a default constructor or a
parameterized constructor whichever
makes sense for you and this is your
exception class ready to use and you can
just invoke this exception explicitly
remember whenever you are creating your
custom exception it is by default a chat
exception so your program has to handle
it for example if i go back to this
particular class and if i do this let me
just comment all of this code now and
remove the throws clause as well so if i
go here and i'm saying throw new my
exception my exception was my class so
i'm explicitly throwing an exception
which was my custom exception and i
again get the error if i hover over it
it says unhandled exception type my
exception so i have to handle this
exception or i can just throw this
exception
and let the caller handle it so this
also works so this basically builds our
understanding that broadly there are
three different types of exceptions
which we work with there is a runtime
exception which is also called unchecked
exception which happens because of
developers mistakes in the program like
this one then there is a checked
exception
which developer might not be responsible
for creating the exception but developer
has to handle it and there are some
classes in java which throw those
checked exceptions like file not found
exception and ioexception whenever you
are working with file handling
operations java will force you to handle
those checked exceptions or re-throw
those checked exception using the throws
clause similarly the third type is when
you create your custom exception type
and custom exception types are also
checked exceptions by default and
whenever you are explicitly throwing
your own custom exceptions you again
have to either handle the exception
within your enclosing code or you can
just re-throw the exception and let the
caller handle it so this is a quick tour
of different types of exception and
including this exception hierarchy let's
get started with exception handling in
java using try and catch blocks
so in the previous session we had a look
at the scenarios where an exception can
occur how do we
see that there's a runtime exception or
there's a checked exception or there's
an unchecked exception or there is a
custom exception
now
we did not talk about how to handle
those exceptions
and now we are going to focus on the
handling part
so whenever you have to handle those
exceptions
the way java provides for that is using
the try catch block
so try catch block is basically a bunch
of syntax which you have to follow to
handle different types of exceptions in
your programming code
and the syntax of the try catch block is
pretty straightforward
you write try and you put curly braces
and then you write whatever code
which might
throw an exception you don't know that
but it's always safer to enclose your
code in a try catch block so that you
know that if an exception occurs in the
try block
then you can handle it in the catch
block
so it's a it's always considered a
better practice to enclose your
application code in a try catch block so
that you can handle the exceptions
so you put this tribe block and right
write all the
suspicious or non-suspicious code which
may or may not throw an exception inside
the try block
once you have done the dry block part
then comes the catch block part
so let me go to the catch block
so this is how the syntax look like once
you have written the try block then you
write catch
and you put braces
and you write the exception type
which this block of code might throw or
the exception type which you are
interested in catching
you might not be interested in catching
all the different exceptions but only a
few ones based on your business
requirements so whatever exception type
you want to catch
you are going to catch it like this
and if an exception occurs in the tri
code
let's say you have specified an
arithmetic exception here and if
any line of code in the try block throws
an arithmetic exception
then this catch block is going to catch
that exception and then inside these
curly braces
you can decide what to do with that
exception
whether you want to lock that exception
or whether you want to re-throw that
exception whether you want to
embed some error code or get an error
code out of it or convert that exception
into a business or custom exception of
your own choice so it's up to you what
you want to do with that
but catch block will be able to catch
that arithmetic exception
similarly you can specify as many
exception types to be caught as you want
and keep adding more and more catch
blocks
remember that these catch blocks work in
a in a sequential fashion
so if an exception occurs here it will
first go to this particular block to
match the exception type
if it didn't match then only it will
move to the second type
if it did match the first type it is not
going to execute the second type so that
is how the try catch block work
you can see an example here that if the
code here is throwing an index out of
bond exception then it is going to be
caught here
and we are just printing the index out
of one exceptions message
if it is throwing an io exception then i
can do this so you can keep adding
different checked and unchecked
exceptions in the catch block
you can also catch more than one type of
exception with one exception handler so
rather than writing these multiple catch
blocks individually you can combine
these exceptions together if your
logic of processing
both of these exceptions is the same
remember if the logic of processing
these two exceptions is the same
logic means whatever you write inside
these curly braces
so if that code is going to be the same
for both of these exceptions then why
bother writing two catch blocks
just write one catch block like this
use the pipe operator to separate
different types of exceptions and write
the common code which is going to be
applied if your try block is going to
through an i o exception or an sql
exception
so that depends upon you
that's the second piece
the third piece of the try block is the
final block so we talked about the try
block we talked about the catch block
now there's a finally block as well
remember this is finally and not final
the final block is used
together with the try catch block when
you want to perform some cleanup
operations
imagine you are opening up a file
handler
in the try block you are doing something
with it and then you want to just close
the file handler irrespective of the
fact if there was an exception in the
try block or not because even if there
was an exception the file handler
resource is going to remain open and is
going to consume memory in your
application you might you don't want to
do that similarly if you open the
database connection inside your try
block
irrespective of the fact of what happens
in the try block you always would like
to close the database connection and you
can write that closing code in the final
block that's the purpose of the finale
block that you can write the code
inside the finally block which is
supposed to be always executed
irrespective of the fact whether an
exception occurs or doesn't occur
so now we have built a good
understanding of what is the try catch
what is what is the try block catch
block and the finally block now if you
just put it all together
this is how it is going to look like
that you write the try block you do
something inside the try block then you
write the catch blocks
after that you write the final block
you can write the finely block without
the catch block as well remember that if
you do not have any exception to catch
but you have some resources to close or
free up after executing the try block
you can skip the catch block and just
right try finally that is also possible
with that understanding let's switch to
the ide and let's look at some examples
i have a writer helper class
which is having a method called write
list i have a try block here
and this try block is basically
initializing an error list
adding an item to the error list
and then i'm accessing list dot get one
remember when i added this particular
value let me make it tend to make it
more understandable when i added 10 to
this particular list this goes to the
index 0 position
and here i'm trying to access index one
position
which does not have anything
so in such case it might throw an error
because there is nothing at least not
get one so this is my method where i put
the try block code and then because
i don't want to end up in a position
where i get an index out of bond
exception index out of bonds exception
comes if you are trying to access an
index
which is illegal which is does not
having any value
so i'm putting a catch block and
catching the index out of bound
exception
and just printing the message of the
and then i'm for just for simplicity i'm
showing a final block as well though i
do not have any resource to close here
but this is just to show you how this
looks like in the code
this is just to show you that i'm
putting i'm printing assist out here
this is what my method is and if i go to
the main class
the try catch demo class i'm creating an
object of the writer helper class and
calling the write list method which we
just walked through
let's run this program and see what
happens
okay so first i get the statement saying
entering try statement so if i go here
i call this method
the execution goes inside the try block
and i get this out which says entering
try statement
then i try to access the second element
in the list because the position is 1
this is going to index 0 and i'm trying
to access index 1. there is nothing at
index 1 so i get an error saying index
out of bounds exception index 1
out of bounds for length 1
because the total length of the list
currently is 1 because there is just 1
element and that 1 element is sitting at
0 and not 1.
so i get the exception
which is the index outer bound exception
but the index outer bound exception is
caught by my catch block and the
system.error.println
is something which gets executed
and i get this particular
line this particular line
from
this
line number 17
and then irrespective of the fact
whether an exception occurred or not my
final block always gets executed
let's fix this and see if the finally
block gets executed even if there is no
exception so now accessing get 0 and
let's see what happens
yep i access the element 10 no exception
but the final block still gets executed
so this is to assert our understanding
that the finally block will always be
executed irrespective of the fact
whether there was an exception or there
wasn't
now you can also nest different try
blocks if you want to
let's look at an example where i have
multiple try blocks so you can initial
you can write a try within a try within
a try if you want and you can go as deep
as you want but remember the more
indentations the more hierarchy you
create the program is going to get more
and more complex so always remember
to have that kind of trade-off
so i write multiple try blocks i
initialize an array i print
added 10 obviously array 10 does not
exist because this array has just four
elements so this is bound to throw an
index out of bound exception and i'm
catching that exception immediately in
the catch block this is the exception
printing assist out and just to
rethrowing the exception you can also
read through the exception by just using
the throw keyword remember this throw is
different from the throws keyword which
comes in the method signature this is
just to throw any exception from your
code
so this is array index outer bond
exception for this try block
then i have another array index outer
bond exception for this try block
which starts from here block two
and then i have another catch block for
the block one try block
so you can see it is already getting a
bit complicated where i have multiple
hierarchies but you can do that
so this is what is happening in this
particular program now let's try to run
this and see what happens and try to
decipher the output
okay so at first i get this particular
line which says
array index out of bounds exception in
block 3.
what happens here is that this line gets
executed
it throws an array index out of bounds
exception
at line 13 that array index out of
bounds exception is caught
which was generated from this line
and then we go inside the catch block we
execute this cis out this is what you
see here the same sysout and then we
re-throw the exception
if we read through the exception the
exception goes to the enclosing
try block
the enclosing try block is this one
there was an exception rethrone from
this try block and now it has gone to
this try block
and now
this try block block 2 will try to see
if it can catch this array index out of
bound exception
yes we can catch it
so it can so the block 2 again has a
catch block which catches the array
index out of bound and it prints assists
out here which says exception in block 2
which we see here
and it again re-throws the exception
and if it rethrows the exception so now
the block 2
now the block 2 is re-throwing the
exception so this whole code
is now re-throwing the exception if this
block 2 is re-throwing the exception it
goes to block 1 just going one hierarchy
up and then it sees if it can handle the
exception in the catch block
of this block one so yes the block one
try block also had a catch exception
which said array index out of bound e4
and here it just had a sys out
so if i just bring back the output
yes we do get this a particular
exception printed here which says array
index out of bounds exception in block
one
this is what you see here
and this is where the exception just
stops going propagated because i'm not
re-throwing the exception from this
particular catch block so that's where
the exception ends the reason you see a
hyperlink here is because the text
the text which i have printed here
exactly matches with the name of the
exception so java is pretty smart in
that case if you use the exact same name
exception it will link it to the
matching class name in java which is
pretty cool
i also have a redundant cache block here
which does not have a try block this is
just to show you that you can write a
catch block without a try block but it
doesn't make sense it is of no use so i
can just remove this particular catch
block and the program still will compile
fine
so this was a quick demo to show you how
you can use try catch and finally blocks
and when would you use the final block
and if you want you can use a nested
hierarchy of try blocks and you can
re-throw
the exception from within the catch
block only to be caught in the outside
or the outer or the enclosing block so
this is all i want to cover in this
particular session let's get started
with equals and hash code in java
this is probably one of the most
important and interesting concept in
java and extremely extremely popular
when it comes to java interview
questions
so let's cover this in detail to
understand why we need equals and hash
code and what equals and hash code is
all about let's first understand the
object class of java
remember i'm calling it an object class
and not just an object
object is a class as well in java and it
is the super super class of any class
you create in java so anything you do in
java any class you create it will
automatically be inherited by the object
class
object class is the superclass of any
class created in java
and if you look at this documentation
and if you come here you will see that
object class
defines this equals method which
indicates whether some
other object is equal to this one or not
and it also
defines a hash code method which returns
a hash code value for the object
so let's understand both of them one by
one
first of all let's establish that this
these methods have their concrete
implementations
available inside the object class
but how do you do that and how do we how
does it come into effect
remember when we talked about hash set
and i said that hashtag will maintain
uniqueness automatically
how does it maintain uniqueness
automatically
it is because of the equals method
implementation which it inherits from
the object class
that's how it maintains uniqueness
and if you remember i also told that
you can do
you you can maintain uniqueness in a
hash set if it's a built-in data type
like integer or string or float or
double etc
but what if you are trying to create a
hash set of student objects
then java does not know how to perform
equality on two student objects because
student is a custom object java doesn't
know how to run equality and that's
where equals and hash code comes into
picture
so the contract is that whenever you are
creating your own custom objects and you
have a need
to perform equality on those objects you
must override the equals method in your
own class
you have to override that if you do not
override that then two student objects
will be compared based on the reference
and not based on the actual object
values we will see all of that with the
help of an example
another thing which says that whenever
you are overriding equals
you should also override hashcode method
reason is because hashcode is also used
in certain collections and we will cover
that in a while but let's just focus on
equals first
and let me switch back to the eclipse
ide
where i have a student class
again it's a very familiar class which
we have covered in other lectures as
well
and i have three different properties
here role number name and address
i have a constructor and i have setters
and getters
now if i go here and i create three
different
objects of the student class
you see i have created three different
objects
this student object has a role number
one named john and the address is the
same one
second object has a role number two
and the name john
and the address is the same as this one
and third one again has a different role
number but the name and address is the
same it's a hypothetical situation
so let's do one thing let's make this
roll number as one as well so now these
two student objects are exactly
identical
so what happens if i compare john with
john 2
by looking at naked eyes these two
objects look exactly the same so john
equals john 2 should return true
let's run this program
but we get false
the reason we get false is because the
default implementation of equals is
being run
on the on comparing the student objects
because java still does not know how to
equate these two objects why you are
getting false because these two are
different references java created a new
memory location somewhere and put this
object created a reference drawn to it
then java created one more new object in
this line
and create a new reference john 2 so
these two
different references are pointing to two
different memory locations of the
objects though their internal values are
same but their memory locations are
different
that's why you get this particular value
as false because these are pointing to
two different memory locations and that
brings me to the hash code contract
you need to
override the hash code contract as well
along with the equals to make sure that
your equality runs perfectly
let's go back to the student class and
let's fix this problem because we can
see that these are identical objects you
don't want to store the same student
twice in your database right
so you need to fix this so i go back to
the student.java
and i have commented this equals method
and let me uncomment this now
so what i do that i override
the equals method
and the equals method contract looks
like this where you supply an object
which is an which is a foreign object
and now you need to compare this foreign
object with your current object of the
student class which is this
so at first you need to run this
particular condition which says are
these two objects
these two references that this reference
and the obj reference
pointing to the same object
if they are pointing to the same object
then
this will return true and then we will
say that the object is that that
equality holds true because both are
pointing to the same object so obj
equals this
if that doesn't hold true if this
doesn't hold true then it moves on to
line 50 and it runs a condition saying
that
is obj null or obj.get class is not
equal to this dot get class
get class is a method which will tell
you the class type
here we are checking is the obj class
object is of the type student or not
if it's of different type let's say
vehicle or something then then
definitely they will not be equal
and we can directly return false so
that's why i am checking that it should
not be null
or
the class types should be matching
if these two conditions are if either of
these conditions are holding true then i
return false and i say that objects are
not equal
so covered this condition where both of
the references are pointing to the same
object i covered this condition where
the class types were not matching or the
obj itself was null then all then we
returned false
if we passed all of these sanity checks
then we do the actual comparison
before doing the actual comparison i
need to do this explicit casting so i
cast the obj object into the student
type if you remember that's it this is
how we did this this the casting for
other data types as well
once you have converted this obj into
the student object
then you need to define your own
business logic based on which you are
going to define uniqueness
so how are you going to uniquely
identify
a student in your application will
govern this logic
in this particular example i'm saying
that i am going to identify a unique
student based on its role number
so even if two students have exact same
matching details but if their role
numbers are different then these are two
different objects for me but if two
objects have are having the same role
number and even if they have a different
name and address i am going to say that
those two objects are duplicate so roll
number is the is the condition on which
i'm defining
uniqueness equality and duplicity
so i define this and say if the roll
numbers are equal then the object is
equal objects are same basically or
duplicate and if the roll numbers are
different then these two are different
objects
good so far coming back to the main
class
so now i have the same roll number here
let me change the name just for fun and
address as well
so i have a different name and a
different address but the roll number is
exactly the same
remember we have defined the equality
condition based on the roll number and
here we are comparing if john is equal
to john 2 or not
so let's run this program
now i get true the reason i get true is
because this equals method is is used
to run this equals comparison
so this establishes how we can use the
equals contract to maintain uniqueness
now i also said that whenever you have
you are defining the equals method you
also have to override the hashcode
method
and to understand why do we need
hashcode as well let's go back to how
hashmap works
remember in the hashmap or let's say
even hash set in the hash set you have
to maintain uniqueness now java
maintains uniqueness using both equals
and hash code
hashcode is nothing but a memory bucket
in the in java's memory where your
object is stored it's basically a memory
location
so every object has a hash code and that
hash code is the actual memory footprint
where the object is stored
and whenever you're dealing with hash
set or hash maps you will be required to
overwrite both of these methods
let's understand how this works
so if you have a hash set and you are
trying to insert an element then first
java will use your equals method
definition to check if an object similar
to the object being inserted is already
present in the hash set or not
if it finds an object it will basically
flag that this is a duplicate object and
it will not insert it
let's understand how an object is
fetched from hash set
let me open a hashtag example
just to
give you some sort of a visual
representation of what i'm talking about
so if i go to my hash set example in
in the collections package somewhere
and let's open a hash set demo class
yeah
so when we were doing these insertions
though this is this was a string object
so it was the java already knew how to
use the equals and hash code of it but
if it was a student object and you were
doing multiple
ad and then when you were actually
fetching the element or you were doing
that contains
then how does it work is basically
first it is going to calculate the hash
code of the object let's say you are
saying hashtag dot get
b or hashtag dot get john 1
then it is going to calculate the hash
code
of your john one object
hashcode is a memory footprint and
hashcode and the way it is going to
calculate the hashcode is going to be
based on the definition which you have
provided
so the definition which you have
provided this hash code will be run to
calculate the memory footprint
and then that particular memory for java
will go to that particular memory
footprint and see
if there is an object present there or
not
now java has a memory location right and
there can be multiple objects stored at
that particular memory location this is
possible in java so if there are
multiple objects present in that
particular memory location which was
calculated based on the your hash code
implementation
then java is going to run the equals
method to find the exact matching object
so just to try to visualize this if i
try to visualize this let's say you have
this memory locations
and let's say your hash code came up to
memory location 2
and then at 2 memory location
you had multiple objects obj 1
obj2
obj3 etc this is possible
multiple objects can point to the same
memory location so if this happens then
java is going to use the equals contract
to compare your john 1 object with obj 1
with obj 2 and with obj3
this is where the equals will come into
use so you see the both hash code and
equals are being used here to
point to the right memory location and
that's why i said that hash set and hash
maps are where equals and hash code will
come in full force where you will be
required to implement this and it's a
good practice to always override the
equals and hash code in your application
whenever you are creating classes the
reason is that you don't know when and
where these classes will be stored into
a hashtag collection or a hashmap
collection so it's always a good idea to
have equals and hashcode being
implemented and when you implement
hashcode the rule the thumb rule is that
you should use the same parameters which
have been used in the equals contract
in the hash code contract as well
the reason for that is what if you used
here let's say you use name here and you
use roll number here then two different
properties are being used to
find memory location and uni and the
uniqueness
and remember this logic which i just
gave you here both hash code and equals
are working together to find the right
object so if you are go if you make any
mistakes in defining the equals and hash
code or if you made any mistake in
defining the symmetry between equals and
hash code then you may get unpredictable
results
how you define your hash code
up to you but make sure to use the same
properties
which you have used to define the
equality always keep this consistent to
avoid any unexpected results
you can also do this just say return one
and every and what happens what will
happen that when you use this particular
student class in a hash set all the
objects are going to be stored at a
single memory location and then this
particular situation will occur where
you will have a single memory location
and all of your objects will be present
at that memory location and when you are
trying to fetch anything
the hash code will always point to the
same memory location and then equals
will make sure to find out the right
object you are trying to fetch from the
hash set
so this is all about equals and hash
code which i wanted to cover in this
particular lecture
do read about this in detail there are
tons of article available on this
particular concept because this is a
very important and popular concept
both from implementation perspective and
from interview perspective let's get
started with comparable in java and
before we go there let's understand why
do we need comparable the need for
comparable comes from the requirement
whenever you have to sort your
collections
so to understand that let's move over to
the java docs to understand how this
works
so the basic idea is that you want to
sort your collection
and to do that java provides you with a
method called collections.sort
you just provide you just supply your
list or your collection inside the sort
method and all the elements or objects
inside your collection will be sorted
based on the natural sorted ordering
this holds true for built-in data types
but what if your list is of type student
objects then again the same constraint
applies that java does not know how to
sort student objects it knows how to
sort strings and hints and floats and
doubles because those are built-in data
types but student is a custom type and
java doesn't know how to sort it and to
solve that problem java provides an
interface
called comparable
so comparable is the interface which you
need to
implement
from your class
whenever you have a need
to sort your objects or of your class
type
so this is the interface which your
class needs to implement this interface
provides a single method which says
compare to
and it provides the foreign object and
then you need to compare this foreign
object with your
current object
so let's go back to the java class and
understand how do we work with this
comparable interface
so again i have used the student class
for the sake of continuity and i have
the same properties as role number name
and age but this time i say implements
comparable of type student this is a
generics type we are we will be covering
generics in a bit more detail in this
whole in this whole series but the basic
idea is that you define that this
comparable interface will only work for
student types you define the type in
this particular construct which we also
call a generic type
so you do this and the moment you do
this java will force you to provide the
implementation of the comparative method
which i have provided here
so the way this
implementation works is you have a
foreign object here but this time this
foreign object since i have defined this
as of type student so if you the moment
you do this
java will ask you to override this
method and using eclipse ide if you
overwrite this
then you will get this signature
automatically let me show you this how
this works
so if you do this you will get an error
here and if you click on this balloon it
will say add unimplemented methods if
you double click on this
you will see a comparative
implementation here
and this is exactly the skeleton which
you see here by default it says return 0
but i'll just come back to that in a
while
so this is how this method came up here
and once you have this signature
available then you need to provide your
implementation on how do you want to
sort the objects
remember you need to define your your
logic here so again i would like to sort
my students based on the role number
which is the natural sorting order for
me for the student objects so this is
your custom
sorting logic which you which you can
call as natural custom logic sorting
order for your student objects so i want
to sort them based on roll number but
you see i've done a strange thing here
i've done a minus here so what i'm doing
is that the current objects roll number
minus the foreign object's
roll number
so if this value
comes as a positive number then this
this object is going to take priority
this is going to be
sitting before the student
if this result returns in a negative
value then this object will come first
and
this will come second so the student
object will come first and this object
the current object will come second
and if this returns zero then it means
both of the objects deserve the same
priority or the same order priority and
any one of them can come after the other
so the basic idea is that if this if
this results in greater than zero then
the current object
is going to take precedence
if this is going to return in a negative
value then the foreign object which you
are supplying here is going to take
precedence and if this returns in zero
then any one of them can take precedence
so you need to define your compare to
logic in the compared to override
implementation
once you have done that let's understand
this with the help of an example i have
created a comparable demo class which
has a public static void main method and
i create an error list and i create
three different student objects
first student object is named as john
second is jane and third is tom the
first has a roll number of three
so john has a three roll number of three
jane has a roll number of one
and tom has a roll number of two
so if my compared to logic runs
perfectly then jane should be coming
first after after i sort this collection
after i add these three elements into my
list and once i sort this collection
then jane should come first
tom should come second and john should
come third
based on my natural ordering ordering
custom logic which i have implemented in
the compare to method
and that's what i'm doing here
after i've sorted the list i'm just
printing the list
by using the for each construct of the
streams api
i'm just printing the name to see which
one comes first and which one comes
second
so let's run this program
and this is how it looks like so jane
comes first
because she had a roll number one
don tom came second because he had a
roll number two
and john came third because his roll
number was three
so no matter how many times you run this
program you are going to get the
collection in the same sorted sequence
and this is happening because of the
compared to implementation which you
provided here
now
if you comment this implementation
let's see what happens and i remove this
implements comparable as well from here
i just create a simple student class and
now i try to run the sort
now you see that you get an error here
and if you hover over this balloon it
says that the method sort in the type
collection is not applicable to the
argument array list of student
java does not know how to sort this so
it will force you to provide a sorted
implementation
and the moment you provide comparable
implementation here
and if you go back to the main class the
error is gone
so this also will force you to provide
your comparable implementation
now you can use this sorting for any
kind of collection sorting as well and
whenever you are doing this always make
sure to provide the compare to
implementation and remember that
contract which i gave you about greater
than 0 less than 0 and equal let's get
started with working through a core java
project
using all the different oops concept we
have learned so far
so in this example
we are going to have a look at a
calculator application and this
calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction
multiplication
and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open the
main class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user so
we initialize the scanner class and we
start taking the inputs and whatever the
user inputs in terms of the expression
let's say the user entered 4 plus 5 or
whatever that whole expression gets sent
back into this
input line
as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say
let's say the user entered this
expression so this has either numbers
or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the
numbers and operators into two different
string arrays
and here i'm providing the split
expression that split at every time you
encounter one of these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4 5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i've created the string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i'm going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this linked list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this linked list as a
queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now
and then i am using the poll method if
you remember the pole method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the whole
method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable
and after that i run a loop on the
numbers q
and i'm going to run this uh particular
loop till this particular queue
is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do this exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it so
in this case plus will be picked up and
will be stored in this variable called
opr
and then i'm going to run a switch case
on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application we are
supporting four operations which are
addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors
for multiplication i have a class called
multiply and for division i have a class
called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a var arg array this is
called a where arc expression this means
that this numbers will be an array of
arbitrary length it can be a one element
array it can be a two element array it
can be a four element array or whatever
you supply
but it is still going to be a fixed
length array but the length is going to
be dependent upon how much argument you
supply to this particular method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it just has one method declared
which is called get result which is
accepting an array of numbers so
if the add class is implementing the
operate interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and
the exact same kind of logic or similar
logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class
it is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one
so it's doing pretty much the same thing
in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning
the object type to this interface
reference
so i'm using the concept of dynamic
binding which we talked about when we
talked about interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can assign an object
to an interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue remember we
already did one poll here
so as for this example 4 was here in
this rest
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue
so we pick up 5 here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression which was encountered
first in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operator type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum 4 and five this
rest is holding four right now
based on what i described here
numbers.poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically
basically five here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number q is
now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have 3 n2
left there so
again it does the operations dot poll
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll
and this time the numbers dot poll is
going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9
4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate dot get result the
multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3
which will become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls
the queue of the operations
where the expression divide is present
there which is the only element left in
this particular operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers.poll now
the last number which is available in
this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate dot get
result this time since the operate
object refer object operator reference
type was of divide class type
so when we call operate.getresult
the divide operation or the getresult
method of the divide class basically
this method
will get invoked
and
it will
divide the current value of result which
was
4 plus 5
9 into 3 which was 27
so it is going to divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers dot poll it is going to execute
27 by 2 and whatever value it gets it is
going to store a value back into the
rest variable and then it is again going
to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers q is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now let's try to see this in action and
we'll try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
star
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step we
pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator and
whatever kind of operator we have
we initialize the corresponding class of
it
and then
we
fetch the next
value in the numbers q and then we call
the get result based on the expression
and whatever result we get from the get
result we store it back into the rest
variable so we keep updating the rest
variable at every step so that's the
reason the result of 4 plus 5 gets
stored in the rest and next time you are
calling the get result for a multiply
operation here the rest value is 9 now
and it says 9 into 3 again in the next
time the rest value will be updated to
27 because we are storing the result
back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error-free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts let's get started
with enums or enumerations or enumerated
types in java so before we go into enums
let's understand why we need it
when you are building when you will be
building the java applications you will
face scenarios where you will have to
define some variables which will remain
constant forever for example months of
the year they are not going to change
they are always going to be 12 months in
an year
similarly let's say name of flowers
they're not going to change a lotus will
be a lotus forever similarly the name of
the seasons will always remain same the
season of summer or winter will always
be called summer or winter they will not
be changed the meaning of those
variables will never be overwritten or
will never be changed so you can think
of them as constants but they are not
the constants which your programs may
mutate or your programs may interpret
differently they will be interpreted by
multiple applications multiple
components multiple consumers in exactly
the same way similarly if you take the
example of time zones they are fixed
they work with the gmt with respect to
the gmt time zone and they will always
remain like that
so if you have if you whenever you have
a situation where you have to define
such constructs or such constants
always think of enum types or numerated
types enum is basically a language
construct and you can use this language
construct to define type safe variables
when we say type safe variables what we
mean is that these variables
are not integer or string they are of
enum types that's the reason java
created a completely new data type which
is called the enum type
they are by default constant so you
cannot change them that's their property
and the way you define enums is like
this
you say public enum so instead of the
keyword class you use the keyword enum
and then you define the name of the enum
the name of the enum type and then you
define the possible values just simply
separating them by a comma
so for example days of the week is again
a constant thing there will always be
seven days of the week irrespective of
what you do on this planet
so that's why you can declare an enum
for the day and you can define those as
as the values
you also notice that the values are caps
by default and yes that is how you
define the enums
let's have a look at a more interesting
example of the enums in the ide now so
if i switch to the ide
i have created a class called color not
a class but an enum type called color
and this enum type color is basically
holding all the different color types
their values basically like all the vip
gear colors for example
so i've defined three colors here which
are red green and blue
so you see i've defined them as caps
they automatically become bold you don't
have to bold them
but you see an interesting thing a
difference here that there is another
value in the brackets here this was not
there when we looked at this example of
day there is no value inside each of the
enum types but i have defined the value
of the enum types and that is optional
there will be use cases where you want
to define some enum constants where the
name of the enum type is a constant
which is a placeholder but it will have
an internal value which may be more
practical for your application so this
is what your consumers see and this is
what
is used whenever you call red inside
your application is just for simplicity
they would be they might be use cases
where you use some abbreviations and
their full forms for example if you want
to use here an abbreviation of let's say
wh o
and inside this you can define the value
as
world
health
organization so this is just a toy
example i'm giving you where you will
have use cases where you want to define
a constant but you want to define an
internal value of it which is to be read
by your application elsewhere but
everybody who wants to consume this enum
can just use this particular keyword and
if they want to get the value they can
get the value as well
so this is the use case where you might
need to define values of your enum types
as well but whenever you have to do that
if you want to fetch the value of an
enum type you have to write some extra
code which is written here if you were
not defining the value of your enum
types your enum can be as simple as this
you don't need to define anything else
apart from just defining the constant of
the enum types
i'm giving a more complex use case so
that it covers both of the things of
using just the constants and also using
the values so if you just want to read
the constant you can just say color dot
red or color.green or color.blue in
different classes and you will be able
to refer to the enum types or use the
enum types
but if you want to refer to the value of
the enum type then probably you need to
call this method called getvalue so
whenever you define a value what you
would do is you will define a private
member variable inside the enum which is
defined here you can name it anything if
you want
you define a constructor where you set
this particular value and then you
define a getter so whenever some
consumer application wants to refer to
the value of your enum type they can
call this getvalue method to get that so
this is the enum now let's see how we
can use this genome for using this enum
i have this main class where i have a
public static void main method and you
can simply fetch the enum types by
writing the code like this just write
the enum type holder and then type the
enum type so let me show you how this is
done if you just put a dot here you will
get all the enum type options so i've
defined three enum types red green and
blue and i get all the options so
whatever option i want to choose i can
just select here and i can store this
inside an enum variable
so if you want to just refer to the name
of the enum so this c1 is holding color
dot red or red so if you want to refer
to this just this red then you can call
the dot name method on the c1 variable
so if you say c1.name
it is going to put or print the red in
caps
and if you want to fetch the value
inside the red remember the value is
read in in small caps so if you want to
refer to the or if you want to fetch the
value of the red then you call the get
value method which we have defined here
so that's what we are doing here in this
first two sys outs where we are printing
the red enum name and then printing the
redinum value
now you can also iterate over all the
enum types
and for that you need to call the dot
values method on the enum so you can
just say color.values which is going to
iterate over all the enum types
and you are just storing each of the
enum type in this color placeholder then
you can either call getvalue to get the
actual value of that enum type or you
can call the name to just print the name
of the enum as well both of the options
are available so let's just put it back
to get value and let's run this code so
if i run this application i get some
output here which looks like this
first sis out says red enum name is red
in caps because we are calling the name
method
second says red enum value which prints
red in small because we are calling the
getvalue method and then we are
iterating over all the enums so i had
three enum variables here red green and
blue
and i'm going to iterate over all of
them one by one here printing their
value and not the enum constants
so that's why you see the red green and
blue here in small but if you just want
to print the enum constants themselves
and not their values then you change
this to dot name and then all the enum
constants will be printed here
so this is how you can create enums and
use enums for the constants which are
never going to change in your
application let's get started with
annotations in java now annotations is a
bit advanced concept so let's understand
why we need it there would be some cases
in your pro in your application where
you need to provide some metadata
information to the java compiler now
this sounds a bit complicated but it's
much simpler than that because you might
not want to code everything with lot of
lines of code rather you want to give
some smart instructions to the java
compiler so that they understand what to
do we have already seen some of the
annotations but the basic idea of
annotations is to provide some shorthand
metadata information about the program
to the java compiler generally
annotations will not have any direct
effect on the operation of the code they
annotate but they provide additional
logic to the code that's the idea with
the annotation remember they are
shorthand metadata the main use is
providing information to the compiler or
providing some compile time or
deployment time processing or also
providing some instructions for runtime
processing we have already seen some of
the annotations if you remember when we
were dealing with inheritance we had
this add the rate override over the
methods right this add the rate override
is an annotation this annotation if you
if i if i show you what i'm talking
about if i take you back to one of the
inheritance example or the method
overriding examples and if i open the
mountain bike class here mountain bike
extends bicycle you will see this
override annotation this is an
annotation an annotation always starts
with at the rate in java and the
annotation name is overwrite now this
override is just a shorthand to tell the
compiler that hey i am overriding this
method from the base class that's what
this annotation does if you remove the
annotation in some cases the java
compiler might not understand what to do
and the java compiler has to do some
extra processing to figure out that this
method is actually being overridden but
if you put this at override here then
the java compiler pre-hand will know
that this is coming from the base class
so you save some of the compiler
processing time as well by using the
annotation it's a shorthand providing
instructions to the compiler you see
exactly what i'm talking about so this
is one of the annotations which we have
used but we will look at some of the
other more generic annotations and we
will also see how we can build our own
custom annotation in java you might have
also seen some other annotations like
for example you can put aggregate
suppressor warning annotation which is a
very popular annotation to suppress any
kind of yellow warnings in your code
generally we do not recommend doing that
but if you have a use case then you can
use a direct suppress annotation as well
there are some other annotations as well
like advocate author if you want to put
your name as the author of a particular
piece of code then you can add this
metadata so that whenever somebody looks
at even the documentation of your code
your name will be shown there as the
author so that's the idea with
annotations so let's see how you can
build your own custom annotation
whenever you have to do that there are
multiple ways to doing that and the
first type of annotation we are going to
have a look at is called marker
annotation a marker annotation is just
an empty annotation without having any
metadata logic at all you can see it is
i have defined an annotation here i will
talk about what is all this means but
inside the block there is no code here
and this is how you define a marker
annotation marker annotation is just to
provide very high level instructions to
the compiler and the way you will write
your custom annotation is you will put
an access modifier keyword like public
then you will write add the rate
interface this is the keyword which you
have to use whenever you are trying to
create your custom annotation marker or
no marker doesn't matter whenever you
define your annotation you have to use
add grade interface once you do that
then you provide a name for your
annotation which can be anything but
still not complete you need to also
provide more instructions to the
compiler or the runtime processor to
tell them when to execute this
annotation and what the annotation type
is going to be applied upon so at first
you specify when this annotation is
going to be active or executed or
evaluated so here you can say add the
rate retention which is another
annotation so you say add direct
retention and then you say retention
policy dot whatever you want to write as
you can write it as runtime or you can
write it as source if you write it as
source then it is going to be applied at
compile time and if you select it as
runtime then the annotation is going to
be processed at runtime so this is the
first thing which you need to provide
the second thing which you need to
provide is where this annotation is
going to be applied whether you want
this annotation to be applied to a class
or to a method or to a member variable
or to any other type and that's what you
define in the add the rate target
annotation you specify the target
audience for this particular annotation
and here inside the element type you
will get multiple options you can apply
this annotation to a constructor to a
field local variable method module
package record component type etc so
here i'm going to use type which means
it can be applied to a class or a
generic element type which generally
means class type and that's all you can
define your marker annotation like this
but generally these marker annotations
does not have any logic so you will not
get much value out of it until you have
very special cases but if you have a
case where you want to also run some
business logic or provide some metadata
logic to the compiler while defining the
annotation then you can define the
annotation like this so i've created one
more annotation here which is called
which is called my custom annotation
again the target audience for this is
method so this annotation can only and
only be applied to methods if you try to
apply this annotation to a class you
will get an error the retention policy
is run time it means it is going to be
processed at runtime and have declared a
method here which is called hint value
so this is how you will declare your
annotation now let's see how do you how
do you use this annotation so i have a
class called as my class here and if you
look at this structure of the my class
we create the class and then i create a
method which is named as say hello and i
am applying this annotation on this
particular method remember the target
audience of this particular annotation
was method so it only be applied a
method if i try to put this on the class
type here then i get an error here it
says the annotation my custom annotation
is disallowed at this location because
the type specified is of type method so
the compiler will not allow you to use
this at an illegal place so you write
any method and you apply your annotation
but you provide a value to the method
the int value method is going to consume
this value and inside the method you can
write any other logic so let's see how
this pans out i create a public static
void method and i create an object of my
class so my class h equal to new my
class and after that i'm saying h dot
get class dot get method i'm basically
calling the method by using reflection
api you can also call the method
directly if you want but this is how you
need to call it if you want to use the
annotation property value if you want to
fetch the value of the annotation so
this is just an example of me showing
you how you fetch the annotation so we
created an object and then we say get
class which is going to return my class
type and then get method is going to
return the method type which has the
name say hello so this is a way to fetch
a method name or a method type from a
class using java's reflection api which
is an advanced api you might you might
not need to use it but for the sake of
demo i'm using this so we fetch the
class and we fetch the method it is
going to search the class for a method
name say hello if it finds the method it
is going to return the method in this
variable and then you can call method
val which was this variable dot get
annotation give me any annotation which
is applied on this particular method and
you supply the annotation class type as
well once you do that you get a my
custom annotation reference type and
then if you call the value method on
this you will get this value as 10. so
this is a way where you can apply an
annotation and you can actually see the
effect of the annotation you might not
always want to do this because like i
said these are metadata instructions to
the compiler but if you have a need to
actually see what your annotation is
doing you can use the getclass.get
method to first fetch the method store
it into a method type and then call get
annotation supplying the exact
annotation class type and then you can
call the exact method which is defined
in your annotation here i've defined it
as value so i'm just calling the value
method so if i run this particular
example i get the value as 10. so i'm
able to see or fetch the exact value
which my annotation metadata is holding
at the runtime and this is the power of
annotation they're a very powerful
concept and they're a very advanced
concept they would be very rare
scenarios in your application where you
need to create your custom annotations
generally you will be better off will
with your uh with your predefined
annotations which are provided in java
like at the rate override and direct
author at the rate of suppress warning
etc let's get started with serialization
in java now before we go further let's
understand why we need the concept of
serialization when you will be building
the enterprise grid applications in in
different organizations you will often
have a use case or a need to send an
object from one application to other
application which is deployed on some
other machine so if you have a network
of computers or if you have a lot of
different uh complex setup where you
need you have a producer application and
you have a consumer application producer
application produces the object and then
this object gets traveled over the
network lines over the network wires and
reaches at the consumer application and
how does the consumer application
receive the object and how does the
producer application sense the object
because when the data travels over the
network lines it will be all bytes so
how do you convert a java object into
bytes send it over network and then the
consumer application has to again
convert that bytes back to an object
representation and then store that or
use that inside its application so you
need to do this whole conversion right
so the process of converting an object
to a byte so that it can be sent over a
network is called serialization and the
process of converting back the byte from
the byte from the network to a java
object is called deserialization so
generally you you may have a use case
where you serialize an object create a
binary representation of it send it over
the network and that's where the java
serialization concept kicks in whenever
whenever you're using the serializable
interface so you need to extend your
objects from this serializable interface
so that those objects themselves becomes
serializable you need to tell java that
this object is able to serialize itself
and deserialize itself and the way you
will tell java is by letting that object
implementing the serializable interface
let's have a look at an example for of
this serialization and deserialization
to understand this concept better so
here again i've used the same student
class where it has the name age and
address so you can see i have created a
student class but the student class
implements serializable this is
something which you have to add to your
class
second thing the moment you do that all
the modern day ides like eclipse or
intellij will ask you to add a serial
version universal id to this particular
class this is added so that java can
uniquely identify your object once it is
serialized and deserialized and it will
also keep a versioning track of it right
because if somebody hops over the
network line and change the
representation of your object and the
consumer application will get a
completely different object copy now so
this is java's way to make sure that the
same version which the producer
application is producing is received by
the consumer application so it's also
sort of a security feature it basically
whenever you do an update on to the
object it is going to increment this
serial version uid by one so when you
create the object first time and you
serialize it for for the very first time
the value is going to be set as default
one and as you mutate the object again
and again before deserializing it the
count will just keep on increasing so
that's how you keep a track of the state
of the object which is being serialized
by adding this long serial version uid
you can also specify your own value if
you want to by default java initializes
a value of 1 and this is a long type
variable so that is the only new thing
which is happening the moment you do
implement serializable after that i have
the same fields here i have the
constructor and the setters and the
getters
and i also have a tostring method just
to print the object nicely where i print
the name
the age and the address
so let's look at a main class and where
we use the student object we serialize
this object and then we deserialize this
object so what is happening here is i
create a class i create the main method
and i create a student object this is
something which we have already seen
then i
want to store the state of this object
when when you serialize this object this
object has to be either sent to a
network but since i am running this demo
on the same machine what i will do that
i will serialize this object onto my
local file system it's the same thing
right you can put it somewhere and then
fetch it from there so either you can
send it over the network or you can put
it on a file system so i create the
object and then i need to store this
into a file so far i have not covered
the file handling operations so we will
not go deeper into the file handling
classes here but i will just explain you
the reasoning for it and when we'll do
the file handling session there i will
go in detail about the file handling
classes so i specify your file name
where the serialized representation of
my student object is going to be stored
and this is the location where i'm
supposed to store this then i create two
different classes which is for writing
to the file and then creating an object
for it so that's what i'm doing here we
can ignore this particular part where
i'm just supplying the file name and we
can focus on this part this line where
i'm saying write the object the student
object to this particular file that's
what i'm doing here in this particular
in this three lines of code that i'm
writing the student object to the file
so when java has to write this object to
the file it is automatically going to
serialize it that's the only way java
can write an object to the file so you
serialize the object and then you print
that message that the object has been
serialized again you can ignore this
part as well like i said we will not
focus on this but what we technically
did is we just wrote we just wrote the
object to a file by serializing it then
i try to deserialize it so i load the
file load this same file into the java
jvm and then i read the object and the
way i read the object is by using this
object input stream class i supply the
file that read this particular file and
then i call the read object method which
is going to return an object a general
object when you call the read object
method the read object method does not
know that it is a student type object so
you so you need to explicitly cast this
to the student type so that you can
store this as a student object
if you do not cast this you will get an
error because like i said read object
does not know anything about the student
class so what does what does this mean
is that when you serialize an object the
class type information is lost you
cannot store the class type information
when you serialize an object because the
moment you call this write object method
from the object output stream class so
you created this object output stream
class you supply the file output
location and you call the right object
the moment you call the right object
it's just any java object for the this
java program the signature of the
student class is lost it does not know
that it's a student class anymore once
it has been once it is being serialized
similarly when you deserialize it the
serialization api has no idea about what
student class is and what student object
is so you need to tell the read object
method explicitly that hey you are
reading an object of the student type
and that's how this line works once you
explicitly provide the casting operation
once you have casted it we try to print
the same deserialized object to see if
all the state which we stored in the
object is still persisted there or not
when we deserialize it so our major
focus in this particular class is this
object output stream classes and the
right object method these are the two
most important statements which you need
to take care of the file output stream
is basically a file location what is an
output stream we will talk about that
later but
whenever you need to serialize you need
to use this particular class called
object output stream so that's all i'm
doing here i'm serializing the object
with this these values and then i will
deserialize and i will again print the
object to see if these values are still
there or not so let's run this
application so when i run this
application let's start from here first
this says out gets called which says
object has been serialized so you see
object has been serialized and what i
serialized was the student object which
had the value of name as john
age as 25 and the address as 23 east
california and that's what gets printed
here then this whole block gets
completed this whole try block gets
completed it's a standard try catch
block you see i have also added the i o
exception you need to do that because
these file operations will force you to
catch or throw the io exception which is
a checked exception that's why it will
force you to do that then we move to the
deserialization block where we create an
object of the object input stream class
and then we call the read object we cast
it to the student type and then we print
the object so when i print this object
this line gets printed object has been
deserialized and then i can see that the
exact same state is still there the name
which is set in the object is still
there after being after being
deserialized the age and the address is
exactly intact so this is how we you can
serialize an object send it anywhere you
want and then the consumer application
need to read the object and cast it back
to the student type and they will be
able to see the exact same state which
you saved in the object
just before serializing it what if you
have a use case where you do you have a
property in up in a student class or in
your object but you do not want that to
be serialized that's also a use case
where you may have 50 different
properties inside the student class and
one of the properties something which
you do not want to serialize because you
do not want the consumer application to
see that value if you ever had that
scenario use the transient variable so
transient is again a keyword and the
moment you put this keyword in front of
a member variable that variable becomes
transient the use case of transient
variable is that if you do not want this
x to be serialized and deserialized then
you put the transient keyword in front
of it the normal member variables will
automatically get serialized and
deserialized when the object is
serialized and deserialized but if you
have a use case where you do not want a
particular member variable to be
serialized or deserialized put transient
in front of it and then have the getters
and setters for this x variable and
let's use this and see if this actually
gets serialized or not so i created the
student object and let me call
student dot
set x and let's put a value to x let's
say 10
so i have said the value of x is 10 and
x is our transient variable and then i
am serializing the whole object here and
then i'm deserializing the object and
let's see if i'm able to fetch the value
of x after d serializing the student
object so i'm calling the
system.out.println and
the
serialized
value of
x is
object
dot
get x
let's see if i'm able to see the value
of x or not so let's run this
application again
so
this is exactly the same as before this
is also exactly the same as before but i
see the value of x is 0. remember i set
the value as 10 before serializing it
but i don't see the value 10 anymore
when i deserialize the object because it
was transient if you remove transient
from it then you will be able to
transfer or travel this value of 10
between serialization and
deserialization so if i just remove this
here don't change anything at all and i
just rerun the application this time
when i deserialize the object the value
of x as 10 is still present there even
after deserialization so this is how you
can use the transient variables if you
want to not have that object serialized
or deserialized when you're doing the
serialization let's get started with
concurrency and threads the reason i
want to talk about concurrency because
once we understand about the concurrency
it will become much more simpler to talk
about threats and the idea behind
concurrency is very simple and plain and
that idea is that as a developer when
you write a program you would expect the
machine or the computer to run multiple
tasks in parallel for example right now
i'm recording this video on on a
particular laptop which is recording my
voice which is also recording the screen
which is also running the eclipse ide
and also running our chrome browser it
is also have it also have opened
multiple background applications so
there are a lot of tasks running in
parallel at the same time and that's the
idea about concurrency now how do we
work with concurrency in java is with
the help of processes and threads so
these are the two basic units of
execution when we talk about concurrent
programming in java and when we talk
about processes you can think of a
process as basically an execution
environment or i should call it as a
standalone execution environment think
of a logical box which is completely cut
out from everything and it has its own
environment for example again the
recording software is running it's in
its own execution environment and when
we talk about process
process generally has an everything or a
private set of all the runtime resources
it needs and the memory space it needs
now this another concept or another
construct which is very important is
threads so threads are also sometimes
called lightweight processes and
basically when we talk about threads
it's a thread also has an execution
environment but creating a new thread
requires lot less resources than
creating a new process and you can also
think of threads as a mini version of a
process because a process can have
multiple threads remember that statement
that a process can have multiple threads
threads always exist within a process
and whenever you start a process there
will be at least one thread attached to
it and each thread is basically a task
for example the voice recording can be a
process and inside that the mic
recording
expression or the mic recording or task
can be run by a particular thread let's
take another example that when you play
games let's say you are playing a racing
game so when you play the racing game
there are multiple things happening at
once you see the current speed of your
car or bike on the screen you also see
your leaderboard position what ranking
you have in the race currently you also
see some other kind of features like
players health or the car's health or
the fuel
consumption available and lots of other
stuff the graphics the motorcycle the
other comp other competitors bikes and
their speeds and their distance to you
as well so if you see all of these are
running our different threads there's a
different thread to show your current
speed there's a different thread to show
the current leaderboard position there's
a different thread to show the fuel
indicator etc everything is running in a
different thread so all of these threads
need to run at the same time in your
program for a complete immersive user
experience and that's what we mean when
we say multi-threading that we want
multiple threads to run at the same time
to create a better experience in the
application so that's the basically the
theoretical part of it please do read
about more about how threads work and
how processes work and there's a lot
more documentation available in the java
docs as well when we talk about threads
but i will keep the theoretical part to
this particular point and now we will
move to an
eclipse example to see how we can create
threads so with that let's move to the
eclipse ide and here i have a demo
prepared basically so what i have here
is a threading demo class which has a
public static void main method and it
has a simple for loop and inside the for
loop i see this strange code here where
i am initializing two threads and
starting them so that's all i'm doing
here but let's see how this thread 1 and
thread 2 class have been written and why
do i see two different ways of
initializing them let's go deeper into
this now so let's see how thread 1 can
be created so first of all you can
create a thread by just creating a
simple class but make sure that you
extend it with the pre-built thread
class this thread class is from coming
from java so from the jdk basically so
the moment you extend your normal class
from the thread class then you will have
to override the run method so if i show
you the thread class here this is the
thread class uh
implementation available inside the jdk
and this is the class which is getting
called when you are extending is from
the third class and this thread class
will ask you to override a run method
here the override annotation is missing
so let me just add this for better
understanding so you need to override
the run method and this is something
which you need to do so that you can
specify what happens when you run the
thread so this run method will be called
whenever the thread is running at this
particular point i would also like to
tell you that there are different states
in the thread so there is a thread which
says thread is ready then there is a
state which is which say thread is
running there is also a state where the
thread is waiting for an i o input from
the user from the console or the command
line there can also be a state which
says dead where the thread has completed
its task and it's not working there can
also be a state which is called sleep
state where the thread is paused so
there are different states of the thread
and in this example we are going to
focus primarily on three states which is
the ready state and the running state
and the completed state so when you call
the run method the thread state is going
to change to running and whatever code
you write inside this particular run
method will be the logic which this
particular thread is supposed to execute
here i'm just putting a dummy logic
where i'm just
printing a cis out but definitely if you
try to create your threads this will
contain your actual business logic for
example that fuel indicator code or for
the leaderboard position code will go
inside this run method and then i'm
catching an exception if there's an
exception but obviously there will not
be an exception coming in because i have
nothing here literally so that's what we
are we are doing when we are creating
this thread one class and let's come
back to the threading demo now so to
initialize a thread or initialize might
not be right word to run a thread the
first thing which you need to do is to
initialize the class containing the run
method so i would avoid calling this
class as thread because technically this
is just a class so you initial so you
basically create an object of the thread
just like you create the object of any
other class there is nothing new here
right so we just say new thread 1 and
then we call t1 dot start now if you
observe carefully there is no start
method here we just had a run method but
this code is still compiling fine and
i'm calling the start method here
because the start method is the internal
method of the thread class which in turn
is going to call the run method so you
are never going to invoke the run method
directly you just need to start the
thread which is going to change the
state of the thread from ready to
running so this start method has the
responsibility of changing the state to
running and the way the start method is
going to do that is by calling the run
method internally inside the jdk itself
from developer perspective you just need
to call the start method and that's it
the thread will start running and
whatever is present in the run method
will get executed so that's the way to
start the thread second thing i have one
more thread created here which is the
thread 2 class so
in this case when i create a thread 2
class i'm not extending it from the
thread class rather i'm implementing the
runnable interface here so this is a
different interface available which is a
functional interface which means it will
have just one method which is the run
method but the interesting thing is that
here when i created thread one i said
extends thread but here when i'm
creating the second thread i am not
using extends thread but i am using
implements runnable let's understand why
do we do that first of all the reason
java provides two different ways of
creating threads is because there might
be a use case that you need to extend
your thread to class from some of your
custom java class remember java does not
support multiple inheritance so at a
time you can only extend this class from
one class so what if there was no
runnable interface and you need to
extend this thread to from student class
let's say so you need to do class thread
to extends
student for example the student is not
present here but let's assume it is so
you do this and then you also have to
extend it from thread now java doesn't
support multiple inheritance and this
will not work so what would you do if
you have to also create it as a thread
but also extend it from some of your
parent class you will not be able to do
that and that's the reason java provides
the implements runnable because then you
can extend it from any of your super
class of your interest and at the same
time also implement implement it with
runnable interface so that you can treat
this class as a thread so that's the
reason java provides two different ways
of creating threads remember that it's a
very important concept and once you
implement runnable again it will ask you
to override the run method so i will
just put override annotation here so
once you overwrite the run method again
you can write whatever logic you want
this particular thread to execute inside
the run block coming back to the main
class so
when you are extending from thread the
initialize and initialization is very
simple where you create the object and
you call the start method on the object
but if you are creating a thread by
implementing the runnable interface the
initialization of the thread is a bit
different and it's different in this
particular part on the left hand side
you still say thread t2 remember you are
saying thread and not thread 2. this is
a this is the java thread class this is
the jdk thread class not your own thread
class so you say thread t2 then you say
new thread and inside the new thread you
provide your own class type thread 2 was
your own class type so you specified
your own custom thread class here inside
the new thread constructor this thread
class is the jdk class if you click on
this you will see this is from the jdk
class so that's the difference extending
thread simple initialization
implementing runnable interface do the
initialization like this and after that
you call the similarly the start method
which is in turn going to call the run
method so that was how you create
threads differently and now let's run
this program to understand how the
output looks like when we run these
threads in loops remember i'm
initializing 10 instances of each of
these threads so in total there would be
20 output lines
so if i go to run as java application i
see this output here so let's observe
this output for once so thread 1 thread
2 is running in sequence in the first
time but then you see thread one is
running twice and then thread two is
running twice then again you see a good
sequence but again thread two has run
twice here again thread one has run
twice if i go further down thread one
runs once then again thread two runs
twice thread one runs once thread two
runs once so there is no particular
order here though based on the code
which we have written we should expect
thread one is running from here and then
thread two is running output from here
in a sequential fashion but we don't see
the sequential fashion here and this is
the power of concurrency this is because
threads never run in sequence they run
in parallel and which thread will
execute first you can't really predict
that so it's so be very careful when you
whenever you're writing multi-threading
code because you cannot predict the
sequence of execution because threads
are going to run whenever they find the
idle cpu so the key is the idle cpu
whenever a thread finds an idle cpu it
is going to occupy that cpu and going to
run its own execution and the moment its
execution finishes the other thread will
jump in and take up and take a piece of
the cpu so whichever thread gets the
idle piece of the cpu is going to
execute and that is the reason you see
this randomized output the next time
you're going to run you will see a
different random order so so this time
you see thread one ran four times you
did not see this in the previous
execution if you run it again you will
see again a different output this time
the thread one run thrice so every time
you will run this you will see a
different sequence there is no guarantee
of order because the threads are running
in parallel and they're running whenever
they get the idle cpu that's the bottom
line so this is how we are going to
create threads and remember you cannot
guarantee the sequence of the execution
so write your code accordingly and use
the threads for independently running
parallel threads which do not depend
upon each other let's get started with
thread synchronization in java so in the
previous example we saw that when we
execute threads then we can't guarantee
the sequence but it's actually
technically not a problem in the example
which we had look at before but it can
become a bigger problem when two threads
are trying to access the same object
remember object has properties and state
so what if the first thread modified the
object state and the second thread is
reading the state of the object the
second thread is expecting the original
state but while it was trying to read it
the other thread modified its state so
you can see this become a this can
become a big problem for example if you
are working with a banking system and if
there are two persons accessing the same
account at the same time one is
depositing the money and one is
withdrawing the money from the account
and if the total balance is thousand and
if both of them deposit 500 and withdraw
500 at the same time then who sees what
and if these are two if these are
handled by two different threads then we
can't guarantee if somebody sees a 1500
as the total sum or somebody sees a 500
as a total sum or there can be a
scenario where somebody sees zero as the
total sum so it there so the application
can turn into really weird scenarios if
two threads are trying to change the
state of a particular object at the same
time and java provides a solution of it
with the concept of intrinsic locks and
synchronizations so the idea is that
when a thread tries to work on a
particular object it basically takes a
lock on that particular object we also
call this as an intrinsic lock or
monitor lock so it takes a lock on the
object and it means that that particular
object becomes completely inaccessible
to other threads in the system at that
particular time so the moment you put
synchronization or you put lock on a
particular object only the thread which
has taken the lock will be able to
access the object and other threads will
be forbidden from accessing the object
so that's the idea behind intrinsic
locks and synchronization so that was
about the brief theory of it now let's
have a look at a practical example so i
have prepared another example for it so
here i have again created two threads
but these two threads it's the pretty
much the same threads which we covered
in the previous
session named as thread one and thread
two one is extending thread class and
other is implementing runnable but
that's the that's same but the
interesting part is this
both of them have a reference to a class
called mathutils if you see thread1 also
has the reference and thread 2 also has
the reference and what the math utils is
doing here is basically you supply a
number and it prints the multiples of it
till five so for example if you supply
two you will get the output two four six
eight ten if you supply three you will
get the multiple of three up to three
times 5 so 3 6 9 12 15. if you supply 4
you will get the outputs of the in the
multiples of 4 till 20. so whatever
number you will supply you will get the
next 5 multiples of that particular
number that's what this class is doing
and another thing which interesting
thing which i've done here is this
thread.sleep which means that when you
run this loop where you are printing the
multiples till five of that number every
time you do the first multiplication
then you sleep for 400 millisecond and
when i say sleep it basically means the
current thread is going to pause its
execution for 400 millisecond and it is
going to leave the cpu idle and if there
is another thread running currently in
the system that thread will get the
share of the cpu for that 400
millisecond and once the 400
milliseconds is finished the thread is
going to wake up and it is again going
to hunt for the idle cpu to pick up and
start doing its execution so that thread
dot sleep happens for 400 milliseconds
at every step of this iteration in this
for loop so thread one is going to use
this particular method of this
particular class and it is going to ask
the class to print the multiples of 2
and thread 2 is also going to access the
reference of the class and access the
get multiples method but this thread
asks to print the multiple of 3. so
thread 1 asks for printing the multiples
of 2 up to 2 times 5 and thread 2 wants
to print the output to multiple sub 3 up
to 3 times 5. so that's the basic
scenario two threads accessing the same
object supplying different values and
expecting the output so if i run this
demo as is without any change here i'm
just initializing the math utils class
initializing two threads and then
calling the start only once so if i run
this particular program i see get i see
this range output that even when i said
t1 dot start first so t1 was holding the
multiple of 2 remember but i still get 3
first then 2 then 4 6 so multiples of 2
gets executed here but then the other
thread takes the cpu and it starts
running its own multiples outputs and
you see 9 printing first and then 6 gets
printed then 12 then 8 then 15 and then
10 at very last so the output looks very
random it would have been nicer if i
could have seen two four six at ten once
and then three six nine twelve fifteen
once if i see them in different sections
in different sequences that would have
been so nice because then i know which
thread is running when and when that
particular thread is working on the
object so i'm just trying to replicate
the same scenario where two threads are
accessing the same object at the same
time but they are executing the object
randomly they are changing the state of
the object randomly here so how do we
fix this to fix this we can put so we
have this get multiples method which is
the bone of contention here this is the
method which is being randomly accessed
so what i can do here that i can put
synchronized keyword in front of the
method so once you put the synchronized
keyword in front of the method which is
being accessed by multiple threads at
the same time this method this whole
method gets synchronized now what this
means that one thread will be execute
this method at once there will never be
a scenario where two threads are
simultaneously executing this get
multiples method or even getting a hold
of this get multiples method at the same
time there would be only one thread at a
time executing this method so if i put
the synchronized here and if i rerun
this example you see i get a more
streamlined output if you notice
everything is one running like clockwork
where first the thread 1 gets executed
so i get 2 4 6 8 10 really well printed
and then the second thread starts which
says 3 6 9 12 15. the reason i get this
output is because when i did t1 dot
start it immediately went to execute the
get multiples method but it saw
synchronized there so it took a lock on
the method and even when the t2.start
might have got executed maybe
milliseconds after that or no seconds
after that it still could not get hold
of the get multiples method because
thread1 occupied this particular method
it took a lock on this particular method
due to the synchronized keyword so
that's the power of synchronized keyword
that you can take a lock on a particular
method if you put it in front of the
method now there can be scenarios that
you do not want to lock the whole method
you still want two different threads to
access the method but there can be very
few lines of code inside the method
which is the which is thread sensitive
code now how do you spot that sensitive
code there is no magic bullet there is
no silver bullet for it and it comes
with experience so you need to have that
experience to know which is the thread
sensitive code which can create problems
if two threads run that code at the same
time so the moment you have spotted that
code and if you don't want to lock the
whole method you can lock the exact
lines of code by putting the
synchronized block so if i remove this
and i enable this particular part so
what i'm doing that i know that this is
the code which is exactly causing the
problem which is creating this random
output so what i can do that i can put
the synchronized keyword right before
the block of the code starts which is
thread sensitive and the way you do that
is you write synchronized and you supply
this
which means whoever has the current who
whoever has the object of the math
appeals that whole object gets logged
for this particular block of code so
whoever has the math utils object takes
the lock on the object for this
particular block of code if there were
some other code which was written in the
get multiples method before the
synchronized block or after the
synchronized block that block can be
accessed by multiple threads at the same
time but this code will only be
accessible to one thread at a time there
will never be there will never be a
concurrent access to the synchronized
block that's the power of synchronized
block and it will work the exact same
way so to show you if i run this
particular program i still get the
output in the same streamline way where
first the multiples of two get printed
and then the multiples of three get
printed so that's how you can actually
use synchronized methods or synchronized
block to make sure that one thread is
accessing a sensitive object at a time
and there will never be a scenario that
two threads are mutating the same object
at the same time again like i said be
very very cautious of when you use
synchronized blocks and when you use
threads because threads have
unpredictable execution cycle execution
sequence basically and synchronized
blocks also have problems if you have if
you have thousands and thousands of
threads running in your application and
if you put synchronized on a particular
method your application may face severe
performance issues because all of the
threads will be executing that method in
a sequence imagine you put this on to a
huge application or a huge ecommerce
application or a news website it is it
is going to create serious performance
issues so be very cautious of how and
when you use synchronized method and the
key to that is to have that developer
dna to spot the code which is causing
this problem which might be thread
sensitive and maybe you might need to
change the code itself you might not
need to go into the multi-threading
scenario and you might you might be able
to fix it without using the threading or
synchronized concept it completely
depends but always have a good tradeoff
when to use the synchronized methods and
synchronize blocks let's get started
with auto boxing and unboxing in java so
if you remember in the very first
sessions i talked about the primitive
data types and then later on we talked
about the objects for example we had the
int data type but there later we also
saw an integer data type which is which
can also pretty much do the exact same
work which int data type was doing and
we saw the similar kind of uh experience
for the float data type and the float
class double data type and the double
class care data type and the character
class and so on so forth so java
provides an easy way to convert a int
data type variable into an integer data
type variable and also back from integer
data type variable to an int primitive
data type variable now you might be
wondering why we need that there would
be scenarios for example if you had an
int array as in primitive int array and
if you want to store that into a
collection now collection can only be of
type of objects it cannot be a type of
primitive data type so you might need to
convert this int primitive data type
array into an integer object collection
so you need to do this conversion of
into data type to integer data type and
there would be cases where you invited
you might need to do vice versa so
that's the basic idea about auto boxing
and unboxing so when we talk about the
definition you can see auto boxing is
the automatic conversion that the java
compiler makes between the primitive and
their corresponding object wrapper
classes so whenever you are converting a
primitive data type to an object class
this is called autoboxing and when you
do the reverse it is called auto
unboxing or simply unboxing so let's
understand this with the help of an
example now so i'm just going to open an
example about auto boxing and unboxing
so that we can have a look at it and
here it is i've created a class which is
called auto boxing demo it has a public
static void main method and inside the
method i'm first simply declaring an int
data type variable i with the value 10
then if i need to auto box this if i
need to convert this primitive value
into an integer object wrapper class or
an integer class type then i need to
write the code like this which says
integer
dot value off and then you can supply
the primitive data type value and the
output of it will be of type integer
class so you get an integer object and
then you can print the object to check
if it is successfully doing the
autoboxing or not similarly doing the
other way round once i have converted
this into an integer object let's
convert this back to a primitive data
type so from integer object i'm
converting this back into the primitive
data type and you see here it's a simple
assignment i just have to assign the
object to the primitive data type and
that's it i can do the same for a
character
object and a cad data type so first i
create a character object care obj and
then if i have to unbox it i can simply
assign this cad obj to a care primitive
data type ch and that would be it so you
can do the similar drill for any other
primitive to object wrapper conversion
let's say you want to convert a float
data type to a float class or you want
to convert a double data type to a
double class then whichever primitive
data type has an object wrapper class
you can do the auto boxing and auto
unboxing like this remember whenever you
have to do auto box it means you're
going from primitive to object and for
that you need to call the value of
method for example if you were
converting a double primitive to a
double object class double object type
basically then you are going to call
double dot value off and similarly the
same kind of behavior will be seen for
other object wrapper classes as well so
for auto boxing you call the value off
and for auto unboxing you literally just
assign this to an primitive and the
object wrapper class value will
automatically be assigned to the
primitive data type so let's run this
now and observe the output so i had the
int i equal to 10 then i wanted to
convert this primitive into the object
wrapper and the way i can do that is by
calling the value of method and
supplying the primitive data types value
so that's why i'm doing it that's what
i'm doing here and this i obj
should get the 10 value now which i can
see if i print the cis out and if i just
print the integer object all together i
get the value 10 so this concludes that
i've successfully am able to
auto box the primitive into an integer
object now looking at auto unbox like i
said you simply can assign the object
wrapper to the primitive data type
variable and that should work as is and
that's why at line 15 we get this output
which says value of i1 is 10. similarly
when we try to auto box the character
object so i have created a character
object here and then i want to unbox
this back into a simple car data type ch
so when i print ch i get the same value
and when i print the cad obj i again get
the same value remember the reason i've
put this as auto box is because this by
default is being stored into a car data
type i can also write it like this for
example i can say care x equal to a and
then i can refer here as character
dot value of x this will pretty much
have the same impact or the same effect
which i had just now it is going to
print the exact same output if i read on
this program i am going to get the exact
same output so this this basically
concludes our understanding that you can
use the auto boxing and auto unboxing
pretty easily whenever you have a
scenario where you want to convert the
primitive data types to the object
wrapper classes or you want to convert
the object wrapper classes back to the
primitive data types let's get started
with using jdbc in java to connect to
the databases in this example i'm using
the open source community edition
postgresql but you can use any database
vendor provider if you want to if you
want to use oracle or mysql feel free to
do that but in this demo i'm going to
use postgres so you can download the
postgres windows installer since i'm
using a windows machine here you can
download the installer from the official
postgresql.org website and you can also
download the jdbc driver for post resql
going to this particular official
website which is jdbc.postgresql.org
similarly you will be able to find the
jdbc driver for all other database
vendor providers as well once you
download this this is going to download
a jar for you and you can store the jar
anywhere like i put this jar into this
particular location you can see this
latest jdbc driver jar for post sql so
for every database vendor there would be
a different jdbc jar which you need to
download so that's that you install the
postgresql you set up its database and
when you install the post resql you also
get a nice sql client to talk to the
database because database has a server
and database has a client right so to
deal with that you install the server
and all these database vendors like
postgres oracle microsoft sql etc they
also provide a nice thin client with it
postgres also provides a client when you
install the uh postgres server it will
also ask you or it will actually
automatically install the sql client for
it as well which is called pg admin so
this is how the pg admin client looks
like the current edition of it is pg
admin 4 so you will get that installed
automatically and once your postgres
server has been successfully installed
if you just go to search and type pg
admin you will get this option once you
click on this option a new browser
window will be opened and you will see
this client here you will not see this
particular window let me let me close
this one but you will see something like
this you will see a server here so you
can go inside it you will see a
postgresql edition here and if you go
inside it you will see a database here
if you open the database you will see
the postgres database by default created
so you can just right click on this and
create a database here you can name it
as whatever you want you can leave
everything as is for now and hit save
another thing which you need to do when
you do the installation is it will ask
you to set a database user and password
so choose whatever database username and
password you are comfortable with and
you will be using that user username and
password in your program as well so
create your database here and just leave
the database at this particular point
and now we will try to connect to this
particular database in the in the
example which i prepared i'm going to
connect to this test database so let's
go to the jdbc demo and see what is
happening there so for this purpose i
have created a class called jdbc demo it
has a public static void main method and
there's a lot going on here so let's
take it step by step and i will be keep
shuffling between the database sql
client and this particular class to
build a nice narrative so if you think
carefully what you need to have if you
want to connect to a database
the obvious answer is the address of the
database where is that database you need
to know the location of the database to
connect to it so that is called the
connection url every database vendor
will provide its own connection url and
you can find that connection url from
the official documentation there are
tons of examples available for it as
well but always refer to the official
documentation for that particular
database provider the general syntax is
jdbc colon your database vendor's name
colon double slash the host name this
can be any ip address or your local host
generally we also put a port here
something like this 5432 is the port on
which the post resql server runs but
again you can put the post the port here
on which your database server is running
every database vendor has their own
default port the postgres sql server has
the default port as 5432 so you provide
the host name you provide the port and
then you provide the database name you
provide the database name to connect to
so if you remember i told you that i
have written the program to connect to
this particular database called test so
whatever that be you provide that name
here and this is going to form the
connection url i can remove this for now
but this is how the connection string is
going to look like and it is going to
its follow it follows the same format
for any database vendor that you say
jdbc column you write the database
vendor name and then you say column
double slash you provide the host port
and then you provide the database name
so that is your connection url after
that to connect to a connect your java
program to a database you need to use
the
java.sql.connection class this is very
critical class and very important and
probably the single most important class
which you need to have in your program
if you want to connect to a database so
you say connection con equal to null i'm
just creating a null reference to it and
before we go any further let me also
tell you why we need this jdbc and what
is actually this jdbc so
java is a programming language it does
not comes with its own database but
there are multiple other vendors like
post sql mysql microsoft sql oracle etc
so java wanted to provide a uniform way
to connect to all of these databases
because imagine all of these databases
building their own api contract it would
have been a nightmare for the developers
to connect to different databases or
shift from one database to other
database and that's the reason java
created this nice interface called jdbc
and it said whoever wants to connect to
java should follow this jdbc
specification and provide their
implementation similar to the the
interface and concrete class thing it's
not exactly that but you can think of it
in that manner that jdbc provides an
interface with the method declarations
and then oracle post sql mysql all these
database vendors are supposed to
implement that interface and provide
their own implementation but jdbc apis
will always remain the same whoever
wants to connect to java has to create a
driver and that driver contains that
implementation and that's the reason we
downloaded that jdbc driver and i will
come to how do we include that but
that's the background of jdbc and that's
why you need jdbc to build that uniform
contract and your vendor will provide
their own jar which will have the
implementation of the jdbc interface and
in this program what i'm trying to do is
basically i'm trying to insert a record
into a table so what is a table and how
do you create that so let's go back here
so in this test database you will see a
schema by default you will see a public
schema and you can create a new schema
if you want to or you can just use the
public schema so inside the public
schema you will go under and you will
see a
an entry for tables so you just right
click and you say create table you can
also write in complete sql statement but
i'm just showing you how to do that in
pg admin and you can give the table name
you can give the column information and
that's how you create the table so i
have created a table here which is
called student and the student table has
three columns roll number name and page
if i show you the exact query or the the
whole create tdl for it it looks like
this so i created the
student table in the public schema which
has a roll number field a roll number
column which is of type numeric it has a
name column which is a varchar or a
character varying and it has a age
column which is again a numeric so roll
number name and age these are the three
different columns which i created inside
the student table so i have a student
table with these three columns so that's
that now let's go back to the program so
i have the student table and now i want
to insert some records in the student
table so let me just change the values
here so that we can see a different
entry so i have just hardcoded some
values generally you will be getting
these values from somewhere in the
program but for simplicity let's say you
have got those values once you have got
those values the next thing you need to
do is to build the sql statement the
exact sql statement which the postgres
which is going to be run on the post sql
server so you write that statement in
this case i'm showing you in a creation
example so it is going to be an insert
query so i say insert into table name
which is student and then i provide all
the column names it is always a better
practice to provide the column names in
these brackets even if you are inserting
the values to all the columns still
provide the column names so i say insert
into table column
values and then you provide the actual
values as the roll number variable which
i created here the name variable and the
age variable values so i just supply the
values here remember the when you are
inserting the values roll number and age
are integer so you don't need to put any
single commas single inverted commas for
it but name is a string variable so i
put this single inverted commas it's a
simple string concatenation nothing
fancy here so i'm just writing and a
plain sql statement here and storing
that into a string once i've done that
the next piece which i need to do is to
get a connection to the database and the
way you are going to get a connection is
by this uniform method no matter which
database provider you are using you are
always going to use the
drivermanager.getconnection method to
get a connection to the database and how
do you get the connection you supply the
connection url you supply the username
to connect to the database and you
supply the password in this case i've
just set the username and password as
postgres and postgres so postgres is the
username and postgres is the password
pretty lame i accept but this is just
for demonstration purpose so it's fine
but generally you will be getting these
values from some application property
file so these are the three parameters
which you need to supply to this get
connection method and then you will get
a live connection to the database this
is this this is the line which is going
to make it all happen to connect to your
database server so if this line gets
executed successfully you have a live
connection once you have a live
connection the next thing which you are
going to do is to create a statement
object on the connection statement is it
can be anything it can be an insert
statement or a select statement or
update statement or a delete statement
everything is a statement there right so
that's why you need to create a
statement object so you create a
statement object and then you execute
the sql this insert sql which you
prepared you're going to execute the sql
here saying st dot execute update
execute update is the method which is
used for any insertion or deletion
operations so that's the method you're
going to use and supplying the sql query
which you built with the actual values
of roll number name and age the execute
update method returns the number of rows
affected once this statement got run on
the database server or the sql query got
run on the database server it might
impact one rows if it's just if it's an
insertion it might impact multiple rows
if it was an update query right so it is
going to return the number of rows
affected and that is what we are going
to use to check if my insertion
successfully went or my insertion failed
so if this execute update is going to
return 1 which means that my row got
inserted successfully in the database so
i'm just printing us this out here and
if any if this particular m returned 0
which means none of the rows were
affected by my sql query which means my
insertion operation failed so i'm just
printing assist out here and then i'm
just putting this in a catch block here
to print any error and finally closing
the connection this is again very very
important database correction is one of
the costliest connections you will be
creating when you will be writing your
java applications always and always make
sure to close this database connections
otherwise your application is going to
face serious database bottlenecks so we
close the connection so that's all we
are doing here we prepare the url we
prepare we just create a placeholder for
connection object we prepare our skill
query with all the relevant values we
get a connection to the database we get
a create statement we get a statement
object from the create statement method
and then we execute the statement and
then we can validate the statement
execution if there is a way to validate
it once you've done all of that you
close the connection so let's run this
program and see if we can see this new
record inside the student table and
before we do that let's also validate
what is present in the student table as
of now so if i go here and i say view
all rows this is just going to run a
select star on the student table so
currently student table has one record
with role number one name as john and
age as 20 and now i am trying to insert
another row with roll number two name as
jane and age as 22. so if i right click
and run as java application i get this
entry which says inserted successfully
which is coming from here insert it
successfully and it also prints the
exact sql so that you can see what sql
actually got executed on the database
server this is the same string sql which
i built so this is the sql which got run
on the server which said insert into
student values and the roll number the
roll number was 2 and the name was jane
with single inverted commas because this
was a string and then age was 22. this
was the exact sql which got executed so
my sql has been executed my connection
has been closed if i go back to the pg
admin client and if i try to rerun this
query now i get two records so if you
remember this record was already there
but now i get the second entry which is
the new entry it just got inserted
because i did i ran the program and you
see the rule number two the name as jane
and the age as 22. so this was a very
simple example to show you how you can
do the jdbc correction but one of the
things which i still haven't covered is
the usage of the jdbc driver the jar
which i talked about so the way you are
going to add the jar is you go to the
project you right click on the project
you go to the build path go to the
configure build path and there you will
see different tabs source projects
libraries so go to the libraries tab and
select the class path here and you can
choose the add external jars option
click on this load your sql jdbc jar for
your particular database vendor for my
case it was post resql let me just
quickly remove this jar and show you
right from how it's done so this is how
it will look like for you you select the
class path you click on add external
jars you go to the location where you
have downloaded your jdbc driver jar for
your particular database select that
click open it will come here hit apply
and close that's how the jar is going to
be there if you don't provide the jar
your program is going to fail miserably
it is not going to work so make sure
that you have the jar and then only it
is going to be able to create a
successful connection and be able to
successfully execute the query remember
jdbc provides the specifications and
then the particular database vendor like
postgresql provides the jdbc driver
which has the implementation for that
jdbc api and that the java has this
uniform jdbc avi api and every database
vendor is expected to honor and
implement that api only so that java
developers can work on the jdbc contract
and everything should work as is let's
get started with generics in java so
before we go about generics let's
understand why do we need generics and
what what was the requirement that led
to the creation of generics so as we
know that when we work in any object
oriented programming language we created
classes we create objects we create
variables and everything has a type
everything has a type and that type is
static the type cannot be changed that's
why we call java as a strong type
checking language at compile time it
checks the types of the variables of the
classes at the compile time and if the
classes are mismatching or their types
are mismatching then you basically get a
compilation error but
what we see as we as we moved along we
saw that we were creating the similar
kind of functionality again and again in
different classes for example if there
is a login functionality which should
allow a person to log in and we should
also allow an application to log in then
these are the two different use cases
but the functionality still remains the
same so how would the login
functionality allow both of the types of
entities be it user or application to
get into the application or login into
the consumer application how do you do
that and that's what led to the creation
of generics that you can reuse the same
code with different types of inputs
remember the stress here is on the types
and that's what it is mentioned here
that we will like to reuse the same code
with different inputs we will just keep
changing the type parameters and we'll
keep using the same same code again and
again it has some benefits over the
non-generic code like we mentioned like
i mentioned earlier that when we work
with the non-generic code we have the
statically assigned types to the
variables and objects and if we use
generics then we don't have to do that
and at the same time you don't even have
to explicitly cast them we touched upon
this concept of
generics in different bits and pieces in
different sessions throughout this
tutorial series where we saw that
whenever i was creating a list i was
supplying this type into these brackets
right and i told that this that this is
the generic type but now we'll go deeper
into this concept and we'll see how we
can create our own generic types if java
does not provide it so with that let's
move to an example and see how we can
implement our own generic types to
create generic code
where we can supply the types
dynamically so i've prepared an example
for this i've actually prepared two
examples for this and we'll go through
both of them one by one so here what i'm
doing that i'm creating any class you
can think of it as any class holding any
functionality which is applicable to
multiple entity types think of it as the
same login class which i just talked
about so if your class has a
functionality which should be reused by
many different types then one of the way
to not repeat the code or repeat the
class or repeat the functionality again
and again is to make that class use a
generic signature and how you do that
you write the class name and then you
put these brackets and you just type t
you can write any variable abc or
whatever you feel like but t is sort of
the
default standard the java developers
have been using since generics was
launched so you put this t here now
whoever calls this class or whoever
whoever initializes this class will have
to supply the type of the class on which
this particular functionality is going
to get executed now remember the
collection examples i took i took in the
past series what if this was a list
class because we have used the exact
same syntax right we use list we put
brackets and then we wrote string and we
said okay now this list is a
list of strings if we said list of
integers then we just write integer in
these brackets and that list became a
list of integers so you see the same
list was being reused for different data
types and the exact same concept is
applied here for your custom classes and
your own custom functionality so i write
t here then i can do whatever with this
t i want so i just
put a reference of it inside the class i
create a constructor constructor is also
assigning the t type i do a get object
and that's all it's a very simple toy
example but just to get the point across
you can write as complex logic as you
want inside the class depending upon
your use case but this is just a
straightforward example that you can use
generics in the classes as well once you
do that then how do you initialize this
class
so let's have a look at that as well so
i've just created a public static void
bin method inside the same class
obviously you can create this method
outside the outside this class as well
there's no stopping that logic but but
for the sake of simplicity i've just put
the main class here so it's a simple
public static void main method there i
am initializing the single generic
holder class the same class and here the
t type is of integer this t type can be
of anything else as well for example
your own student class can also be
supplied here and then the single
generic holder will become of student
type in this case i'm just using a
pre-built java class so this single
generic holder becomes of integer type i
give a reference i create an object
and i provide a value to the object
because you see the constructor is this
whatever t you supply so if the t is the
integer this t becomes integer and this
obj is going to hold the value 10
because that's the constructor being
called here and after that you can do
whatever you want in terms of the logic
here i'm just i just have i just have a
get object method so i'm just calling
that method and printing the object
that's all similarly you can also
initialize the same class with the
string type so you see i'm reusing the
same class in the same functionality
again and again for different class
types so this time i'm using the string
type instead of integer and i'm
supplying a string parameter this time
and this this constructor still will
work because this is generic when you
created with integer this constructor
this t became of integer type and when
you initialized it with the string type
this constructor started accepting the
string objects so just supply a string
called simply code and then i call get
object
so let's run this method so when we run
the main method from the first
invocation at line 16 and 17 when you
call the get object the value of the
object gets printed which is 10 for the
integer and then at line 20 the value of
the string gets printed which is simply
code so that's how you can use generics
inside a class or for a class now there
might be use cases where you have to
create a class which can accept multiple
types of generic types let's take an
example if you remember when we talked
about hashmap we had the exact same
situation so you had the key and you had
the value now key can be of any type any
data type it can be string integer
whatever and then value can also be of
any data type it can also be your custom
data types for example the key becomes a
roll numbers and the value becomes
student object so map is a situation
where you have two generic types so i'm
just trying to replicate that similar
kind of behavior that if you have to
create a class with two three as many
generic types as you want you can still
do that by just providing a comma here
you can go on doing as many generics as
you want in this example i'm using two
generics and then it again goes to the
same drill that i've created references
for both d and u i have initialized both
p and u in the constructor and then i
have a display method which is going to
call the and display the obj 1 and obj
2's values or their two string methods
basically because when you when you try
to call the object inside the
system.out.println method the by default
the tostring method of the object will
automatically get called so that's all i
have in this particular class so i it's
a simple class accepting two different
types of generics and then calling the
display method and here is the public
static void main method for the same
here i am initializing the dual generic
class and here the t is string and u is
integer so these t and u are
assigned these class types and then i
create the class i again write the same
types and i provide the value so for the
string one i provide simply code for the
integer one i provide 10 this
constructor gets called obj one gets the
value simply code and obj 2 gets the
value 10 and then i call display method
there i am printing obj1 and obj2 so
let's run this method okay i'm getting
simply code in 10 because when i call
the display method at line 13 obj 1 gets
printed obj 1 is holding simply code
value and at line 14 obj 2 gets printed
or the two string method of the obj 2
gets printed which is holding the value
10. so this was a quick tour to tell you
how can you use generics you can
obviously use generics in the variable
types as well you can use generics in
the method argument types as well
wherever you want the simple idea is
that one you would like to reuse the
functionality again and again and second
you would like to you would not like to
have a strong strict type checking and
like i said try to relate these generic
concepts with the collection framework
we listen because collection framework
is completely built upon the concept of
generics whenever we initialize a list
or a map or a hash set or a linked list
or error list or anything we always
supply the type and the type is coming
from these uh if you look at the
implementation of error list class you
will see that let me see if i can open
that for you to show you how that looks
like if i go to an example
of collections and if i try to just open
the class you will be able to see that
yep so if i click on this list class you
see list of e type so here e is the type
which you are going to supply so in this
particular case when you say list of
integer this integer gets
typed into e so whatever so this this
whole list class whatever operations you
are doing inside the list class will be
applied for the integer type so
similarly you can look at other
collection classes and you will always
see these generics everywhere in the
collection classes let's get started
with java.lang package so java.lang
package is one of the most core and
fundamental packages in java which is
provided out of the box to the developer
you never explicitly import this package
in your java program because you don't
need to java provides this automatically
the moment you create a file with java
extension or and you have you are
running that particular program inside
or on a jdk you get the java.lang
package automatically for example when
we were when we were running the string
handling demo i was using the string
class but i never imported the string
class you can see there is no import for
string because string class is also part
of the java.lang package it's
automatically imported for you you never
need to explicitly import the package or
any classes of that package so this is
going to be more of a theoretical
lecture where we will just have a look
at our quick overview of all the
java.lang package classes and other
utilities you don't need to remember all
the classes and utilities but this is
just to give you a sense of what all it
contains so in terms of the interfaces
it has the appendable interface auto
cloud auto closable care sequence
clonable comparable if you remember we
also used comparable when we were
writing the comparable
implementation to compare different
objects in a collection so this also
comes automatically as part of the
java.lang package iterable runnable
again we use this in the in the
threading example so this also comes
automatically to you you never need to
import the runnable class from the
java.lang package when we move to the
classes all the data type classes which
you can think of in terms of boolean
byte character class class loader
compiler enums even float integer long
math so all the classes which we were
using the the data type classes which we
were using in different examples are
also part of the java.lang package okay
so this is a long long list it also has
a thread class so whenever you are
creating thread you again never imported
thread class but it still just worked
fine because there was uh
this was also coming as part of the
java.lang package there are also bunch
of enumerations which it provides in
terms of unicode thread state etc it
also provides exception classes like
arithmetic exception or the different
runtime exceptions which we dealt with
like array index out of bound array
store class cast class not supported the
root exception class so a lot of
exception classes also come as part of
the java.lang package it also provides
some error classes if you remember when
we talked about the exception framework
you have the error types and you have
the exception types so it also provides
some error classes if you want to use
that you don't you never need to import
any of these classes and you will
automatically get them from the
java.lang package similarly it also
provides some annotations as well like
functional interfaces or you remember we
use this annotation a lot the add the
rate override annotation but we never
imported the override class or the
override annotation because it's part of
the java.lang package so this basically
tells us that there are a lot of
different classes utilities enums errors
exceptions data types which are provided
out of the box from the java.lang
package which makes our life so much
easier whenever we want to work with
java because we don't need to import the
very basic classes which
which we use very frequently and another
very important package is the java.util
package we have been using the java.util
package in all of the collections
examples and tutorials we walk through
in this whole tutorial series so let me
just open the java.util package for you
so if i go here to java.util and i will
be able to see the java.util packages
different classes etc yes so here is
here it is the java.util package and
remember java.util package is not
imported automatically you have to
explicitly import the java.util package
to use the classes of it so it so that's
the difference between java.lang package
and java.util package that you cannot
you can use
the classes coming from the java.lang
package without explicitly importing
those glasses or importing the java.lang
package but java.util package is
something which you have to explicitly
import in your java program to make it
work or even make it compile so what
java.util provides first of all the
collections framework the whole
collections framework comes from the
java.util package so for example all the
interfaces which we use while we work
with the collections framework classes
interfaces like collection list set map
you can see the map interface you can
see the list interface with the generics
so all the interfaces which we use from
in the collections framework are present
in the java.util package similarly when
we talk about the glasses all the
concrete classes implementation of the
collections framework in terms of error
list linked list hash map hash set
preset tree map you will see all of
those classes here here we are covering
all the this is showing all the classes
summary so you see some abstract classes
and you will also see some concrete
classes as you move further down in this
particular list so you see hash map you
see hash set hash table linked hash map
linked asset linked list we used all of
these classes while we were going
through the collections framework
tutorials so it provides all of these
and a lot of other classes like the
scanner class which we covered in the
java project for taking the inputs from
the command line from the user uh stack
class again from the collection some
time classes and it also provides bunch
of enumerations like the locale
basically setting the language
categories for a particular program it
also provides some exceptions which we
used while we were working with the
collections framework so most of these
exceptions are or some of these
exceptions are related to the collection
classes for example the concurrent
modification exception gets thrown uh
whenever you your the whole execution
detects concurrent modification of an
object when such modification is not
allowed you will see other different
types of exceptions like illegal format
etc in this particular exception
section of this particular package then
it also provides just one error class as
well so this is what the java.util
package contains and just to refresh
your memory whenever we ran any
collection demo we always imported the
java.util classes you can see this is
all coming from java.util so this is
something which you have to import
without which your program will not even
compile so that's also one of the
difference between the java.lang package
and the java.util package and that's
pretty much all i want to cover in this
particular session so we basically did a
quick tour of the java.lang package and
the java.util package and like i said
it's impossible to cover all of that for
all of the classes and enums and
interfaces and errors and exceptions
with all the examples so i would suggest
you to just keep this in mind about the
java.lang package and java.util package
i told you the basic concept that
java.lang contains all the types the
class and the variable types or the data
types we dealt with and java.util
majorly contains all the collection
classes uh that's that's the that's the
basic uh thing which you need to
remember whenever you work with java and
your java.lang package never needs to be
imported but java.util package needs to
be imported always whenever you use the
util classes let's get started with
concurrency utilities in java now
concurrency is a huge topic and it's not
possible to cover this into a 10 or 15
minutes tutorials so treat this
particular session as an introductory
session where i will talk about some of
the most relevant classes which you need
to know when you talk about concurrency
we have been talking about this whole
concept of concurrency programming
throughout the thread tutorials as well
and the basic idea is that you would
like to do multiple things at the same
time that's the basic idea now in that
context java does provide a lot of
utilities and packages especially the
java.util.concurrent package is one of
the most popular package which you need
to use whenever you are dealing with
concurrency programming paradigms in
java so with that let's have a look at
what does this
java.util.concurrent package contains so
broadly it contains lot of utility
classes which can be very useful for you
when you are writing the concurrent
programming code apart from that it will
also provide some basic ideas around the
locking functionality and the atomic
packages as well when we talk about
locks again we discussed about locks
when we talked about the whole sync
thread synchronization concept as well
and it basically marries very well with
the whole concept of locks and atomic
packages as well atomic is again a
different topic which is used for thread
safe types basically but whenever you
will hear about concurrency utilities be
it in your discussions or be it in your
interviews you will be seeing a
discussion happening around executors
you will hear these terms like executors
executor service future completable
future callable all of these you will
hear the name of all of these classes
quite frequently so we these classes
were first introduced in java 8 and have
been there since then to support the
concurrency programming paradigm so i
will talk about these three classes
broadly in today's session and we'll
have a look at a demonstration of these
three classes as well uh let's first
talk about executor technically it's an
it's an interface it's not a class
though i said that it's a class but it's
basically an interface an executor is
basically a very simple interface which
will help you define the subsystems
which you want to which you would like
to create with the help of threads may
be including thread pools or if you want
to do a disk reading and writing
operation in an insynchronous way or you
want to create some sequence of task
frameworks as well so executor will
provide you a very lightweight framework
to do all of that especially around
thread pooling and asynchronous i o is
is where it shines most because in your
computer you have limited resources and
you would like to
dedicate a certain pool of threads for a
particular task or for a particular
executor object so with that and the
second class which we would like to know
about is executor service an executor
service will provide a more asynchronous
task execution framework and this is
probably the class which you will be
using whenever you're dealing with
asynchronous programming in java
asynchronous programming basically means
that you submitted a particular task but
you did not wait for it to be completed
you did not hang your process or your
thread for that particular task to be
completed it's very simple it's very uh
easy to relate this to a real life for
example if you are
you know there are times when you do two
things at the same time for example uh
let's take a very very simple example if
you're just boiling milk on on your gas
stove so you put the milk on the gas
stove and then you move out for a couple
of minutes to do some something else for
example maybe checking your mobile for
new emails or or doing some other work
doing maybe just doing some laundry so
uh you are doing you you submitted the
milk boiling task then you moved away
from that task because you know that
this particular task is going to take
some time and you utilize your time
somewhere else that's what we mean by
asynchronous programming and executor
service will provide you with constructs
to create a similar behavior in your
java program as well so remember about
executor and executor service uh we will
look at the implementations later where
we can talk about that another
interesting class which i would like
which i would like to talk about is
future if we have it here yeah so future
is another class which we will be
looking at and future is basically uh to
fetch the result of the submitted task
again taking the same knife example of
the milk boiling example so
it would be great right if if there is
some mechanism or some alarm which just
sets off the moment the milk is is is
boiling and it's about to be spilled out
it would be great to know that in that
in advance via some alarm or something
so future provides that kind of a
carrier or that kind of a holder where
you submitted a particular task you
moved your threads to something else you
did something else and then you can
check with the future object and future
object will tell the status of their
submitted task whether it is completed
or whether it's still in progress once
it is complete then you can fetch the
result of that submitted task based on
with the future object so that's the
concept of future so remember executor
service and future they will work quite
hand in hand because executor service
will be used to submit the task and
future will be able to fetch the result
of that particular task asynchronously
so that was about a quick theory you can
read more about it in the documentation
you can see an executor service future
class what does what does this basically
in this class do
but to have a look at or or get a
greater sense of this let's have a look
at our demonstration of it to understand
these classes better so let's move to uh
the eclipse ide to look at an example
let me close all the classes and just
open a relevant one so yeah so let's
first deal with the executor interface
itself so if i just minimize this one
here i've created a main class and i've
created a public static void main method
and you see two static methods here
executor invoke an executor service
invoke i'm basically showing you how you
can use executor and execute a service
so if you're just using executor then
how you would do that is basically you
are going to create a reference of the
executor and then the executor needs a
basically an executor object because
it's an executor reference so you need
to supply an executor object so either
you can supply an inner class right here
or you can call you can create a
executor type of class which i've
created here which is called caller
class so i've created a class called
caller which implements the executor
type and execu the moment you write
implements executor it will force you to
override the execute method and inside
the execute method you are going to run
your own thread so this is how the
current thread or the executor's own
thread will be running so once you have
done the initialization then you can
call the execute method on the executor
class remember you got this object so
you know you can call the executor
execute method on the executor object
here and inside this you can provide
this particular lambda function
implementation which is going to ask you
what exactly you want to do when i run
this particular thread so when i run
this thread when java runs this
particular thread what do you want java
to do that's something which you will
provide here so this is how you can use
it's a very simple example like i said
uh
this if i build a more complex example
it will take a lot of time and lot of
other concepts to cover so treat this as
an introductory session and you can
basically try to run a very simple
example of this writing whatever complex
logic you want to write while the thread
is running and put that into this
execute similarly if you if you want to
use executor service for doing the
asynchronous operations then it will
follow the same way but there are some
differences along the way as well so
this is the method which is showing the
executor service implementation or the
way of using executor service so again i
create a reference of executor service
and then here you see i'm saying
executors dot new fixed thread pool with
a size of 10. so that's the power of
executor service it is going to create a
pool of threads dedicated to itself to
do the tasks whichever are written
inside here so whatever you write here
these thread pool will be utilized to
execute that particular task you can
assign the size of the thread pool based
on how many threads you need there are
multiple static utility methods like
there is one new fixed thread pull which
i've used but if you just do control
enter you will see cached thread pool a
single thread execution a new work
stealing pool so like i mentioned there
are a lot of classes interesting classes
here which you can use for simplicity
i've just used a fixed thread pool here
once you get the executor service object
then here you called execute but here
you will be calling the submit method
and then the drill goes exactly the same
way that you write the lambda function
implementation inside here basically the
functional interface implementation and
you provide your own implementation code
which you would like to run whenever you
call the run method whenever this
executor service calls the run method on
that particular thread you can actually
go to the submit method and you will see
it accepts a runnable it basically
accepts a thread object so whatever you
write inside this particular code will
be the public void run implementation of
that particular thread class if you
don't
if you don't remember how threadable
works please go back to my threading uh
tutorial and watch that where i
explained the runnable interface and the
run method in detail so that's what we
are doing here so this is for executor
and this is for executor service so
let's run this program and yes i mean
nothing because i'm not doing anything
much apart from just doing sis outs here
and that's what you see here the
executor's example and the executor
service exam so this was about executor
and executor service now let's deal with
another interesting class of
of called future which i said that i
will also talk about so for that i've
created a separate demo because it
deserves a separate demo it's a very
interesting class so let me just make it
full screen yeah so i've created a class
called future demo which has a public
static void main method and again i'm
doing the
executor service initialization but this
time i'm using a new single thread
executor now what does this does this
this will basically create an executor
which will use a single worker thread
operating from an unbounded queue
remember even if this single thread
terminates due to let's say a failure
during the execution before the before
the graceful shutdown a new one will
automatically be spawned and will take
its place if the execution is still
pending so that's the power of single
worker thread from an unbounded queue
that's what i've used here based on your
use case you can use other ones as well
like i mentioned earlier then uh i have
the executor service object with me and
similar to the previous example i'm
going to call the submit method and
inside this submit method i need to
provide the runnable class runnable
interfaces implementation and that
implementation will basically be of the
public void run method and this is what
i want to do in my run method where i'm
sleeping the thread for 10 seconds
thread.sleep method takes milliseconds
values as the parameter so this is 10
000 which means 10 seconds so i'm
sleeping this thread or pausing this
thread for 10 seconds and then returning
a string called completed this is what i
am doing in the executor service dot
submit implementation the result of it
is going to be a future object remember
the result of the submit task is going
to be a future object so i store that
future reference here and then at line
20 i'm using the same feature of future
object to ask java to check if this task
is done and the way you do that is just
by calling is done so till the time
there's a negation condition till the
time the task is still in progress
because this means future is not done
because i've put a negation then just
print this out there where you say the
task is still in progress it's still not
complete and you pause this particular
thread remember this was a different
thread if you you pause this particular
thread for 500 millisecond or basically
half a second and you again check this
condition if it's still not done you
print this again pause for half a second
again check this till the time feature
dot is done becomes true when future dot
is done becomes true that means that
this particular task is completed now
you see i mean generally when we execute
the programs the execution happens
sequently sequentially that after line
17 the control will automatically flow
to line 20 and before the control can
reach line 20 everything above line 17
has to be completed that's that's
basically synchronous programming for
you but when you talk about asynchronous
programming using the power of executor
service and future objects we can do
something here which will go into a
separate thread and then you can
continue your execution here so this can
be in a different method altogether
where you submit something and this is
basically checking the status of this
task understand this very well this is
very important concept that it's not a
it's though it's a sequential execution
after line 17 line 20 is getting
executed but line 20 is not waiting for
everything above line 17 to be finished
it will continue that's the power of
asynchronous programming so here we are
checking this and once the feature the
future dot is done says true then we say
task completed we and then you probably
would like to fetch the result of this
particular task right and for that
future provides a method called future
dot get this is going to pick the future
object state and whatever you are
returning from here will be returned
here and then i'm printing the result so
if everything went fine this result
should say completed because that's what
i'm returning from this future object
and always remember to shut down your
executor service to release the thread
pool which you created here i've also
put a catch block here because i'm using
the thread.sleep method which will ask
you to handle an interrupted exception
and then there is an executor service
exception which is execution and a
timeout exception as well there are
other interesting methods as well on the
future class future object sorry which
is like future dot cancel where you can
cancel explicitly a future task which is
currently in progress you can check the
status of it by calling is done which
i've used here you can also call is
cancel to check if the user or some
other process explicitly cancelled the
execution of the submission of the
executor service task so hope this is
you are able to understand the flow of
it that these block and these block will
program will execute them but they will
run in different threads so let's see
what happens now i'm going to run this
particular program and if i bring this
here you see the task still in progress
keeps getting called so we submitted the
task here and now this block is getting
executed this block kept getting
executed so this task did not finish
right the thread dot sleep was this this
thread this whole thread was sleeping
for 10 seconds but line 20 did not wait
for 10 seconds it continued execution
and it kept checking the future object
10 times at least or till the whole 10
second sleep was taken away and one once
that once this thread woke up it
returned completed feature dot is done
became true and it came out and it said
task completed so that's what we get
here and at the end in the result you
get completed which is which is what you
returned from here so this is the power
of asynchronous programming please like
i mentioned please do read about more
about these classes and how they work
and what is the paradigm of asynchronous
programming it does make debugging a bit
hard at times but it's a very
interesting concept to be used in
concurrent applications let's get
started with regular expressions or
regex in java you may hear people
calling it as as regex or regex doesn't
matter you can call it anything as as
you want till the time you have the
concept understood in the right way i'll
just call it as regex so when we talk
about regex let's understand why do we
need them and what are how java actually
provides support for that so the basic
idea behind regular expressions is is to
find a pattern in a in a text corpus if
you have lot of strings available if you
have any kind of text any kind of string
and if you would like to find a
particular pattern saying okay does this
whole text paragraph contains any
character or contains any number or
contains any special characters or
contains characters after numbers or
numbers after characters so if you would
like to find those kind of patterns in
in your text corpus then you can then
that concept is called regular
expression finding and java provides the
support for that particular regular
expression finding through a package
called java dot util dot regex package
so this is the package which you would
need to use when you want to do any kind
of regular expression finding in that
text now you may want you may be
thinking that why do i need to use this
i already have the string handling
methods right you can do substring you
can find a particular character in the
string etc but that is limited because
it only and only provides string methods
ways to manipulate and find and replace
strings but regex is generic you can
literally find any kind of character in
your string it can be a special
character it can be a square bracket it
can be a multiply sign it can be a
divide sign it can be like i said
integer uh capital letters small case
letters so any kind of pattern you would
like to find
java.util.regex can be used to find that
kind of pattern now this package is very
interesting and it provides lots of
classes and again this is a very very
very big topic and very complex topic so
we will just scratch the surface of it
and like i always say whenever you would
like to read more about it go back and
read the documentation currently the
documentation i've opened is for version
8 but when you are reading it you can go
for the latest java edition uh
documentation so with that let's talk
about some of the interesting classes
which we will be dealing with and we
must know when we talk about regex in
java so i already explained what are
regular expressions uh let's go to the
interesting classes the first class
which we need to know about is the
pattern class so pattern class or an
object of the pattern class will
basically be representing a compiled
regular expression so you write your
regular expression in a certain way
regular expression has its own language
i would say to write the pattern for
example if you would like to write a
pattern saying that find uh
check if this particular text paragraph
has the characters first then the
integers then the characters then this
particular special character so that is
your pattern you write that pattern then
you need to compile that pattern to
compile that pattern you can use the
pattern class this this class generally
does not provide any kind of public
constructors to you so you cannot
initialize the pattern object explicitly
but to create a pattern you first you
need to basically call the static
methods a static method named as compile
so compile is the method which you need
to use to compile your regular
expression which will then return the
pattern object once you have compiled
your written your pattern and compile
your pattern the next class which you
need to know about is the matcher class
matcher class will provide that
particular engine framework which will
understand and interpret the pattern and
then will try to find that pattern on
the text paragraph which you're
supplying and it will result in true or
false if it finds that pattern it will
say true if it's not finding the pattern
it will say false so that's the basic
idea so you need to you need to know
about the pattern class and you need to
know about the matcher class so it also
does not the matcher class also does not
provide any kind of public constructors
and you obtain a matcher object by
calling the matcher method on the
pattern object so once you created a
pattern object just call the matcher on
that particular object and that will get
you a matcher object and it then you can
use that object to find the patterns in
that particular text corpus there is
also a dedicated exception which is
called pattern syntax exception which
will be
thrown whenever you have written the
regular expression syntax incorrectly
like i said it has it has its own
language so you need to write the
expression in a way regular expressions
are supposed to be written and supposed
to be understood i will touch upon that
in a while but that's that's the basic
idea about the three classes now when
when you would like to find a pattern it
can be a string pattern it can be some
characters it can be some predefined
characters some quantifiers you can also
create subgroups within the regular
expression so there is a like i said
there is a tons of functionality which
is available in this particular concept
and we will just cover some of the
relevant ones or just run through some
of these concepts and then i will switch
to a demonstration for example if we
talk about the string literals then you
can do the string matching for example
if you want to find this particular word
or this pattern this is just a text
pattern right so if you would like to
find this particular text pattern in the
text string then you can write this
particular text pattern as a string
pattern inside the pattern object so
that's that's about the string literals
now let's move to some interesting ones
like like meta characters and the meta
characters are very interesting because
they have a special meaning for example
if you write your regular expression
like this where you say cat and then you
say dot then when you are applying this
particular regular expression to find
the match into a string it is only going
to find the match for c a t it is not
going to find the match for c a t dot
because dot is a meta character in
regular expression it has a special
meaning it it does not mean dot but it
has a special meaning and that special
meaning basically means that even though
the dot is not present it will basically
mean that after cat it can be any
character so the meta character dot
means any character which is why you see
this snatch succeeds because it will
search for this pattern which it matches
and after that it can be any character
it doesn't care so even if it's s or d
or whatever it will say true because c80
was found a match so dot means any
character after the pattern you have
specified similarly there are a lot of
other characters special characters are
meta characters like the ones which have
been listed here question mark star plus
dot on and all of these have their own
dedicated special meaning they are not
your your normal uh arithmetic operators
or other operators they have their
special meaning when you are dealing
with meta characters so do read about
them in detail and i will be using a bit
of meta characters in the example as
well then the character classes are also
very interesting uh similar to the
example which i told you before if you
want to find a particular string or a
particular integer into a into a text
corpus then you can use the character
class patterns for example you just put
a square brackets and you write abc this
means that it will try to find exactly
abc in the string if you put a cap in
front of abc then it will try to match
any character or find any character
except a b or c so it's a negation
similarly if you specify small a to z
and capital a to z it means any
character can be there between small
case a to z and capital case a to z a to
z inclusive similarly you can provide
specific ranges like a through d or m
through p so only the characters which
will match the union of this condition
will be returning true and rest of the
if that if this particular
pattern is violated then you will get
false so similarly there are you can
build lot of complex combinations and
permutations with these uh special meta
characters and character classes do read
about these in detail if you are curious
to know about it and there is tons of
materials available on this on internet
which you can read about to learn more
about similarly there are predefined
character classes as well dot is
something which i already explained
which means any character then you can
use slash d to find a digit in a
particular string or a particular text
corpus slash capital d is for non-digit
or you can use the classic negation
condition as well slash s is for a white
space character slash capital s is for a
non-white space character word non-word
so there are a lot of different examples
so i think by now you would have built a
decent understanding of what i'm trying
to tell you is that you can specify
these patterns compile them and then use
the matcher so let's move to a very
simple demonstration it's not a complex
example but very simple example just to
get the point across so i'm creating a
regex string here and this is the
pattern i've specified i'm saying any
character star means any number of
characters so it can be anything here
then the string the the pattern expects
an alphabetical
string or alphabetical section after
that the alphabetical section should be
followed by a numerical section and
after the numerical section again it can
be any character so this is my pattern i
create a simple string with this regex
pattern and like i mentioned in the
documentation you call pattern.compile
to compile the regular expression so i
compile the regular expression i get the
pattern object and after again as per
the documentation it said that you can
call the matcher method on the pattern
object to get a matcher object so i say
pattern dot matcher and i provide my
string on which i want to test it so
i've just put a random string where
there are some integers then there is
some alphabets and then again there are
some integers once you have got the
matcher object just call matcher dot
find this will return a boolean where
you can test whether the uh the matcher
found a hit in the text corpus or not if
it found a match the match found will be
true and if it didn't found find the
match you will get a false value in this
result so with that understanding let's
run this program so i get the output
match found why did i get that because i
said that start with anything so it
started with anything i don't care what
it is it's an integer or any special
character i don't care after that there
should be some alphabets so there are
some alphabets and right after alphabets
there should be some numbers so again
there are some numbers and after that
there can be any character 0 or more
characters so there is nothing here
that's why you see a match found let's
do an interesting test here let me do
this i put a to z again here so now i'm
saying start with anything have
alphabets have numbers and again after
numbers you should have some alphabet
which is not the case here because you
start with something you have alphabets
you have numbers and after numbers the
string ends there is nothing after that
so let's see what happens now you get a
match not found because this particular
pattern when got compiled and got
applied on this particular string did
not find the string following the regex
pattern which we have specified so this
is a very simple example to show you how
you can build patterns you can use
groups concepts as well to group the
patterns it can get very very complex
and very very nasty so use them very
wisely very carefully
and do read about the documentation and
other examples which i talked about to
get more understanding and more
comfortable with regex let's get started
with spring framework so spring
framework is the most popular web
application framework available out
there today and all of the big companies
from netflix to whatnot use spring
framework to build the modern day java
applications so before we go any further
let's understand why do we need a
framework so let's understand this with
the help of a diagram so let me just
open a blank paint page and let me show
you what i mean by a framework and why
do we need this so we built simple
applications so far but if you have to
build a enterprise grid web application
you will have a front end probably where
you will have what you see in the
browser so you will have the html the
javascript or or any other
java enterprise edition classes like gsp
servlet etc then you will have a back
end where your java classes are present
which contains the business logic so the
business logic and then you have a
database where you have the you store
the basic basically the whole data so
you have these three different layers we
also call this a three tier architecture
so you cannot build all of this by just
using the core java classes which we
talked about you need to
do more integrations you need to use
more different programming languages and
concepts to build a complete enterprise
grid application and if you try to build
all of this by yourself then it's going
to take a lot of time and lot of effort
that's why we have frameworks which
basically create provide the structure
to create these three layers so that's
why we have this frameworks and in the
frameworks spring is the most popular
framework it provides the structure to
write all these these three layers one
of the reasons i did not talk about the
the java enterprise edition technology
technologies like servlets and gsps
because nobody works on them today even
if you learn about servlet it's good to
know the conceptual overview of servlets
but nobody today builds applications on
jsps and servlets that's the reason i
did not talk about it because today we
have sophisticated front-end frameworks
like angularjs or react.js or amber js
and whatnot and it is hydrating at a
very fast speed so there is literally
practically no need for a java developer
today to learn about gsp because i can
bet you on that you can take it in
written for me nobody is going to build
the jsp app based applications in 2021
everybody is going to use some sort of
front-end framework to build that and
then you have a back end in the back end
you have the exact core java classes
like i just explained so you will be
using the java beans and you will be
basically using the pure java concepts
of collections and and etc to write the
backend logic using the java classes and
then you will need a jdbc connection to
write to a database as well so you would
need a database as well and spring
provides connectors and
specifications to support all of these
three layers that's the reason so
generally when you talk about a web
application let's talk about web
application because java primarily is
used in web applications so in a web
application you basically see a browser
window where you load a particular page
but what happens behind the scene this
browser has some html and some js maybe
and this code is basically calling some
end point this endpoint is present in
the backend layer so this endpoint is
present in the backend layer that end
point transfers the control to the
business layer where you have your core
business logic written and then the
business layer
transfers the control to the
data layer or some people also call it
dow layer this dow layer then talks to
the database
that's how a web application works and
that's what that's the architecture you
will mostly be following whenever you
are building any enterprise grid
application in any organization so
spring provides support for all of these
parts this obviously is written by
angular and react and other frameworks
but this is this whole section is
basically presented or supported by
spring so with that let's understand a
bit more about spring framework so if
you go to the spring official website it
talks about some of the value
propositions spring is used heavily like
i said it's used everywhere it's very
flexible framework there are a couple of
concepts which spring provides which is
around inversion of control and
dependency injection and i will talk
about these concepts in a while uh
when we'll talk more about the springs
components it makes uh it's quite
productive and quite fast as well so
it's very fast to build application on
on spring it has a whole dedicated
security module as well so it's quite
secure by design and the spring
community is huge so you can find lot of
support on internet let's learn bit more
about the springs core components or
core technologies so if you talk about
the springs core components these are
the springs core components so you have
a testing module you have you have a
core module first of all inside the
techno in the core components you have a
core module which has ioc containers
resources events i will talk a bit about
that it has a it has its own testing
component so it provides very good
support for testing applications it has
a data access component the data access
component is used to provide connections
utilities to the database because like i
mentioned your application will be
talking to the database and spring
provides a a complete dedicated
component to be used whenever you are
dealing whenever you are talking to the
database it also provides a web servlet
component uh to uh provide support for
spring mvc which i will be covering in
the next session websockets and stomp
and messaging frameworks etc it also
supports reactive or asynchronous
programming if you want to do that it
provides a lot of integration
capabilities in the integration modules
if you want to do gms or jmx or email or
task scheduling etc and it also provides
language support to support
internationalized internationalization
of the applications so
it has a lot of different components but
we will focus on this core component
which is of the interest here so let's
talk about that the first thing which
you need to know about string is its
support for inversion of control and it
provides that support by creating an
inversion of control container what do
we mean by inversion of control the
basic idea is let me
take any random example and i will be
able to communicate the idea behind this
so let's go to any simple example which
i have already covered let's go to
method calling for example so we had a
student class we created a student class
simple student class three properties
constructor and public getters and
setters and then i created a main class
and i initialized the student object so
to the responsibility of creating the
student object lies with the student
class itself student class have to be
explicitly initialized to be having an
object of the student so this creates a
problem because when you're dealing with
enterprise grade frameworks you might
need to create lot of objects on the fly
whenever the
end point is talking to the business
layer
if i take the reference of this
architecture if the endpoint is talking
to the business layer classes business
layer classes are talking to the data
access layer classes so when the
business layer classes needs to talk to
the data access layer classes the data
access layer classes needs to have an
object because that communication
happens between objects only so who
creates those objects if every time the
data access object has been uh has been
called and if we provide
if we pass that responsibility to the
dao class to create the object or every
time the end point talks to the business
class we ask the business layer to
create the objects it becomes a lot of
painful process because every time you
will be doing this new student
everywhere you need a student object
which is very painful process so what
spring says it says okay involved the
control of creating the object so let's
not give the responsibility of creating
the object to the class let's give that
responsibility to the framework so the
framework will be responsible for
creating the objects of a class and it's
not the class who will be responsible
for creating its own objects so
generally outside the framework a class
is responsible for getting its object
but with spring spring inverts this
responsibility that's why we call it
inversion of control the control is
inverted it's reversed and now it's the
frameworks responsibility to create the
objects you will also hear about a
concept called dependency injection a
lot in context of ioc and dependency
injection is an implementation of the
ioc concept so using springs dependency
injection mechanism you can inject the
object of any class into any class once
you do that spring dependency is going
to use the inversion of control concept
and create the object that's about ioc
and di or dependency injection then the
other modules like resources will
provide a way to refer different files
and properties if you want to then you
have a validation module as well which
will provide different validation
constructs because once you receive the
data you might need to run a lot of
validation right and writing the
validation by yourself can be very
painful so it provides a validation
framework as well by providing the
validator interface you can use this
particular framework to write the
validation rules checking the name not
empty etc similarly it also supports an
expression language if you want to use
that so the expression language support
is wide very wide in fact you can create
an expression parser and you can do the
expression language evaluation using the
uh a spring expression language
similarly it also provides support for
aspect-oriented programming now again
all these concepts of validation and
spring expression language and resource
support the you probably would need
hours of reading to learn about these
concepts and i'm just running through
them just to tell you about these
concepts and do read about why do you
need resources why do you want to do
validation why do you need an expression
language what is aspect oriented
programming read about all of those
concepts because they are not related to
java they are generic concepts which
will be applicable to any programming
language so any enterprise application
you build in any programming language
you would need to do the validation you
would need to do the resource reference
management you would need to have an
expression language you would need to
have aspect oriented programming support
so this is just to tell you that that
java does provide an aop or aspect
oriented programming support as well and
it has a lot of
apis available for that along with that
it also provides very good logging
capabilities because you definitely need
to log all the actions which the
framework or your objects are taking so
this was a very quick lightning overview
about spring i understand it's not
possible to cover all the concept of a
framework as sophisticated and as smart
as spring in in 10 to 15 minutes lecture
so treat this as an introduction session
and like i said read more about all of
these components i just explained the
core because this is this is sort of the
main building block of spring framework
and then you have other supporting uh
components as well so do check out the
documentation there are tons of examples
available in fact in the springs
official website itself if you go to the
spring guide section if you go to the
learn and you go to the guide section
there are awesome getting started and
topical guides and tutorials available
so for example how to build a restful
web service how to schedule tasks how to
consume a restful web service how to
build a simple java project with maven
how to upload files with string how to
do messaging with redis which is
basically a caching framework how to do
messaging using spring to rabbit mq
rabbit mq is a messaging framework so
there are tons of examples available
here very good documentation and very
robust documentation do check out the
examples to learn more about this let's
get started with mvc and the
implementation of mvc using spring so
before we go any further let's first
understand what do we mean by an mvc
application so in the previous lectures
i discussed about the three tier
application where you had a presentation
layer you had a business layer and then
you had a database layer which is
talking to the database and that's how
we built a three-tier application which
can also evolve into an end-tier
application but when when the web
development started the most popular
concept which came out was
v c m stands for model v stands for view
and c stands for controller so the idea
was that these three components together
can render a web application and how
they render the web application is
basically that the controller is going
to receive the request which is coming
from the web browser then the controller
will have the knowledge of where the
business logic for that particular
request will be residing so the
controller is going to invoke the model
the corresponding model which is
required to execute the business logic
of the request and the controller will
also have the knowledge of what response
page to be sent back to the user so we
are talking about the response page here
not response remember that because it's
a web application so the model view
controller architecture basically was
designed uh to keep in mind that you
have a web application where a request
is coming from and you need to process
some business logic and then you need to
return back with a page response which
is going to be displayed on the web
browser of the client machine so that's
why we had these three components as
model view and controller controller
taking up the request then finding the
right model for it which can execute the
business logic and then also finding the
right view for it which can render the
business logic processed by the model so
that's a quick overview about model view
controller or mvc architecture do read
about it in detail to understand how
this works but like i mentioned that mvc
the most popular mvc implementation is
provided by spring spring is the most
popular mvc framework and the way spring
implements it is something which i have
drawn already here so let's understand
how this works so first the request
comes from the web browser and spring
has uh the a very first welcome servlet
which is called dispatcher servlet any
request which is coming to the spring
enabled web application will first hit
dispatcher servlet and once the request
comes to the dispatcher servlet the
dispatcher servlet has all the knowledge
of all the controllers of all the view
resolvers which i will talk about in a
while and of all the views as well it
also has knowledge about handler
mappings which again i will just discuss
now so the basic premise is that
dispatcher servlet is the component
which has knowledge about literally
everything happening in your application
and that's why dispatcher servlet is the
first servlet or the first component
which receives your web request so once
the request comes here first of all it
looks at the path and finds out the
right handler for it the right
controller for it and the way it does
that by using the handler mapping
component or handler mapping logic which
is provided out of the box by spring
framework so the handler mapping logic
will tell the dispatcher servlet which
particular controller is going to
process the request which is coming
because every request will have a
different controller return so whatever
the type of request is whatever the path
of the request is based on that the
dispatcher servlet is going to find a
particular controller once the
controller is found like i mentioned
earlier the controller will have
knowledge about the right model to
invoke for that particular request model
is nothing
but basically a java class holding the
business logic for this particular
request so it will invoke that java
class and get all the business logic
processed and then it is going to return
a model and view object view is here
simply pointing to the ui response which
you are going to send back to the user
it can be a jsp page it can be an html
page it can be any other view technology
so anything which is
which is used to render a web
application on a web page is view and
controller is going to send both the
model and view information back to the
dispatcher servlet the dispatcher
servlet will take the view part of it
and go to another component which is
again provided by spring which is called
view resolver the view resolver will
have the knowledge to see which
particular actual jsp or template to
invoke for the view value coming from
the controller so based on the value
which is returned by the controller a
view resolver is going to return the
right page mapping and once the
dispatcher servlet knows the page
mapping it is just going to invoke that
page by calling the view component so
dispatcher servlet handler mapping
controller view resolver and view these
five components together help render a
web mvc application in the spring
framework so that was about the theory
of how spring works now let's move on to
uh example to understand how this works
in action so here i have already built a
spring mvc application and if you're
wondering how to build that there's an
easy way to do that using spring
initializer and that's also the
recommended way actually if you go to
the documentation of spring you will see
that it recommends creating a new
project from scratch using the spring
initializer utility which is provided by
spring out of the box so just go to web
a web browser and ta and type start dot
spring dot io you will get this page
where you can specify what type of
project you want to create so it is
going to create the basic skeleton for
any spring application automatically for
you it's probably like i said it's
probably the fastest way to get started
with spring so we will choose a maven
project maven is again a dependency
management tool which is used to
download any kind of jars for your
application so we are going to use a
maven project and we want to create a
skeleton for a java application we are
going to use the latest released version
of spring or spring boot which is 2.4.2
it says spring boot here but don't get
confused with it we are going to use
just the mvc classes and not the spring
boot specific logic yet then you provide
your group artifact id and the name for
your jar you provide a description you
can provide a welcome package name
whatever suits you and then how you
would like to run your application
whether you would like to package your
application as a jar file which is a
java archive or you would like to run it
as a web archive which is a var file so
you can choose either packaging mode and
it is going to add appropriate
dependencies inside the project to
support the packaging of jar or the
packaging of var then you can also
choose the java version so you can see
there are three java versions listed
here which are 8 11 and 15 so whichever
java version you are working on you can
choose that particular version and once
you have set all with everything just
hit generate once you do that it is
going to create a project here and then
you can import this project just as a
normal project inside the eclipse ide
and that's exactly what i've done for
this initial project which is showing a
very basic hello world sort of example
for how spring mvc will work so this
whole structure will automatically be
created for you and like i said it was a
maven project and in every maven project
you will have a palm.xml if i double
click on this it is going to open this
xml and it will list down all the
dependencies which my project needs to
have let's understand the dependencies
as well so this project is currently
using the properties of 1.8 but that's
and that's fine you can obviously
definitely change this value i just kept
it as 1.8 for now because i'm not using
any new functionality yet in the
dependencies section you will see all
the dependencies or all the jars which
are required by the spring application
to run successfully the first dependency
we see here is about daimy leaf and
daimy leaf basically is a view
technology similar to jsp or similar to
servlets
technically where you can supply use
this dye my leaf templates which are
basically just htmls with some dynamic
values and you can use these dimi leaf
templates to render web pages for your
spring mvc application if you want to
use some other view technology you need
to include the dependency of that view
technology here instead of dye my life
so that's about that then you need to
include the spring boot starter web the
spring boot starter web is going to
enable your application to become a web
application then this is this is a this
is basically a good to have dependency
which you can have in your project which
will help you deploy the project at
runtime automatically without restarting
the server because the web application
will be running on a
server on a web server basically or an
application server technically because
it needs to run somewhere so that it so
that clients can access it that's how a
web client architecture works or the
server client architecture works so this
dependency will allow you to deploy
changes dynamically at runtime without
restarting the server then this
dependency is for tests if you're
writing any unit tests and then you have
a plugin which will allow to run this
particular project with a single command
which we will see in a while so that's
about the dependency tour now let's look
at what is in the src main java in the
src main java i just have two classes
one is the main class which will have a
public static void main method and this
is the entry point of this spring
application and then i have a controller
class i already talked about what
controller is but i will come back to
that in a while let's understand the
rest of the files as well the next one
is src main resources where you will
have your view technology data available
like i mentioned it is using dye my leaf
templates currently and basically like i
said they are technically htmls with
some dynamic data so i've created a
templates folder under src main
resources which will automatically be
generated by spring initializer and then
under templates i have placed an html
file it's a pure html file with the only
difference is this value so this is what
the dynamic value means which which is
supported by dimer leaf templates
otherwise this is pure html it's just a
paragraph with a header and this is the
dynamic value which i am populating it
also has application.properties which
has nothing but you can use this
particular file to supply environment
specific properties for the development
environment or the testing environment
or the real production environment if
you have any unit tests those will go
here under src test java and this is the
system library already provided
supported by eclipse itself and i
already talked about the palm.xml you
also see couple of more files created by
springboot if you want to use that you
can use that to run the run the program
from the command line as a utility
otherwise you can just use ambient
spring boot command which i will show
you in a while there's also a gradle
folder which you can ignore probably we
don't need this because we are just
using maven and we are not using gradle
gradle is another dependency management
tool very very similar to maven so you
can ignore this folder right now so
that's the structure and now let's come
back to the controllers remember i told
you that controllers are the ones which
receive the request so from the
dispatcher servlet which i talked about
here after the dispatcher servlet the
request comes to the controller so once
you hit a particular url then you need
to create a controller for that url
mapping remember that you need to create
a controller for almost every url
mapping you are having in your
application there should be some mapping
to some controller somewhere so i've
created a greeting controller and the
way you specify or you make a simple
class as a controller is by putting the
add the red controller annotation this
is the annotation which is supported by
spring and you can put this annotation
on top of any class and that class will
be treated as controller by spring and
the moment the moment you put this this
class will also be registered with the
dispatcher servlet and like i mentioned
the controller's main purpose is to
receive the requests the web requests
which are coming from the client and the
way you can receive the requests to a
controller by providing the exact url
mapping so if somebody runs this web
application and says
slash greeting then this particular
method should get invoked and how you
define that is with the get mapping
annotation use the get mapping
annotation to provide the url path
whenever somebody invokes this url path
this method would be getting called and
when this method is getting called at
that same time this url can also accept
some query parameters we call that as
the request parameters in in the spring
language so you can use the request
parameters as an annotation to provide a
placeholder for the variable for which
the value will be supplied in the url so
slash greeting if if you call this url
something like this
then it will work because you have a
variable called name which is which is
being parsed as a query string because
you have used the request paramentation
so we'll see an example of that when
once we run this application and how we
can supply the query string but you use
the request param annotation to supply
the query string parameters to the url
you can mention if the parameter is
mandatory or non-mandatory if the
required equal to true was there then
this parameter would be mandatory you
can also supply a default value if
somebody is if the client is not
providing this query parameter at all
would you like to set any default value
if yes you can supply the default value
here and then you just give a
placeholder name like i said then the
second argument which your your methods
which are intercepting the request
should have is the model argument and
remember i told you that the controller
will have what should have the knowledge
about the model and from here that
knowledge comes you this particular
method will expect you to provide a
model argument as well so if somebody
calls this application and provides the
urls with slash greeting this particular
method will get invoked and then the
code inside this method will be getting
executed so it's a very simple code
right now but this is where your whole
logic will go remember that but here i'm
just saying model dot add attribute name
with the value which is coming from the
query string parameter that's all i'm
doing here and
remember i told you that the model will
hold the business logic so here this is
the business logic where whatever query
string parameter which is coming from
the request param i'm capturing that and
i'm adding that value with the variable
name in the attributes of the model so
my model is set and after that i need to
return the view so that this particular
file name will be intercepted by the
view resolver here if you remember we
talked about the view resolver so when
we return
the greetings as a string that string
goes here and then dispatcher servlet
looks out asks the view resolver to find
a particular html matching with this
particular text so view resolver is
going to look at under src main
resources slash templates to see if
there is a file with the name greeting
available or not since we have that file
available the spring is going to render
this particular file supplying the model
attribute value name now remember the
greeting.html had the exact same
variable name so this variable name
should exactly match
with this variable name here if you do
if you make a mistake here this is not
going to work because the model is
holding the business logic and i'm
printing that business logic inside the
view using the dye my lift template
syntax which is dollar curly braces so
whenever you have to print any variable
or a model attribute or any runtime
value inside a dhammalife template then
you need to use the dollar curly braces
syntax to do that so that was about a
quick overview of how this application
is is written right now and that's all
the code is here now it's time to run
this application so one of the simplest
way to run this application would be to
provide a spring at the run
configuration here for the spring
application or you can choose another
way which is to first have a look at the
spring web content application which is
the entry point so once your application
boots up this is the first line of code
which is going to get executed and to
make sure that this code works make sure
that you have the add the red spring
boot application annotation on top of
the entry point class so this is this is
sort of the mandate which spring will
force you to put in front of the or on
top of the entry point class to to treat
this class as the first entry point when
you run the project so to run the
project what we will do that we will
just go to the command line and we will
say mvn spring boot run so let's do that
and let me open the terminal for that so
i have opened a git bash prompt here you
can also open the classic windows
terminal but this is something which git
installs by default if you install git
on your system it's pretty much exactly
the same it's just more unix-like but
it's also just a simple terminal shell
utility to access your file system so i
have gone to the project which we were
working with in the eclipse ide and this
is the path of the project so once you
reach to the path what you would like to
run is just say mvn
spring hyphen boot colon run that's it
and you hit enter once you write mvn
sprinkle hyphen boot call and run you
will see lot of code lot of logs here
where it is going to run all the compile
all the java classes run any tests if
there are any and then it is going to
start the web content application you
can see and once the application is
started you will get this message that
everything is run one of the interesting
thing which you can see here is that it
is also spinning up an application
server automatically for you and that
application server here which is being
used by spring is apache tomcat
technically apache tomcat is a servlet
container and it's not a full fledged
application server but just to get the
point across you can use apache tomcat
as an application server which is being
used here
out of the box by spring if you don't
want to use apache tomcat and you want
to use something else you can do that as
well so now everything is ready and we
can now execute the application to
observe the output so for that let me
open a fresh browser window so that we
don't get any cached response and now i
can just type localhost 8080 and if i
hit entry enter i i get a white level
error page because there is no home page
for tomcat defined but there is a home
page for my application defined in fact
let's try to access the url which we
wrote in the greeting controller the url
was slash greeting so let's copy this
and let's put this here so
localhost8080
greeting and if i hit enter i get the
message hello world let me just zoom
this in a bit so that you can see so you
will see this hello world message here
by putting this url why do we see hello
world let's go back to the controller so
when you call this url this greeting
controller got invoked since we did not
provide any query string parameter the
default value which was world was picked
up and this world value was stored in
the name variable and the name variable
was added as an attribute to the model
and then we were using the greeting.html
and we were printing the name variable
since the name variable was holding the
value world so the message came as hello
world
with an exclamation and that's the
output which we see here now let's try
to supply the query query string
parameter the way you do that is provide
a question mark provide the key of the
query string parameter and the value you
want to put here so let's put simply
code as a value and hit enter so now the
message got changed and now it says
hello simply code so what happened here
is that whatever con query string
parameter we supplied that got passed
here at par as part of the request param
and the value of simply code got stored
in this name key and in turn in this
name variable and then i added the same
value into another name attribute and
added that attribute to the model so now
this name here is storing the value
simply code and then the all the things
work exactly is the same as i just
described it goes to greeting.html and
it prints whatever is stored in the name
attribute coming from the model let's
get started with spring boot and how we
can build a simple application using
spring boot before we go further let's
understand why we need spring boot and
the basic idea of spring boot is to
build restful web services if you want
to know more about what are restful
services please you can read about the
restful concept as a concept what does
rest stand for but the basic idea is
that if you are accessing anything over
http then that particular component can
be built as a restful component and
spring boot is the most popular choice
for building restful web services today
and even in fact microservices which you
might have heard about so you can build
microservices which also run on https
using spring boot so what i'm showing
you right now is the official guide of
spring which you can use to build an
application with spring boot it will
list down all the requisites which you
need in terms of the
jdk installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same springs initializer
which i talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an ide where i have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc we had an src main
resources folder and that src main
resources folder was having all the web
components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the html but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure xml or it can
be pure json but you do not send back
and view and that's the main difference
between spring mvc and spring boot that
in spring mvc it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a dye my
life template which is basically in html
you can also written a gsp but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using html or whatnot what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
spring boot was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar there's a palm.xml here
which will provide all the list of jars
and dependencies which are required for
this particular project so you can see
all the dependencies here pretty much
the similar ones we have a starter web
we have a starters test and we have a
spring boot maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and spring boot
will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example that
we are just printing all the beans which
are provided by spring that's all we are
doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and introductory session so
we will keep the logics to minimum and
i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
you get the bean definition you get that
with this application context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say spring application dot run
and you supply application dot class
with any command line arguments which
you might want to use once you do this
it is going to return an application
context object to you and the
application context object can be used
to get all the bean definitions by
calling this method which says get bean
definition names so that's the basic
logic which is being run in the main
class now we also have a controller but
this time it's not a web controller but
it's a rest controller so you see in the
previous example we just had written
something like this it was just a pure
controller but here we have become more
specific we are saying that hey this is
not a simple mvc controller but this is
a string boot controller or technically
a rest controller so spring provides a
separate annotation for that which is at
the rate rest controller so you write
that particular annotation or that on
the top of the controller class which
you are creating and then you provide a
request mapping similar to what we did
in spring mvc but while you return it
you do not return a view technology you
just return the raw response here i'm
just returning a string but you can
return a json object you can return an
xml object or whatever you want to but
not a view technology that's what i'm
doing like like you can see there's
literally nothing i'm doing in this it's
just a simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes okay so that was all about
what i have written in the project and
now it's time to run the project so i
have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the project
bom.xml was present and
if i just do an ls you will see that
there is a palm.xml available here and
all the code directly is also available
here so now i will just run this
application and to run this application
i'm just going to type mvn spring hyphen
boot colon run and hit enter once i do
that the spring application is going to
spring boot application is going to get
started and let's go back to uh the
controller and actually the main app
main end point and see what we were
doing there i did a cis out here which
said let's inspect the beans provided by
spring boot and then i was printing all
the bean names and if i go back to the
output i will see the same line being
written here which was around let's
inspect the beans so you can see that
message which says let's inspect the
beans provided by spring boot and then
all the beans which are available in the
application context are printed here so
that's that's the basic idea which i
want to give you that you can actually
build a spring boot application and you
can write your rest controllers return a
string body from it and once this is run
then you can also run your application
for from the web browser as well so
let's try to hit that particular url
which i wrote here so the url of hello
so for that let me just open a new
cognito window and our application is
already running so if i just say http
localhost 8080 slash i get this message
here which says greetings from spring
boot and this is the message which we
were sending from the rest controller so
this validates our understanding that we
can invoke a rest controller which is a
spring boot rest controller via the same
method but this time we are not getting
an html but we are just returning this
particular string now you can use the
string in any ways you want so it
depends upon the consumer so that's all
i want to cover as part of the spring
boot now spring boot is a huge huge
topic and we can spend hours and hours
talking about spring boot but since this
is more of an introductory session so i
just wanted the concept to get
introduced and remember the value
proposition of why you would need spring
boot the basic idea is to build restful
web services or build restful micro
services that's the basic idea behind
using spring boot in your applications
and also remember the difference between
web mvc spring mvc application and
spring boot application spring mvc is
for building web application spring boot
is for building restful applications
which might not have a web interface
integrated with them at that moment so
that's all i want to cover for this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to have a look at
an advanced java project using some of
the concepts which we might have learned
during this whole journey and that would
be the last session of this particular
tutorial series let's get started with
our demo of a project which is using
spring boot to build a restful web
service so a restful web service is
nothing but any end point which you can
access or you can consume the data from
via an http layer or via a simply a web
layer because most of the web traffic
which we deal with is built on http so
to take an example if you go to any
website where you sometimes see on the
top right corner you see today's weather
so how is that today's weather coming in
it's coming in via a rest web service
the website which you are accessing is
basically hitting an http endpoint which
is
where the where the weather application
is sitting and it asks for the weather
data and the dressed web application
just returns the data and that's how the
website is able to show you the current
weather so restful web services are
everywhere and they are the most popular
way to build applications today where
you just build your restful web service
and you expose an http url and then the
consumers need to just access that http
url to consume the data from your
application and you see this makes it
very easy because there is no data type
restrictions there is no tight coupling
here it's just an http endpoint so
that's the basic idea and we will look
at a project where we will be using
spring boot to build a restful web
service and then we will try to run that
web service to save some data and also
to return some data so here on the on
the package explorer you see i have
created a project called rest service
and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an src main
java where i have a package and i have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project needs some dependencies some
jars to execute it for example spring
itself is basically a jar so you need to
include the spring jar in your project
so that your project can become a spring
project and there are generally two
dependency tools one is maven and one is
gradle in this particular project i am
using maven
dependency tool for downloading and
managing the dependencies which are
needed to run this project successfully
and the way you will find if it's a
maven project or if it's a gradle
project for a maven project you will see
a file called
pom.xml pom.xml and if it's a gradle
project you will see a dot gradle file
that's how you can spot whether the
project is using maven for dependency
management or it is using gradle for
dependency management so let's open the
palm.xml since it's an xml file it will
be a bit verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand first
of all since this is a spring project i
need to include the parent dependency
which brings lot of good defaults
sensible defaults from spring boot
automatically and this is the jar name
this is the artifact id which is spring
boot starter parent so any spring boot
project you are starting do include this
parent this parent is basically bringing
all the dependencies from some other jar
and you can make your project as a as a
child of this particular parent so all
these spring
board projects have this as a parent as
a standard practice after that you
provide your own details in terms of
what is the package name how do you want
to see the jar name on what is the jar
actual name what is the jar version etc
etc you also set the minimum required
java version to run this application and
then you in the dependency sections you
provide all the jars which you need to
run your project successfully both
compile and run your project
successfully so we added the spring boot
starter web on dependency which
basically brings all the dependencies
around making a controller or making a
repository
context component scan all the
interesting features which spring
provides get wrapped up inside the
spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so i'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need java to talk to the
database and the way spring suggests to
talk to the database is why are using
the spring boot data jpl library we will
see this how this library can be used
but basically this provides ways to
represent your java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an
in-memory h2 database so i'm not using
an external database like mysql or
oracle or post sql because that will
just make more configurations more
complicated i just wanted to keep it
simple and generally you in this h2
database you can easily access by adding
this dependency and it will be an
in-memory database created for you then
i've also added a spring boot starter
test here which will be used whenever
you are writing unit tests and you must
write unit test for your project and
then we need to add the plugin so that
spring boot can run this project that's
all i have in the palm dot xml now let's
move to the interesting part the java
section part let's start from the main
class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create uh any
any name with the class and then you add
a public static void main method inside
the public static void main method you
call spring application dot run and this
run method is basically going to run
your application and you just provide
the same class name which you just wrote
here so you just say dot class and if
you're supplying any command line
arguments it can interpret that command
line arguments as well if you want so
you'd always need an entry point in an
application and this is the entry point
which spring boot supports and this is
if you see this code this is just normal
code to make spring be aware about this
class being treated as an entry point
you need to add add the red spring boot
application annotation on top of the
class this is one of the annotation
which is coming directly from the spring
boot library you can see this import so
once you add this then only spring will
be able to treat this class as an entry
point otherwise spring doesn't know
where to start from so when you run
spring it will fi it will try to find a
class with an annotation spring boot
application and then inside the class it
will try to find a public start a static
void main method and once it has found
both of them then it will just run the
application so very simple nothing fancy
here and what we are dealing with here
is a student object so we will try to
insert a student object and we will try
to retrieve the student object so
if you ignore these annotations which
i've added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object you create
a student class let's ignore this field
as well for now i'll just come back to
this annotation in this field but this
is just a student class it has three
fields as name age and address an empty
constructor and a parameterized
constructor and some getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because generally whenever you are
building any enterprise grade
application you would like to keep your
objects immutable means once they have
been created you would not like somebody
to allow to change the values of the
object this just makes programming but
much more easy if you treat all the
objects in your application as immutable
that's why i have not added setters here
it's just considered a good practice
so apart from the standard things which
we have already seen there are two
things here which i want to talk about
let's first talk about this one so
accurate entity is the annotation which
is coming from java x persistent entity
persistence entity and this makes
springboot save this particular object
into the database this is the annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a id it will have sort
of a primary key so i've created a new
column called id which is basically
representing the student's role number
or something or maybe a registration
number and here i'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java x persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new id to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this id variable springboot
will automatically generate a new id
value every time you create a new
student object and how does it generate
you you can provide the generation type
as well so currently i've just said that
set it as automatic but you can set it
as identity sequence or rate or
controlled by table you can also see the
explanation of each of these here but
i've just kept it as auto which
basically
let the persistence provider pick any
appropriate strategy for the particular
database in our case the database is h2
so that's about the entity class let's
call this as entity class now let's move
to the repository so you need a
repository class
like i explained in dots in that three
tier architecture you always need a
dowel layer or a repository layer to
store your student object into the
database so we have enabled the student
object to be saved but we need a handler
which can save this particular file this
particular object into the database and
the repository classes are the classes
which will allow you to do that so you
create a very simple interface you what
you name whatever you want to name your
interface as and then you say extends
jpa repository the type of the object
and the unique identifier of the object
so the type of the object is student
here and the unique identifier of the
student object is the id which is of
type long so you need to just supply the
types type of the object type of the
primary key or the type of the unique
identifier and this annotation is coming
from spring boot you can see
specifically spring boot data library
which we added so you just need to
create an interface extend it from jp
repository and make sure that you add
this annotation as well spring heavily
uses the concept of annotations and this
will help spring understand that this is
a repository layer class and it will
apply some more metadata to this class
while this class is running in the jvm
so what happens here you just created an
interface you did not provide any method
to create or any method to delete or any
method to get a student object because
all of that is automatically provided by
springboard via the jpa repository class
if we go inside this class and if you
scroll down you will see the find all
method find all find all by id save all
flush save and flush delete etc and if
you go further up this also extends the
paging and sorting repository which
provides pagination and sorting
facilities but the interesting one is
that pages and sorting repository again
extends a crud repository and if you go
to the crud repository you will find all
the basic methods to save an entity save
multiple entities find an entity by the
id that's why it needed that long type
to make sure this that it can execute
this method you can check the existence
of an object find all the entries find
all by id count them delete them so all
the basic crud functionality so we call
them as crud because the reason it is
called because create read update delete
that's the basically the
generic acronym so because uh this
credit repository provides all the
methods and their implementations
automatically we do not need to write
any code at all so that's why springboot
is so awesome and that's why springboard
is very popular because it's zero code
in the repository and you still get all
the crud functionality so that's about
repository now we have covered the
entity class we have covered the
repository class we have covered the
entry point class now the only thing
which is remaining is the is the uh end
point the http endpoint which i talked
about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class and make sure that you put
add the rate rest controller annotation
on top of it this annotation will allow
string to treat this particular class as
an end point class then you can auto
wire the student repository so if you
remember i talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at runtime student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects it's the spring
which will automatically read the
autobot annotation and will
automatically supply an object whenever
it is required then i have two methods
here since we are talking about http
endpoints so i have represented a post
method here and a get method here the
way you will write a post method is via
the ratepost mapping annotation and then
you can provide the url path on which
somebody should call your end point to
save something so for example somebody
can call it http localhost 8080
student create whenever they hit that
url the control or that request will
directly hit this particular method why
because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent its uh
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here i'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular url yes all good but you
need to supply me with a text
representation of the student object or
a json representation of the student
object and then i inside the method i'm
calling student repository dot save
which is going to save the student
object which is coming in so you see
there's a lot going on here i will i
will show you how the student is
represented in the request body as well
and then i will come back to how it got
converted from json to java but this is
how you can store this particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want and keep
inserting a new student object every
time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student and then
in the curly braces there's an id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the id of the student so
generally there would be another method
here which would be find all to see all
the students uh and with their id and
then you can pick a particular student's
id supply that student id value here
dynamically that's why at the curly
braces curly braces supports dynamic
value so here it can insert one two
three or whatever the student id you
want to fetch the value for you provide
that value in the student slash id and
all good then some if somebody is
hitting the url with saying localhost
student slash 1 then student with the id
1 will be returned from the request and
you need to put advert get mapping to
make sure that this method is treated as
an http get method and you can provide
the type you can say get student and
here this dynamic value is captured with
the add the rate path variable because
you need to know the id right whatever
id somebody has supplied in the url you
need to capture that ide and then use
that ide for calling the repository so
that's you can do that by using the add
variate path variable so here i'm just
saying whatever id is coming in i will
store that value inside this ide once
i've done that then i can again call
student repository dot find by id which
is again a built-in method provided to
me by the crud repository i can supply
the id and this actually is going to
return an optional object which is uh
which is an object which may or may not
contain a value so it said just a types
of defensive programming style so this
will return an optional and you can call
a get method to return the actual
student object this will return an
optional of student so option of student
means that this optional object may have
a student or may not have a student why
did spring do that because the id
somebody is supplying that id can be
invalid also right so optional object
tree takes care of that that if there is
no student found then you will not get a
null pointer exception and if there's a
student found you can return that so
it's just a defensive programming style
which spring has adopted by returning an
optional of the student object rather
than directly the student object but if
you're confident that this particular
option of student object does contain a
student object then just call
optional.get which i've called here
which will return the actual student
object sitting inside the optional
object you can read more about the
optional object and its usage uh from
the official java docs and there are
tons of examples available on it on
internet so this is about the controller
uh we have covered all the classes now
it's time to run the application so you
go to the command prompt you go to the
particular
file folder location and there
you just say mvn spring hyphen boot
colon run so i just hit enter and this
is going to
run the application it's going to split
some logs here and if everything is fine
you will not get an error and you will
just be getting a message saying that
application got started and it's running
on tomcat localhost 8080 with no context
url so this is not a web application
this is a rest full web service right
this is a restful service this is not a
web application so there is no web
interface so how do you access this you
just have an http url so you can use any
of the rest client available on the
internet there are probably hundreds of
different clients available on the
internet you can choose any one of them
i am using advanced rest client which
you can also install as an extension
from the chrome browser itself so if you
just if i just open the chrome browser
and i just say rest client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from google play
stores app store so you can go to the
app store that basically the chrome web
store not the play store but the chrome
web store and you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so this is pretty
uh this is not a tutorial for advanced
risk client so i'll just be quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say i want to do a
post and then you can provide the url
here so remember the url which we put
here in the controller method this has
to exactly match so http localhost slash
student slash create should be the url
so let me just copy paste this one here
okay so the url is good here it's a post
type of method which i want to do and i
want to hit this particular url now i
need to supply the content type and the
body so in the content type you can
choose application json because i'm
going to supply a json object and in the
body this is how the json object looks
like advanced risk client also provides
a nice visual interface to basically uh
create this json if you are thinking
that json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough it's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just put an enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting an end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name age and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can send this
particular request when you click send
it is going to hit my spring boot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this json into a java
object because here i'm supplying a java
object so it will convert the json which
i'm sending from here to java object
automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because i've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once i hit send i
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header i get
the object back because i have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created uh so
everything is good here my object has
been stored here and now it's time to
fetch the object so it has already been
saved into the h2 in memory database and
you can obviously go and connect to the
in memory h2 database and have a look at
it but for simplicity i'm just gonna do
this here and let's say the first object
is generally
added as the id one by default by the h2
database so let's hit this particular
url when i hit this url it is going to
hit the student controller here and in
the student controller it is going to
hit the get student method which is
having a student id url and it is going
to find the database with that id and if
it finds a student object with that id
it is going to return that so let's
confirm that now let's hit this
particular send button and it is going
to hit a get request with this
particular url springboard is going to
find if a student with the id 1 exists
in its database
so once i hit send i get a 200 okay and
you see in the response headers i get
the same student object back which i
added let's try with 2 now let's see
what happens i see 2 and i get 500
internal server error because there is
no object stored in the h2 database of
the spring application with the id 2 yet
because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically was one so
when you hit for get request with a
student id one you get the object when
you put any invalid value and you hit
this you get a 500 internal server error
you can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found you can say something like
that or else throw which is again an
optional object and here you can supply
a particular type of exception which you
want to supply instead of just throwing
500 internal server error but that's
just additional thing additional
defensive programming you can do you can
add more and more validations and
constraints into this project as you
build this project in a more complex
paradigm so this is basically what i
wanted to show you that and that we have
created a spring up boot application we
have connected it to a database we
haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller we ran that
application we used any random rest
client in my case i used advanced rest
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you're going to use the
http get method and you again provide a
url which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
id you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid id
you're going to get a 500 internal
server error and from here on you can
make this controller as robust and as
mature as you want you can add find all
method you can add update student method
you can add a delete student method you
can have all different kinds of filters
like for example return to me all the
students starting with the name a or
return all the first
students with the role number one and
hundred are between 100 so you can write
as many endpoints as you want and build
this application in
as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want and that's all i
want to cover in this particular lecture
thank you and we'll meet again in
another session thanks to our training
experts it was really a wonderful
session i hope this session was
informative and interesting if you have
any queries regarding the topics covered
in this particular tutorial then please
feel free to ask in the comment section
below our support team will be happy to
help you out with all your queries until
next time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
we will be discussing java interview
questions we all know that java is one
of the most sought programming languages
in the current iit industry there are
multiple multi-million dollar companies
which are using java till today
so this video is completely dedicated to
help out the java developers and the
beginners in java programming language
to crack the most frequently asked java
interview questions
so without further ado let's begin with
our interview questions
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the byte code
in the runtime
jit or just-in-time compiler compiles
code to machine level directly for
higher speeds of code execution
so basically just-in-time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader
now let's discuss the answer for this
particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute any java
program so the java class loader is the
integrated part of java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders
so the third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java
so the answer for this particular
question is
java provides multiple types of memory
allocations but the five major types of
memory allocations which are most
frequently used are class memory heap
memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is yes because java does not
follow any specific rule for the order
of specifiers you place in your program
so when you execute the program with
such pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare a local variable or a global
variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if you just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question
so what would be the output of the
following code segment is the sixth
question so this might happen sometimes
so basically what happens is your
interviewer will throw a question at you
which has a code segment so all you need
to do is decode that code in your mind
and provide the output so this would be
the code that we will be dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has hundred plus hundred
plus a string which is simply learn and
in the second printf statement we have a
string that is e-learning company plus
100 plus 100 so what will be the output
of these two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and elearning company 1
0 0 1 0 0 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so jvm
here understands 100 as an integer value
and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here so followed by the
addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers hundred plus
hundred so followed by that we have
another plus symbol here so followed by
the plus symbol we have a string value
so here the jvm considers the plus
symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learned similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value so it considered the
plus symbol as a concatenating operator
similarly it happened with the second
plus symbol as well so that's the reason
we had e-learning one zero zero one zero
zero as the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association
so the answer for this question is an
association can be defined as a
relationship that has no ownership over
the other so to understand this
definition we can consider a simple
example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c
and similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and banksy are
associated with the person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x
but the banks do not possess any kind of
ownership over the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface
but normally in interface we provide
some signatures so these signatures
belong to particular methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning
i guess the word object learning is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented so this question might be a
little confusing but it's true java is
not completely object oriented but
what's the reason yes i'll explain you
why java is not completely object
oriented
so the answer for this question is java
is not considered as 100 object oriented
programming language because of the data
types it uses
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are in flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100
object oriented programming language so
the next question is
define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is in
java when you declare primitive data
types that is the end flow double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types
just as we discussed before java is not
100 object-oriented programming language
just because of the primitive data types
it uses so when you include such
primitive data types then wrapper
classes are the ones which convert them
into objects or reference types for the
ease of compilation and execution of
programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes so followed
by that we have our next question that
says define package in java so if you
use some of the popular ides that is the
integrated development enterprises such
as intellij or eclipse then you might be
familiar with projects packages source
files and then the class file so
basically you create a project first and
inside the project you will be having
your source folder and then you will be
creating your own package using the
source folder and inside the package you
will create a class file and inside the
class file is where you write your java
program so here the question is define
package in java so the answer for this
question is as follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and jar files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember
c programming language we had pointers
there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no
because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implicitly so java's major
motive was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
implement pointers in java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool
so for example you wanted to create a
new string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string port if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there then the jvm will create a new
string that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program
so for example just consider that you
are going to write a program for
division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
0 or any other sort of input so if this
kind of input is provided to your
program then your program might crash so
you can avoid this kind of crash by
using exception handling so basically
you can use try and catch blocks so you
can embed your code inside the try block
and say to your program that if any kind
of wrong input such as special symbol or
zero is provided by the evaluator then
send a message saying wrong input or
divide by zero exception so this kind of
approach will provide an output but this
kind of approach will avoid your program
from crashing so this is how exceptions
are handled in real time so followed by
this we have our next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable
will remain constant throughout the
execution of program so sometimes if you
include a normal variable and
provide an operation on that particular
variable then the value of that
particular variable will change after
the execution of program but when you
declare the same variable using final
keyword then no number of operations or
any kind of manipulations applied onto
that variable will not change the value
of that particular variable so that's
the speciality of final keyword in java
so followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method don't forget to specify the
static keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions followed by the
beginners segment we have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is
so jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets
oracle has the following variants for
java development kit
so the first one is the jdk standard
edition which is normally used by
beginners and intermediate developers
next after the jdk standard edition we
have the java development kit for
enterprise
so this particular enterprise edition is
used by professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition now followed by 21st
question we will dive into the next
question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only
and finally we have the protected access
specifier
so the protected access specifier is a
bit more secure than the private access
specifier so the access for this
particular protected data member or
protected data manipulating method could
be a little more difficult to access
unless you are going to implement
everything which is present in that
particular package
so basically if you are trying to access
the protected data member or protected
data manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically so finally after the major
three axis specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
java virtual machine so in case if you
declare a variable or a data
manipulating method without using any
specific access specifiers that are
public private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is
can a constructor return a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but
automatically it returns the instance of
a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable
so the term this keyword is used to
refer to the current class properties
like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain super keyword in java so the
answer for this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyboard
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism so now let's have a
correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures using one method name
is called as method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name at so here
you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference
you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method then which method to be
overloaded that's the confusion right so
should i overload or should i execute
the first add method or the second
method so this completely depends on the
number of parameters you pass if you are
passing two parameters then the first
method will be executed if you are
passing three parameters then the second
method will be executed so this is how
the method overloading happens in java
so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before
the values of the variables or data
manipulating methods will not be changed
when we have used the keyword static in
front of it so the question is can we
overload a static method
now let's discuss the answer for this
the answer is no
java does not support overloading of
static method the process worked through
an error reading static method cannot be
referenced so followed by this we have
our next question
so the next question is define
late binding
the answer for this question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the method score
segment
late binding happens when the methods
code segment is unknown till the method
is called during the run time
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the runtime the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in linked
list than an array
so basically linkedlist and array are
the java collections or in other words
it's also considered as data structure
so to answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is a
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations
so consider that your memory location
starts from 100 and your array has 10
locations so it's a complete reserved
block of from 100 101 102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number
then what you do is just to manipulate
the addresses so the address of the
consecutive node will be changed so
that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the delete
function or any kind of manipulation
function is faster in linked list
compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make a minor update
to the point of value so that the node
can point to the next successor in the
list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly born state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
performed the operation of right
shifting so when you provide a binary
number or binary value then the bits
will be shifted towards the right and
the second symbol or the second operator
which is having three greater than
symbols is used to shift out the zero
filled bits so this is the functionality
of these two operators now followed by
that let's have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages the first
stage is the initialization stage next
is the start stage third is the stop
stage fourth is destroy and finally we
have paint
now the next question is why are
generics used in java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify a single method
declaration a set of related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain
externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
right external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization
serialization is a process of sending
your java code or java project from one
computer system to a different computer
system so basically if you wanted to
execute some kind of java program from a
different location then you serialize
this particular code to a different
location where you actually want to
execute and this particular process of
transferring your code is called as
serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
daemon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java
the set daemon method is used to create
the daemon thread in java programming
language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in java
so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class when creating the
objects at low time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called
so the answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the
finalized method just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is can the keywords this and
super
be used together
so the answer for this question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use so with this
let's continue with the next question in
the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain
jdbc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbreviation for java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine after the jsp
page is compiled into a servlet
directives are used to set page level
instructions
insert data from external files and
specify custom tag libraries directives
are defined between the following
symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive
so include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page the page directive is used
to define specific attributes in the jsp
page like error page and buffer the
taglib directory is used to declare a
custom tag library which is used in the
jsp page
followed by that we have the next
question
what are observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative desk
course of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any java application
so the next question is explain jca in
java so the answer for this question is
jca is basically an abbreviation for
java cryptography architecture
so jca provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security
so the next question is
explain j pa in java so the answer for
this question is
jpa stands as an abbreviation for java
persistence api
the jpa is enabling us to create the
persistence layer for desktop and web
applications
jpa deals with the following
java persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form-based authentication in this
particular type of authentication the
login form is made by the programmer by
using html
followed by that we have the third type
of authentication that is digest
authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly we have the client certificate
authentication the client certificate
authentication requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate itself
this requires ssl protocol
now thanks to our training experts with
that we have come to an end of this java
tutorial if you have any queries
regarding the topics covered in this
particular tutorial or if you need the
code documents that have been executed
in this particular tutorial then please
feel free to ask them down in the
comment section below our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
you